nous examinons ce matin chers collègues
la proposition de loi adoptée par le
Sénat encadrant l'intervention des
cabinets de conseil privé dans les
politiques publique la proposition en
question a été déposée le 21 juin 2022
au Sénat par Madame héan Assassi
Monsieur Arnaud Bazin et plusieurs de
leurs collègues et elle a été adoptée
par cette chambre haute le 18 octobre
2022 la Conférence des Présidents a
choisi de l'inscrire à l'ordre du jour
de l'assemblée au cours de la semaine de
l'Assemblée nationale dans une séance
réservée aux initiatives transpartisan
et c'est pourquoi nous avons désigné
deux RPP rteur Monsieur Bruno milen du
groupe démocrate et Monsieur Nicolas
sensu du groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine messieur le rapporteur je
vais vous donner la parole et puis
j'aurai comme les orateurs de groupe
quelques questions à vous poser par la
suite je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègue cher Bruno enfin enfin
cette proposition de loi a trouvé son
chemin pour parvenir à forcer la porte
de l'ordre du jour de notre assemblée
ainsi nous allons faire œuvre utile dans
ce qui doit toujours guider nos travaux
mieux répondre à l'exigence de
transparence de notre vie publique et
donc être garant de l'intérêt général
car les vicissitudes et c'est un
euphémisme de quelques-uns risqueent
toujours de jeter l'eau probre sur tout
le monde la pente dangereuse qui était
celle empruntée depuis des années non du
recours au cabinet conseil qui est
autorisé mais au recours excessif et au
mélange des genres doit être stoppé et
inversé pour deux raisons essentielles
d'abord parce que circonscrire et
interdire les conflits d'intérêt c'est
la condition d'une démocratie qui
fonctionne en ne livrant pas de
carburant aux ennemis de notre
démocratie qui s'en repèent
ensuite parce que notre état a des
compétences remarquables qui ne
demandent qu'à être valorisé dans une
vision de service public qui ne singe
pas systématiquement les méthodes du
privé avec l'intervention des cabinets
conseil comme cheval de TR disant cela
je tiens juste à souligner que les
objectifs ne sont pas les mêmes entre le
privé et le public les indicateurs ne
sauraient être les mêmes en clair l'État
avait participé à son propre désarmement
pour reprendre un concept qui va parler
à nos collègues de la majorité
présidentielle donc il était plus que
temps que nous prenions en main cette
proposition de loi sur notre bureau
depuis près de 14 mois adopté par le
Sénat à une très large majorité en
octobre 2022 avec aucun vote contre ce
n'est pas une lub de nos collègues
sénateurs c'est l'aboutissement de
travaux d'une commission d'enquête
sénatoriale remarquable conduite par
Elien Assassi comme rapporteur et Arnaud
Bazin président sur l'influence des
cabinets de conseil privé sur les
politiques publiques et qui avait fait
grand bruit au printemps 2022 cette
commission d'enquête a cristallisé une
attention qui avait connu des travaux
divers qui seront tous rappelés par par
Bruno milenne et cette profusion de
travaux démontre si besoin était que
l'État ne pouvait plus s'affranchir de
règles de transparence de déontologie de
maîtrise publique dans le cadre de son
recours aux prestations intellectuelles
au-delà même du montant d'un milliard
d'euros de dépenses de conseil couvertes
par l'article 1 le Sénat a surtout
documenté la dynamique inquiétante de ce
recours et a donc réalisé un constat
très tranché en identifiant quatre
difficultés principales l'opacité le
foisonnement incontrôlé la dépossession
de l'État et les risques de
déontologique non maîtrisé ce sont ces
difficultés que la proposition de loi
transpartisane du Sénat et j'insiste
adopté sans aucun vote contre ce sont
ces difficultés que le texte qui nous
est soumis et vous est soumis permet de
dépasser bien sûr le vent du boulet
nétant pas passé trop loin des mesures
correctrices et régulatrices ont été
instaurées par le gouvernement Castex
mise en place d'un jaune budgétaire
règles plus restrictives pour les
accords 4AD de marché public de conseil
de la direction interministérielle de la
transformation public extension des
codes de conduite dans les
administrations centrales tout cela a eu
des effets mais n'enlève nullement la
question majeure de l'influence des
cabinets conseil sur les politiques
publiques et quand on voit les dérives
qui ont existé et celles qui se font
jour dans d'autres grands pays
occidentaux mis en lumière par des
ouvrages comme celui sur minse pour le
meilleur ou pour le pire ou bien celui
intitulé The Big con sorti fin 2023 le
travail que nous allons conduire me
semble essentiel en fait ce que nous
voulons c'est nous assurer que
l'interven des cabinets de conseil aide
à la décision publique et ne prennent
pas sa place c'est pourquoi la
proposition de loi n'interdit pas le
recours au cabinet de conseil mais la
sortie de trois grands principes 1 un
principe de transparence la liste
exhaustive des prestations de conseil
listé à l'article 1 et les montants
budgétaires y afférents serai publiés
chaque année 2 le respect de règles
déontologique renforcé avec notamment
l'interdiction du probonau et le suivi
des données collectées 3 une meilleure
prévention et sanction des conflit
d'intérêts toutes les auditions que nous
avons conduites ont été assorties de la
volonté de rechercher le meilleur
équilibre entre ser principe et la
portée opérationnelle des dispositions
et je veux sincèrement remercier Bruno
milen pour sa bonne humeur et l'esprit
d'ouverture qui l'ont animé j'espère
qu'il aura pris le même plaisir que moi
je le dis en début d'examen c'est
toujours moins risqué je veux aussi
saluer l'administrateur patient
compétent et toujours disponiblebl ainsi
que nos collaborateurs respectifs avant
de finir et de passer la parole à Bruno
je tiens à aborder deux sujets sur le
champ d'application de la proposition de
loi le Sénat a travaillé ce sujet pour
préciser le champ des prestations en
article 1 et et regarder ce qui était
concerné profession réglementée ou non
quelle prestation informatique le débat
reste ouvert sur ce sujet avec un bémol
ne vidons pas la portée de la
proposition de loi de même Bruno
expliquera pourquoi nous avons mieux
ciblé les établissements concernés avec
un seuil et il reste le débat vous
connaissez tous concernant les les
collectivités locales qui avaient fait
l'objet d'une mission flash au printemps
dernier nous avons tourné dans tous les
sens la question pour trouver une
solution qui intégrerit le champ des
administrations publiques locales dans
la proposition de loi actuelle aucune
solution n'est satisfaisante et surtout
su été méconnaître les spécificités et
du marché local du conseil très atomisé
et des collectivités locales en
respectant le principe de libre
administration des collectivités nous y
reviendrons sans aucun doute dans le
débat mais nous avons le sentiment que
les intégrés immédiatement sans un
travail préalable d'évaluation aurait
pour conséquence de désintégrer
l'ensemble des dispositions de la
proposition de loi il nous faudra donc y
revenir très vite en lien avec les
associations d'élus tel a été le choix
qui s'est imposé à nous et que nous
voudrions vous faire partager et je
passe la parole à
Bruno merci mon cher Nicolas monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues ce texte
était attendu et attendu parce qu'il
constitue l'aboutissement des travaux de
la commission d'enquête du Sénat sur
l'influence croissante des cabinets de
conseil privé sur les politiques
publiques qui a remis son rapport en
mars 2022 suite à cette commission
d'enquête une proposition de loi
transpartisane a été adoptée à
l'unanimité des votants en octobre 2022
je me félicite pour ma part que ce texte
soit mis à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée et j'espère que nos
discussions permettront d'avoir un texte
équilibré et utile utile car il répond à
la demande de nos concitoyens la Cour
des comptes en 2014 les rapports de nos
collègues Véronique louvagie en 2021
Sandra Mottin en 2022 2 l'ouvrage des
journalistes Mathieu Haron et Caroline
Michel agir les infiltré la même année
et plus récemment le premier contrôle
d'initiative citoyenne de la Cour des
comptes ont tous sous des angles
différents et avec des approches et des
sensibilités variées identifi des
insuffisances dans la manière dont
l'état recourt aux prestations
intellectuelles de conseil selon les
chiffres de la commission d'enquête les
dépenses de conseil se sont élevées à
près d'un milliard d'euros en 2021 cela
peut être
identifié en matière de recours aux
prestation de conseil et les
associations non attendez
excusez-moi cela peut paraître beaucoup
même peut-être aux yeux de certains mais
je ne suis pas là pour jeter la pierre à
telle ou telle administration là n'est
pas mon rôle mon rôle est de permettre à
l'État et à ses administrations d'avoir
recours à des cabinets de conseil de
manière raisonnée et transparente là et
je le crois l'esprit de cette
proposition de loi je ne reviendrai que
brièvement sur les différents articles
de cette proposition de loi Nicolas l'a
déjà fait pour partie cette proposition
prévoit des mesures nouvelles que l'on
peut classer en en trois catégories un
principe de transparence des règles
déontologiques et des obligations
déclaratives ce texte dote également la
Haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique de nouveaux pouvoirs
pour assurer le respect de ces règles
mais soyons franc et réalistes ces
obligations seraient dans de trop
nombreux cas lourdes et inapplica
rappelons que l'idée n'est pas
d'interdire le recours au cabinet de
conseil appliquer les règles telles
qu'écrites dans la version du Sénat
reviendrait de facto à une quasi
disparition du recours au cabinet de
conseil monsieur président j'entends vos
j'entends vos futures interrogations
devrais-je dire oui donc j'entends vos
interrogations et je ferai au mieux pour
y répondre ici mais aussi dans les
nombreux amendements que je porte tout
d'abord nous n'inclurons pas les
collectivités territoriales Nicolas vous
l'a dit dans le périmètre de ce texte
pour une raison simple aucune dérive
réelle n'a été constatée en matière de
recours aux prestations de conseil et
les associations d'élus ont toutes
insisté sur les difficultés que
représenterit pour elle une
transposition trop mécanique du texte
qui semble inadaptée à leurs enjeux nous
avons envisagé avec Nicol a plusieurs
solutions mais aucune ne nous a paru
satisfaisante nous demanderons ainsi un
rapport au gouvernement pour étudier une
demande plus de plus de transparence au
collectivité territoriale je demanderai
également à la délégation collectivité
territoriale d'en faire de même je pense
qu'il faut que la DC dcdt pardon se se
saisisse du problème et entame une
mission spécifique pour les
collectivités territorial on avait bien
trouvé des solutions avec Nicolas mais
les solutions étaient parcellires à
chaque fois qu'on bougeit quelque chose
et bien ça avait une incidence directe
sur les administrations de l'État et
tout ça ça pouvait avoir et tout ça se
se matchait pas Mo j'assume et tout ça
ne matchait pas s'agissant du champ de
la proposition de loi l'intention des
auteurs était d'embrasser un ensemble
très vase de prestation dans une
approche exhaustive il nous est apparu
du fait du vaste champ de prestation de
conseil retenu et de la nature des
obligations créées il ne serait pas
pertinent de conserver un périmètre trop
large je proposerai donc un amendement
pour restindre le champ des
établissements publics concerné au plus
gros d'entre eux il nous semble par
ailleurs que la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation que la loi qualifie
d'établissement spécial doit faire
l'objet de dispositions spécifiques lors
de nos travaux préparatoires de
nombreuses personnes auditionnées nous
ont fait part de leurs craintes à propos
de la déclaration d'intérêt prévu à
l'article 10 et de l'obligation de
déclarer des actions les actions de
démarchage prévu à l'article 11 par leur
caractère très général et exhaustif ces
exigences pourraient porter atteinte à
la liberté d'entreprendre et à la vie
privée des consultants qui sont cons
institutionnellement garanti ces
articles posent également des enjeux
opérationnels pour l'administration et
pour les cabinets nous y avons été
sensibles et nous vous proposerons des
amendements pour mieux cibler les
informations exigées et rechercher un
meilleur équilibre entre la volonté de
prévenir les conflits d'intérêts et le
nécessaire respect de nos libertés nous
pourrons également prévoir d'adapter
l'intensité de ces obligations au niveau
de responsabilité du consultant je
proposerai également la suppression de
l'article 16 si je comprends l'objectif
recherché par nos collègues sénateurs
c'est cet article concernait près de 5,5
millions de personnes et ferait peser
sur la h atvp des obligations de
contrôle bien trop importante et pas
réellement pertinente le code général de
la Fonction publique prévoit déjà des
contrôles de la hatvp pour les demandes
de reconversion dans le privé lucratif
pour les agents publics occupant ou
ayant occupé au cours des trois
dernières années un emploi dont le
niveau hiérarchique où la nature des
fonctions le justifie cela permet donc
déjà de couvrir l'effet relevés par la
commission d'enquête enfin je sout je
souhaiterai je soutiendrai pardon
l'amendement de ma collègue lordur
Miller de réécriture de l'article 18
afin de rendre cet article conforme au
droit européen et plus adapté à la
réalité des besoins de sécurité tel que
rédigé aujourd'hui cet article rendrait
impossible pour toutes TPE et PME
d'effectuer des missions de conseil car
elles ne pourront pas effectuer cet
audit infin cet article soutiendrait les
gros au détriment des petits ce texte
est important et attendu je sais pouvoir
compter sur votre sérieux et votre
travail pour que nous puissions trouver
les meilleurs compromis poss possible et
ainsi voter comme je l'espère ce texte à
l'unanimité merci Monsieur les
rapporteur donc vous avez indiqué
Monsieur rapporteur que vous avez
transmis une liste de questions
auxquelles vous avez en partie répondu
et j'avais posé plusieurs questions
d'abord sur le champ d'application
puisque le champ d'application prévoit
l'application de ce texte à l'ensemble
des consultants comme toute personne
exerçant cette activité professionnelle
au sein d'une entreprise cette
définition je voulais savoir si elle ne
vous apparaît pas excessive parce
qu'elle pourrait comprendre des
stagiaires ou des jeunes collaborateurs
n'ayant aucun pouvoir de de décision et
donc de direction dans l'entreprise de
même la proposition intègre des
prestations informatiques ou de
communication comme celle déployé lors
des crises récentes la gestion de
l'épidémie de covid ou la réponse
urgence à l'attaque à l'attaque
informatique d'un établissement
hospitalier que nous avons étudié
d'ailleurs dans la lopmie et ces
situations vous paraissent-elles
compatiblees avec les exigences que la
Commission s'apprête à examiner sur le
champ d'application vous l'avez dit et
d'ailleurs c'était l'objet de la la
mission d'information que vous avez
conduit monsieur sensu avec notre notre
collègue madame Lebec qui avait conclu
la nécessité de faire une autre mission
de la délégation aux collectivités
territorial moi je reste convaincu que
les collectivités sont sujettes en tout
cas pour les plus importantes d'entre
elles aux mêmes obligations de
transparence de déontologie et de
prévention des des conflits d'intérêts
ça c'est pour le le champ le champ
d'application deuxième type
d'interrogation que soulève l'examen de
la la proposition de loi en commission
c'est la nature des obligations
nouvelles faites aux consultants la
Commission a travaillé avec madame
htermeer Monsieur Le Gendre sur les
reprendants d'intérêt de façon très
efficace avec une volonté de renforcer
de façon considérable les obligations
qui pèsent sur eux et cel avait fait
l'objet d'une proposition noi à l'époque
où le bureau des commissions était
autorisé à les faire remonter à titre
transpartisant et donc est-ce que l'on
doit considérer que les obligations qui
sont faites aux consultants doivent être
supérieures à celles qui sont faites aux
représentants d'intérêt parce que ce
serait le cas si nous adoptions si nous
adoptions la proposition de loi sans
l'étendre pour le coup au repr
présentant d'intérêt ce qui serait une
difficulté la troisième préoccupation
c'est que la proposition confèire un
rôle tout à fait nouveau à la chatavp ça
peut-être souhaitable c'est c'est vrai
notamment parce que c'est une demande du
président lui-même de l' chatvp mais en
tout cas il interroge sur le rôle que
nous faisons jouer auï aux autorités
administratives indépendantes d'ailleurs
c'est une question qui est assez
récurrente parce que lorsqu'on
auditionne la contrôleur générale des
lieux de privation de liberté lorsqu'on
auditionne la Défenseur des droits
beaucoup de questions sont posées sur
quel est le rôle des autorités
administratives indépendantes est-ce
qu'il faut selon vous lui confier ce
pouvoir de sanction administrative de
sorte qu'elle puisse la chtvp prononcer
des amendes financières interdire
l'accès au marché public qu'est-ce que
ça a comme conséquence budgétaire
fonctionnelle et temporelle sur
l'organisation de la htvp notamment le
fait devoir se scinder en deux à l'image
de ce que nous connaissons sur l'arcom
puisqu'il faudra un collège des
sanctions et puis un collège de de
conseil ensuite une autre question sur
le marché des cabinets de conseil est-ce
que vous craignez pas que ces nouvelles
obligations législatives réglementaires
elles ai pour effet d'exclure les
petites entités on imagine très bien les
grands groupes ce qui conseille
classiquement l'État ou les
établissements publics que ces grands
groupes puissent se conformer grâce au
service juridique dont il disposeent aux
obligations nouvelles en revanche les
les petites entreprises qui sont qui
constituent le le marché des cabinets de
conseil voir les entrepreneurs
individuels est-ce qu'ils pourront ou
est-ce qu'ils sont prévu pour être
devoir se conformer aux nouvelles
obligations et enfin euh effectivement
vous avez mentionné l'existence et la
création d'un d'un jaune budgétaire qui
vise à rendre plus transparente et
lisible l'action de l'État c'est c'est
une bonne chose est-ce que c'est
suffisant certainement pas je pense que
on peut faire beaucoup mieux et en cela
les mesures de la de la proposition loi
sont assez intéressantes en revanche
comment vous l'articuleer les
dispositions de la proposition noi avec
ces dispositions nouvelles et surtout
avec nos travaux de contrôle à nous et
je veux pour preuve un des exemple que
je vous avais fait connaître le fait que
par exemple la commission des lois
aujourd'hui auditionne des inspections
générales qui sont directement
normalement en prise avec
l'administration l'inspection générale
de la police nationale notamment
l'inspection générale de la gendarmerie
pour une audition qui était nouvelle
l'année dernière mais que je veux annuel
dans le cadre notamment de l'application
du BAU de la sécurité voilà c'est les
questions que vous avez transmis par
écrit et que pour le coup vous avez en
partie répondu pour certaines d'entre
elles mais je pense que c'est l'examen
de la proposition qui doit nous
permettre de répondre aux autres je vais
appeler les orateurs je rappelle c'est 4
minutes pour chacun d'entre vous madame
la Miller pour le groupe Renaissance
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les rapporteurs nous allons donc étudier
ce matin une proposition de loi
provenant du Sénat et é manant plus
particulièrement des recommandations
faites par la commission d'enquête
dédiée à l'influence croissante des
cabinets de conseil sur les politiques
publiques je veux ici commencer par
souligner le caractère transpartisan de
ce travail oui nous sommes fort
heureusement capables de travailler
ensemble pour améliorer nos politiques
publiques en l'occurrence pour assaainir
l'élaboration de nos politiques
publiques en ce sens cette proposition
de loi est sur le principe bienvenue
nous aurons dans un instant à débattre
des articles qui la compose et je ne
détaillerai donc pas dans ce propos
cette proposition de loi elle intervient
comme je l'ai dit après un rapport de la
commission d'enquête créée en novembre
2021 achevé en mars 2022 elle a ensuite
cette proposition de loi été votée le 19
octobre 2022 au Sénat mais dans ce lapse
de temps il est utile de préciser que le
gouvernement a pris ses responsabilités
et que le régime juridique qui encadre
les prestations de conseil a évolué dans
le bon sens le gouvernement Castex a
introduit de nouvelles règles d'ordre
réglementaire par la voie d'une
circulaire du 22 janvier 2022 il y a eu
ensuite un nouvel accord cadre conclu
sur la réalisation des prestations de
conseil en stratégie en juillet 2022
puis la loi de finance pour 2023 a prévu
la remise d'un rapport sous forme
d'annexe au projet de loi de finance
portant sur le recours par l'État aux
prestations de conseil enfin une
circulaire de la première ministre du 8
février 2023 relative au pilotage et
encadrement du recours aux prestations
intellectuelle informatique est venu
renforcer le cadre de régulation toutes
ces évolutions ont permis de construire
notre arsenal législatif pour lutter
contre certaines dérites du recours au
cabinet de conseil notamment en
contraignant l'administration à
démontrer au préalable qu'elle ne
disposait pas des moyens y ou
compétences nécessaires pour avoir
recours au cabinet de conseil un
objectif de réduction des dépenses
fixées dans la circulaire mais aussi un
une maîtrise du montant des dépenses
avec l'accord cadre un dispositif de
pilotage par ministère une évaluation
après chaque prestation un renforcement
des règles de déontologie et de
transparence comme de la protection des
données en somme beaucoup de mesures de
la proposition ont d'une manière ou
d'une autre été traité par l'exécutif
depuis 2021 sans doute est-il nécessaire
de transcrire dans la loi cette
régulation mais il me semblait important
de préciser l'état du droit à l'heure
actuelle en revanche qu'il me soit
permis à l'occasion de ce propos d'avoir
trois points d'alerte le premier c'est
que si nos administrations doivent
gagner en compétence elles ne peuvent de
toute évidence pas disposer de toutes
les expertises parfois techniques à
forceerie lorsqu'il existe des sujets
urgents et spécifiques je pense
évidemment à l'exemple de la crise covid
ne caricaturons donc pas la situation en
empêchant tout recours à des expertises
extérieures sauf à vouloir créer un état
omnipotent ce qui impliquerait
évidemment des agents supplémentaires
qui seraient en quelque sorte en veille
la plupart du temps et sollicité
ponctuellement ça ne serait de toute
évidence pas raisonnable deuxème élément
je suis certaine que vous entendez comme
moi chaque jour notre droit est trop
complexe nous construisons chaque
semaine dans cette enceinte la
démobilisation générale qu'elle soit
économique ou sociale parce que nous
empilons des normes sur des normes et
finissons en voulant protéger par
empêcher toutes les initiatives alors il
est évident évidemment extrêmement sain
de vouloir encadrer le recours au
cabinet de conseil puisque tout
simplement c'est l'argent des Français
dont il s'agit il est légitime de briser
cette espèce de relation de dépendance
qui s'est parfois installés entre les
cabinets de conseil et le secteur public
mais veillons chers collègues à ne pas
bâtir des règles disproportionnées face
au but recherché veillons à ne pas
construire des usines à gaz comme on
sait tous collectivement si bien le
faire dans notre rôle de législateur et
veillons veillons à ne pas aboutir en
privilégiant les grosses structures au
but inversé inverse de celui que nous
recherchion dernier élément évidemment
cette proposition de loi et politique la
tentation serait donc forte pour les uns
et les autres de politiser ce sujet je
reprendrai les mots de François surau
prononcé récemment devant l'Académie des
sciences morales et politiques je cite
la France est un étrange pays
visiblement gouverné par le principe de
l'échange des rôles chacun il fait le
travail d'un autre les ministres
tweetent comme des journalistes et
parlent comme des fonctionnaires les
parlementaires se rêvent juge
d'instruction et convoquent l'une après
l'autre des commissions d'enquête je
forme donc un vœ sans doute pieux que
nous restions tout simplement au moins
sur cette proposition de loi dans notre
rôle de législateur notre groupe
formulera un certain nombre
d'aménagements dans la rédaction de
cette PPL afin qu'elle soit davantage
proportionné au B recherché je vous
remercie merci Monsieur timothéousin
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci Monsieur président la d'enquête
sénatoriale ne s'est pas trompé
lorsqu'elle évoquéit un phénomène
pentaculaire pour une influence des
cabinets de conseil sur
les
pour les choix budgétaires du ministère
des armées ou le plan d'économie de Bery
la lutte contre la radicalisation la
gestion de la crise sanitaire la
stratégie nationale de santé la réforme
de l'aide au logement les états généraux
de la justice l'avenir du métier
d'enseignant ou encore la réforme des
retraites cette privatisation de la
décision publique a un coût avoir
recours à un consultant compte en
moyenne quatre fois plus cher que
d'avoir recours à un fonctionnaire 2 à 3
milliards d'euros par an de dépenses
publiques sont dédié au cabinet de
conseil c'est plus que le budget de
certaines région est proche de celui du
ministère de la Santé à l'époque où il
existait alors que nous avons l'un des
niveaux de dépenses publqu les plus
élevés au monde au vu de ces chiffres il
sera indispensable à terme de veiller au
recours qu'on les collectivités au
cabinet de conseil si le fait d'inclure
les communes nécessite des aménagements
et pourrait nuire à l'adoption d'un
texte commun au de chambres dans un
délai rapide il n'en reste pas moins que
les régions et département devrait être
soumis au dispositif de ce texte et
qu'une commission d'enquête sur le
recours des collectivités locales au
cabinet de conseil est indispensable
pour identifier les besoins en matière
de
législation enfin le recours massif au
cabinet de conseil est une perte de
savoir affire de nos fonctionnaires de
nos ministères de l'État lui-même et
donc une finer une perte de souveraineté
si le recours à ces cabinets peut-être
justifié pour gérer une situation
exceptionnelle ou apporter un regard
extérieur sur un dossier alors il doit
être strictement justifié encadré et
transparent ce sont ces trois piliers
qui forment notre politique en la
matière nous voterons ce texte car nous
approuvons qu'il empêche les dérives en
matière de recours au cabinet de conseil
en terme de conflit d'intérêt de réalité
des prestations ou d'opacité des
contrats cependant nous estimons qu'il
n'encadre pas suffisamment le recours de
la puissance publique aux prestations de
ses cabinets et nous risquons de
continuer à aller vers la privatisation
de la décision publique le groupe RN a
donc déposé une vingtaine d'amendements
qui visent à renforcer ce texte
merci Monsieur Frédéric Mathieu pour le
groupe la France insumise oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président chers collègues la France
insoumis d'abord salue le sérieux du
travail qui a été mené au Sénat autour
de cette proposition de loi qui nous
paraît hautement nécessaire nécessaire
en effet parce que lorsqu'on parle des
cabinets conseil et ça a déjà été évoqué
on ne peut pas se priver d'avoir à la
tête le nom de minseay qui arrive
mckinseay qui symbolise la compromission
de la macronie avec des intérêts privés
ses liens les partages de personnels à
titre gratuit durant des campagnes
électorales avec des renvois
d'ascenseurs qui suivent en terme de
marché public si bien que deux enquêtes
en cours sont diligenté aujourd'hui par
le parquet national financier il
convient de le rappeler mains c'est la
conscience d'unup organisé
quotidiennement non seulement sur les
finances publiques mais surtout sur le
service public ses missions ses
prérogatives et quelque part sur la
responsabilité des décideurs publics
alors peut-être qu'il faut trouver
là-dedans l'explication du monsieur
sANSU l'a rappelé des 15 mois que nous
avons attendu pour retrouver cette
proposition no inscrite à l'ordre du
jour de notre honorable assemblée le
gouvernement s'il était sincère dans sa
démarche l'aurait sans doute inscrite
durant la semaine du gouvernement non il
a fallu attendre que ce soit la semaine
de l'assemblée que nous trouvions un
accord pour cette inscription c'est fait
à toute chose malheur et bon au moins on
aura pu attendre et réfléchir sur ce
projet de loi cette proposition de loi
pardon cette proposition là
euh néanmoins ne nous semble pas
suffisante si au dispositif général nous
convient et recueille l'avis favorable
de la France insoumise les scandales
autour des cabinets conseil du recours
au cabinets conseil sont allés tellement
loin que nous avons aujourd'hui en tant
que législateur la haute responsabilité
d'épuiser les sujets tous les sujets au
autour du recours au cabinet conseil
nous ne devons avoir peur d'aucun sujet
nous ne devons laisser de côté aucun
anglement je l'ai dit les cabinets
conseil lorsqu'on en parle c'est souvent
main qui revient c'est l'évocation du
symbole de l'influence d'intérêt privé
sur la décision publique l'opacité
malsine des relations entre décideurs
publics et intérêts privés finalement la
confiscation du bien commun en vue de sa
mise à sac je rappelle quand même même
durant le covid même durant le covid il
a fallu que le chou des cabinets conseil
du président de la République viennent
se tailler sa part vorace alors que
l'économie était à l'arrêt alors que les
finances publiques qui était
durement durement mise à l'épreuve alors
que chacune et chacun était chez soi en
train d'avoir peur pour soi-même et pour
ses proches il a fallu que le cabinet
minset Vienne taper dans les finances
publiques à hauteur de conseils
stratégiques et en organisation qui sont
des compétences qui appartiennent au
ministère de la Santé qui sont présentes
au ministère de la Santé qui étaient
présente au ministère de la Santé au
moment de cette crise ceci représente un
véritable scandale que les citoyens
n'oublient pas je le dis cette loi nous
satisfait dans son dispositif et nous y
apportons un avis globalement favorable
je l'ai dit également aucun angle mort
ne devra subsister à l'issue de nos
débats nous avons le devoir d'épuiser le
sujet tout le sujet à la hauteur du
scandale que suscite le recours au
cabinet
conseil nous devrons forcément parler
des collectivités territoriales et nous
verrons bien à l'issue de nos débats ce
ce qui l'en euh retirera peut-être il y
aura-t-il des amendements qui seront
votés peut-être qu'en effet euh votre
rapport aura les faveurs unanimes de la
commission nous verrons bien nous devons
en débattre nous devons débattre
également de l'élargiss l'élargissement
pardon du champ des prestations conseil
juridique comptable stratégie dans les
systèmes d'information je rappelle qu'en
2021 la le conseil en stratégie des
systèmes d'information représenté plus
de 50 % de l'ensemble du chiffre
d'affaires des cabinets conseil la
question question de la déontologie des
cabinets conseil dans ses relations
administration la reconquête des
compétences perdues dans les services de
l'État par le recours excessif au
cabinet conseil et bien sûr il faudra
bien avoir une réflexion sur la
transation pénale puisque s'il y a
transation de responsabilité il doit y
avoir transation pénale je vous remercie
Monsieur Philippe goselin pour le groupe
les républicains merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président
messieurs les les rapporteurs chers
collègues comme Nicolas sensus tout à
l'heure j'ai envie de dire enfin enfin
nous y voilà il y a 14 15 mois en effet
que le texte a été adopté par le Sénat à
l'unanimité en réalité aucun vote contre
et on a l'impression que depuis 14 mois
tout a été fait pour différer l'examen
de ce texte qui sans doute était un peu
un peu gênant oui un peu gênant parce
qu'en réalité la campagne présidentielle
de 2022 du président de la République
actuelle a mis en avant un certain
nombre sans doute d'irrégularités en
tout cas il appartiendra à la justice de
se prononcer il y a toujours des
enquêtes en cours euh le parquet
national financier a été saisi en
novembre 22 et nous verrons ce qu'il en
sortira en tout cas il y a un sentiment
très désagréable d'une forme
d'andogamie que l'on cherche à éviter et
c'est l'objet de cette proposition alors
évidemment comme toute proposition de
loi elle n'a pas fait l'objet d'une
étude d'impact c'est le principe même et
et donc un certain nombre d'éléments
peuvent prêter à discussion comme par
exemple le champ d'application sur les
collectivités locales j'y j j'y
reviendrai alors on semble découvrir
avec la polémique euh de l'élection
présidentielle euh de 2022 euh les
cabinets de conseil et minse en en
particulier alors c'est vrai que c'est
devenu un peu la tête de chapitre hein
ce ce ce cabinet euh qui euh euh a eu
euh une implication assez forte mais en
réalité les alertes ne sont pas
nouvelles les alertes ne sont pas
nouvelles cela a été évoqué euh par euh
Nicolas sensu tout à l'heure euh la la
Cour des comptes et puis c'est celui de
Véronique louvagie notre collègue les
républicains en 2021 Sandra metin en
2022 l'avit fait vous avez monsieur le
rapporteur avec maintenant membre du
gouvernement commis un rapport sur les
collectivités locales et les cabinets de
de conseil alors on peut peut-être
supposer que votre rapport maintenant a
le soutien gouvernemental je je je je ne
sais pas allez on on sera sérieux et on
évitera de faire des transpositions en
tout cas un un un vrai un vrai un vrai
souci un vrai dossier parce qu'il y a un
manque de transparence il y a un
foisonnement des conseils et donc une
dépossession de l'État y compris y
compris sur des secteurs régaliens ce
qui fait la grande différence me
semble-t-il d'ailleurs avec les les
collectivités et des risques
déontologiques qui sont avérés cela a
été repris tout à l'heure donc ceux qui
guident cette proposition de loi ce
n'est pas l'envie
d'interdire strictement les cabinets de
conseil je crois que les collectivités
comme l'état peuvent sous certaines
conditions avoir besoin et des besoins
particuliers et toutes les compétences
sont sans doute dans l'État et les
collectivités mais quand même il y a des
sujets parfois très pointus qui
nécessitent un éclairage extérieur et
j'ai pas nous n'avons pas de difficulté
avec ces éléments en revanche il faut
renforcer la transparence oui il faut
renforcer aussi les RG de déontologie et
prévoir des sanctions pour prévenir les
conflits d'intérêts c'est de bon sens me
semble-t-il et et et nous devons le
faire avec justesse en ne rompant pas
l'équilibre qui peut exister c'est tout
cela qui amène aussi à exclure du champ
d'application au moins à ce stade les
collectivités locales je crois d'abord
on a aucun chiffre hein sur sur ce qui a
été fait ou est fait par les consultants
à l'échelle locale
on est très souvent sur des apports
stratégiques différents de ceux de
l'État qui ne touchent pas au régalien à
à l'ordre ou à la sécurité on a vraiment
des des des thématiques très très
différentes et je crois que avant
d'aller au-delà il faudrait à minima
effectivement avoir un rapport
spécifique pour pouvoir documenter et
palier ce ce ce manque d'étude d'impact
vous l'avez compris en conclusion
monsieur le Président les républicains
soutiendront ce texte en le bougeant le
moins possible
pour le groupe
démocrate merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur chers collègues
l'intervention des cabinets de conseil
dans les politiques publiques est un
sujet politique et polémique qui occupe
le débat public depuis maintenant
plusieurs années l'état recours très
souvent au cabinet de conseil pour
concevoir et mettre en place des
politiques publiqu qui nous concern tous
commission d'enquête sénatoriale initiée
par le groupe communiste a très bien
montré que ces prestations sont très peu
encadrées souvent opaqu et qu'elles
peuvent poser des problèmes
diontologiques en l'absence de
législation claire et précise nous nous
retrouvons tous pour affirmer qu'il faut
une loi pour mieux encadrer les
relations entre l'État et les cabinets
de conseil je me réjouis donc que mon
groupe ait trouvé un accord avec le
groupe GDR pour inscrire ce texte à
l'ordre du jour d'une semaine de
l'Assemblée afin que nous aboutissions à
un texte acceptable par tous et je salue
ici mes collègues Bruno milen et Nicolas
sANSU pour leur travail de rapporteur je
tiens tout d'abord à rappeler que
l'objectif ici n'est pas de pointer du
doigt les cabinets de conseil qui par
leur travail contribuent aux politiques
publiqu et sont d'une grande aide pour
l'État je pense en particulier aux
prestations de conseil en informatique
qui est qui est un domaine exigeant des
qualifications dont l'État ne dispose
pas en proportion à ses besoins mais
sans véritable cadre légal les
interventions des cabinets de conseil
dans les politiques publiques manquent
de transparence elle manque de
transparence pour les citoyens qui se
voi imposer des politiques publiques
qu'ils imaginent conçu par des
fonctionnaires alors qu'elles ont été
élaborées par les cabinet de conseil
elle manque également de transparence
pour l'État lui-même qui ne dispose pas
à ce jour de documents qui recensent
l'ensemble des prestations de conseil
passé et en cours auquel il y a eu
recours de ces manques d'encadrement et
de transparence découle un autre
problème les risques déontologiques
aujourd'hui aucune règle ni procédure ne
permet à l'état de contrôler et de se
prévir des conflits d'intérêts qui
pourrai apparaître alors que les
passages du secteur public au secteur
privé sont fréquents et que le
recrutement d'anciens fonctionnaires est
devenu un atout pour les cabinets de
conseil il est important que l'État soit
en mesure d'éviter tout risque
déontologique les cabinets ont également
tendance à proposer des prestations à
titre gratuit et à multiplier des
actions de démarchage et de prospection
commerciale renforçant leur réseau et se
rendant indispensable aux yeux de
l'administration et du politique mais
cette relation de dépendance POS un
risque déontologique important que nous
devons éviter la France s'est dotée en
2014 unee haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique chargé
de s'assurer de l'intégrité et la
probité des responsables publics le
législateur a en particulier décidé de
charger l'ha TVP de contrôler le
pantouflage en lui permettant de rendre
des avis d'incompatibilité parce qu'elle
estime que les nouvelles fonctions
envisagées serait incompatible avec les
précédentes dans la ligée de ces
politiques publiques de transparence si
les consultants sont amenés à exercer
temporairement l'émission d'agent public
nous devons exiger d'eux une probité
exemplaire c'est tout l'objet de la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui définir les prestations de
conseil encadrer le recours au
consultants en finir avec l'opacité de
ses prestations et renforcer les
exigences déontologiques l'enjeu est
également de protéger les données de
l'état qui laisse les cabinets de
conseil travailler avec des données avec
ces données sans préciser quel usage
peut en être fait et surtout pourra
ultérieurement en être fait ainsi je
suis convaincu ce est nécessaire et sous
réserve des améliorations et des
simplifications qui seront portées par
notre rapporteur démocrate nous voterons
en faveur de ce texte je vous
remercie madame cécilemeill pour le
groupe
socialiste merci merci monsieur le
président ident je voudrais en préambule
saluer la qualité du travail
parlementaire qui a conduit donc à la
jeunèse de cette proposition de loi dans
la suite de la dénonciation d'abus cela
a été dit une commission d'enquête
sénatoriale a fourni des conclusions
alarmantes et choquantes s'agissant de
la force de frappe des cabinets de
conseil et leur influence grandissante
dans les politiques publiques en se
saisissant d'un tel sujet le Parlement
prouve à nouveau sa capacité à s'emparer
de dossiers
importants je suis pour ma part soulagée
et heureuse de voir que les termes de
transparence et de déontologie
apparaissent de manière tout à fait Liss
dans les discussions que nous avons
désormais au sein de de ce Parlement et
de l'Assemblée nationale mon deuxème
point c'est le constat d'une nécessité
de réguler l'intervention des cabinets
de conseil dans l'action publique
s'impose à nous depuis plusieurs années
cela a été dit aussi l'émergence des
cabinets privés intervenant auprès de
l'État dans sa stratégie dans
l'élaboration des politiques publiques
son organ ation ou sa gestion des
ressources humaines ne cesse de
s'accroître et dans l'opacité l'État a
eu recours à des prestations pour des
montants atteignant parfois plusieurs
millions d'euros sur l'année 2021 les
dépenses de conseil ont dépassé le
milliard d'euros dont 893 millions pour
les ministères des montants
excessivement élevés pour des
prestations parfois évitables et sans
réel contrôle ni évaluation en cela la
circulaire du Premier ministre du 19
janvier 2022 est la première pierre d'un
arsenal juridique à consolider et je
tiens à souligner quand même cette
capacité à réagir rapidement du
ministère de la Fonction publique par
rapport à ce danger que nous avions
évoqué précisons en 3ème point que les
cabinets de conseil ne sont pas nos
ennemis et ne sont pas les ennemis de
l'action publique et il est clair que
l'État quelquefois recommande même comme
vous me l'aviez dit Monsieur sensu euh
aux collectivités locales d'avoir
recours au cabinet de conseil
oblige voilà AR bien sûr alors dans
l'immense majorité des cas il répondent
à a des besoins de l'administration qui
fait appel à eux et recommande de faire
appel à eux et oblige même de faire
appel à eux si l'enjeu de ce texte n'est
pas d'interdire leur intervention il en
va de notre responsabilité de les
réguler et à travers cela d'impulser une
politique de
réinternalisation des compétences
lesquelles font l'excellence de notre
fonction publique qui nous est envié
partout dans le monde mon 4e point c'est
sur le fond ce texte répond à plusieurs
objectifs dans un premier temps il
renforce les obligations de transparence
avec la publication par les ministères
d'un rapport l'exigence de transparence
doit également s'imposer avant
l'exécution de la prestation en
particulier pour les agents publics
concernés qui doivent en être informés
cela nous paraît tout à fait essentiel
nous formulons cette proposition par
voie d'amendement ensuite ce texte
encadre davantage de recours à ces
prestations en renforçant leur
évaluation à à postériori il nous semble
également qu'en tant que législateur
nous sommes tenus d'interdire la la
rédaction par des cabinets privés d'un
projet de loi ou de son étude d'impact
tel que l'a révélé la commission
d'enquête enfin ce texte renforce les
principes déontologiques applicables au
consultants au sein de la hatvp mais la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts et du
respect des principes déontologiques ne
peut reposer que sur la seule h TVP le
référent déontologue désigné au sein de
chaque administration doit prendre toute
sa part dans cette mission le champ
d'application de ce texte nous interroge
tous je rejoins la préoccupation
exprimée par notre président de
commission s'agissant des stagiaires
collaborateur du rôle de la hatatvp mais
s'agissant des collectivités
territoriales je ne comprendrai pas que
nous ne puissions pas envisager des
mesures qui permettent d'encadrer pour
leur propre sécurité les collectivités
locales qui ont recours à ses cabinets
de conseil je vous mercie merci Madame
Marie AG pouss vinb pour le groupe
horizon alors je veux bien que ce matin
on va être un peu le le le le groupe qui
a un discours un peu différent pardon de
pas être si si enthousiaste euh dans le
payco il y a une expression qui qui dit
méfie-toi méfie-toi toujours méfie-toi
encore et et et typiquement sur ce texte
c'est un peu
notre notre attitude euh la transparence
permet-elle la la confiance c'est l'une
des questions qui nous est posé avec
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
plus philosophique que jur juridique me
direz-vous moi je dirais plutôt plus
pratique et c'est cet aspect là aussi
qu'on qu'on essaierait de de regarder
ensemble ces 30 dernières années la
priorité du législateur s'est focalisé
pour de saines et justes raisons sur la
moralisation et l'encadrement des
relations financière entre le privé et
le public avec une attention
particulière sur le financement des
partis des campagnes par les entreprise
le plafonnement de nos dons des
particuliers des dépenses de campagne la
publication des comptes des candidats
par exemple autant de mesures
nécessaires pour permettre de recréer de
la confiance entre les citoyens et leurs
représentants entre les citoyens et
l'administration or à quoi on assiste
depuis quelques années et bien cette
recherche d'indépendance financière
pourtant nécessaire nous sommes passés
plutôt à une défiance a priori à l'égard
du secteur public et moi c'est vraiment
ce que je crains cette défiance entrave
gravement la volonté de s'engager va à
l'encontre des objectifs recherchés par
le législateur législateur qui
s'intéresse depuis plusieurs mois à
l'étant en tant que personne morale à
ses administrations et à ses partenaires
depuis l'affaire mainse nous avons tout
entendu l'administration cette nébuleuse
tentaculaire je l'ai encore entendu ce
matin dépenserait sans compter et
indument des milliards pour des
prestations de conseil souvent qualifié
à postériori de médiocre quand ce n'est
pas de dangereuse relative à l'ingérence
relativement pardon à l'ingérence
exercée sur les élus loin de ces
caricatures nous soutiens nous
soutiendrons le le groupe l'esprit de
cette proposition de loi qui entend
assurer la traçabilité des rôles des
cabinets dans les prises de décisions
mais aussi garantir une meilleure
information des citoyens pour autant
méfions-nous des faux prophètes je ne
souscris pas au raccourcis qui consiste
à considérer que les pratiques honteuses
de certains résumeraient l'ensemble des
pratiques d'une profession par contre
conséquent je souhaite rappeler quelques
évidences la conduite de l'action
publique peut dans certains cas
précisément identifier nécessiter de
recourir à des prestation
intellectuelles
extérieur rappelons également que nous
partons de loin et que beaucoup a été
fait par cette majorité pour encadrer le
recours au cabinet de conseil la
circulaire du Premier ministre tu l'as
dit lors tout à l'heure du 12 janvier
2022 donnait la responsabilité pleine à
chaque ministère de piloter ses
investissements avec une possibilité
inédite de tracer avec plus de précision
les dépenses réalisées grâce au au
jaunes budgétaire j'ai deux questions
tout d'abord en matière de limitation de
la contrainte administrative la
proportionnalité de la norme est un
principe qui doit nous guider et nous
éviter de faire peser une charge
déraisonnable sur des structures de
taille réduite à ce titre je défendrai
au nom de mon groupe un amendement à
l'article 1er visant à fixer un seil de
60 millions d'euros de dépenses aux
établissements publics concernés par les
obligations de ce texte un second point
et non des moindres et et qui pour nous
constituerait une ligne rouge et là je
vois bien qu'on est un peu isolé c'est
l'extension de ce dispositif aux
collectivités territoriales il est pas
souhaitable selon nous de le faire
rajouter de la complexité et faire subir
de nouvelles contraintes aux élus locaux
est une impasse lorsque l'on connaît
aujourd'hui les difficultés auxquelles
ils font face au quotidien aonsles
notamment en matière de responsabilité
pénale mais cessons de les charger
encore et encore sans compter que les
règles qui s'appliquent aujourd'hui et
bien écoutez l'enjeu est double arriver
à clarifier d'une part et simplifier
d'autre part nos relations monsieur
Benjamin Lucas pour le groupe
écologistes
bien merci Monsieur le le Président
permettez-moi de de saluer également le
Sénat nos deux rapporteurs voisin de de
circonscription et et mon camarade de de
travé euh une collègue nous incitait
tout à l'heure à ne pas faire de
politique bon je suis un peu surpris
parce qu'il n'y a rien de plus politique
que la question de la transparence
condition de la confiance il n'y a rien
de plus politique que la question
finalement de la démocratie de l'état de
l'autorité de l'état de sa compétence et
de la façon dont on construit les
politiques publ excusez-moi euh du terme
et il n'y a rien de plus politique
que d'interroger le pognon de dingue qui
est utilisé et qui est donné à des
cabinets de conseil à titre d'exemple
957000 € pour préparer une réforme des
retraites finalement abandonnée 500000 €
pour réfléchir à l'avenir du métier
d'enseignant ceci dit ça reste quand
même peut-être moins cher que Madame oua
casterra
235600 € pour un guide sur le
télétravail
3880000 € pour pour la réforme des aPL
41 million d'euros pour la stratégie à
adopter pendant la crise covid ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure voilà un un un
échantillon de ce qu'à versa l'état des
cabinets de conseil pour des prestations
disons-le inégal et aux intérêts parfois
souvent limités le coût des prestations
de cabinet privé a été multiplié par 3
depuis 2017 depuis l'arrivée d'Emmanuel
Macron au pouvoir pourtant nous avveit
vendu en 2017 l'arrivée des
professionnels des super technocrates
qui allaient tout remplacer la droite la
gauche la politique ma chère collègue
par la technocratie conquérante et et
talentueuse ils ont visiblement besoin
de beaucoup de soutien et de beaucoup de
conseils dans cette entreprise mais les
Françaises et les Français ont pu
constater l'amateurisme dont vous faites
preuve il n'y a qu'à voir justement les
différentes déclarations de la de
l'Ephémère du moins nous l'espérons
ministre de l'éducation nationale les
chiffres sont vertigineux ils sont
probablement sous-évalués le 27 novembre
2022 le ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le
Maire cette fois c'était pas Bruno
demande c'était Bruno à vous il a avoué
même qu'il y a eu je cite des abus et
une dérive dans le recours au cabinet de
conseil privé par le gouvernement parole
de Bruno Lemer que nous ne citons pas
souvent pour notre part qui fera la
valeur de de recommandation pour
l'examen de ce texte le recours par
l'État à des prestations de conseil
disait-il peut légitim pardon ça c'est
pas lui c'est Didier Migot président de
l' haute autorité pour la transparence
sur la vie publique le recours par
l'État à des prestations de conseil peut
légitimement susciter des inquiétudes en
matière de déontologie et de conflit
d'intérêts voilà des questions
éminemment politiques et même
démocratiques ces dérives et abus sont
confirmés par le rapport de la Cour des
compes de juillet 2023 portant sur le
recours par l'État aux prestations
intellectuelles des cabinets de conseil
ce rapport pointe notamment une doctrine
d'emploi incomplète et un pilotage mal
assuré mais aussi des insuffisances au
regard du droit des marchés derrière ce
recours ces recours massifs et sans
cesse croissant en cabinet de conseil
au-delà de la gabgie d'argent public
au-delà des potentiels conflits
d'intérêts avec lesquels nous avons
malheureusement pris l'habitude de de
fonctionner euh vous concernant un gros
problème se pose avec l'explosion des
recours au cabinet de conseil qui est
l'intervention toujours plus croissante
des intérêts privés dans les affaires
publiques et ça c'est une question
éminemment politique dans la gestion des
politiques nationales et dans la gestion
des politiques locales la décision
publique est de plus en plus suspendu
aux avis de prétendus expert payer une
fortune un milliard d'euros par an tout
de même pour des résultats médiocre ce
que l'État demande au cabinet privé il
peut le demander à son administration
aux fonctionnaires auquels je veux ce
matin rendre hommage 2,5 millions de
fonctionnaires qui sont dépossédés de
ces travaux de recherche au profil de
cabinet sans une 11ce de légitimité
démocratique et finalement c'est ça la
question qui nous est posée à travers
ces débats c'est comment détermine-t-on
l'intérêt général comment l'État
construit-il des politiques publiques au
nom de l'intérêt général est-ce que
cette recherche de l'intérêt général de
l'efficacité doit être confié à des
entreprises privées dont le but est de
faire du profit ou être est-ce qu'elle
doit être confiée aux serviteurs de
l'État pour notre part vous avez compris
que nous croyons que cela doit être
confié au serviteurs de l'État madame
Emeline kerbidi pour le groupe gauche
démocratie
républicaine monsieur le Président
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues bonjour cette proposition loi
adoptée par le Sénat à l'unanimité des
votants met en œuvre les recommandations
de la commission d'enquête sur
l'influence croissante des cabinets de
conseil privé et sur les politiques sur
les politiques publiques présenté dans
son rapport du 16 mars 2022 elle est le
résultat du travail transpartisan que
nous saluons de cette instance de
contrôle temporaire du Sénat rappelons
que la commission du Sénat après 4 mois
d'enquête a révélé un phénomène
tentaculaire l'influence croissante des
cabinets de conseil est privé sur des
pan entiers des politiques publiques
teles que la crise sanitaire la
stratégie nationale de santé l'avenir du
métier d'enseignant la mise en œuvre de
la réforme des es personnels au logement
pour ne citer que ça elle a mis en
lumière des missions plétoriques
externalisées souvent de qualité
médiocre voire non finalisé validé et
payé par l'État à des coûts exorbitants
sans système d'évaluation des
prestations ces abus et dérivent
inacceptabl n'ont pourtant pas freiné
les sort de de l'externalisation des
prestations de conseil la liste des
missions délégées à des cabinets de
conseil privé ces dernières années
témoignent ainsi d' recours massifs et
croissant au cabinet de conseil certes
l'externalisation de mission n'est pas
nouvelle mais elle a doublé depuis 2018
et s'est accéléré en 2021 plus 45 %. en
2021 les dépenses de conseil de l'État
ont ainsi dépassé le milliard d'euros
cette accélération du recours à
l'externalisation soulève aujourd'hui
des questionnements relatifs à la
capacité de la puissance publique à agir
à prendre ses décisions de manière
souveraine et à la bonne utilisation des
donners publicqus
aussi afin de préserver la décision
publique de toute influence de cabinet
de conseil privé de prévenir les
conflits d'intérêts et de rendre
transparent le recours au cabinet privé
cette proposition de loi apparaît
aujourd'hui incontournable celle-ci
n'interdit pas le recours au cabinet de
conseil privé ce n'est pas son but mais
elle vise à encadrer le recours par
l'administration au consultants à
évaluer l'exécution des prestations
fournies tout en imposant une réelle
transparence et en prévoyant un
mécanisme de contrôle et des sanctions
spécifiques si le travail mené au Sénat
a incité le gouvernement à prendre
timidement des mesures telles que la
circulaire du 19 janvier 2022 ou le
jaune budgétaire sur le recours au
conseil extérieur reste que les efforts
engagés sont largement insuffisants le
jaune budgétaire est lacunaire il ne
présente ni la liste des missions de
conseil commandé par l'État ni les
prestations informatiques qui
représentent près des 3/4 des
prestations externalisées de l'État le
contrôle interne renforcé sur le recours
à des prestataires extérieurs apparaît
également très en deà des enjeux aussi
soutenons-nous pleinement cette
proposition de loi dans un souci de
transparence et d'exemplarité pour
conclure au-delà de l'avancée que
constitue cette proposition de loi nous
considérons que l'accélération du
recours à l'externalisation est
aujourd'hui la conséquence du choix de
l'affaiblissement des services publics
qui s'accompagne de la dégradation des
compétences de la puissance publique de
la réduction de ses capacités d'action
et de son étroite dépendance à l'égard
d'opérateurs extérieurs dans de nombreux
domaines l'état ayant externalisé
certaines de ses missions ne possède
plus d'expertise ou les capacités
matérielles nécessaire pour pouvoir
assurer en toute autonomie la mise en
place d'une politique publique pour
rompre ce cercle vicieux l'un des
principaux enjeux consiste aujourd'hui à
réarmer les services publics à procéder
à la réinternalisation progressive des
fonctions les plus stratégiques parmi
celles aujourd'hui sous-traité afin de
redonner à la puissance publique les
moyens de remplir ses missions en toute
indépendance merci Monsieur Paul Molac
pour le groupe liberté indépendant outre
et territoire merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues alors c'est
vrai que les cabinets de conseil sucit
bien de suspicion assez légitime à mon
sens opacité totale coût disproportionné
résultats inégaux voire médiocre et
surtout une influence jugée illégitime
sur la décision publique face à
l'ampleur des scandales min et de
recours incontrôlé au consultant pendant
la péémie le la réponse du gouvernement
sous la forme d'une simple circulaire et
quand même un signe de filosité voire de
culpabilité il est nécessaire
effectivement que notre Parlement S en
part je vais insister d'abord sur le
coût on l'a rappelé l'État a dépensé 1
milliard d'euros en 2021 en prestation
de cabinet de conseil alors notre groupe
s'étonne d'ailleurs de voir le ministère
des Finances arriver avec 20 % du total
des dépenses qui est quand même
considérable pour un ministère qui est
censé faire des économies il a de quoi
s'interroger aussi quand on voit
l'appauvrissement de la fonction
publique certaines rémunérations par
exemple 1528 € une journée de travail de
consultant presque le salaire mensuel
d'un professeur stagiaire ou d'une
infirmière débutante c'est quand même un
peu choquant comment accepter de réduire
les dépenses des administrations tout en
doublant entre 2018 et 2021 les dépenses
de conseil des ministères en
externalisant l'étude on risque de se
voir orienter est-ce le but parce
qu'évidemment il y a des compétences
dans nos ministères et pourquoi ne pas
leur faire
appel second point ce texte porte un
effort de de transparence indéniable
rendre publque et surtout accessible aux
citoyens les données liées au cabinet
conseil en particulier les bilans et
évaluation de chaque prestation est une
avancée dans le même sens alors que le
pantouflage et le lobbying font l'objet
d'un encadrement il était nécessaire de
combler le vide en matière de conseil
cette PPL crée un cadre déontologique
complet et ambitieux sur ce point une
réserve toutefois notre groupe estime
que la saisine de la hatpv gagnerait à
être élargi en l'état seuls les
autorités politiques CAPA de la saisir
serait le premier ministre et les
présidents des deux chambres
parlementaires pourquoi ne pas ouvrir
par exemple à 60 députés ou sénateurs
afin d'accorder un rôle aux opposition
parlementaire enfin je salue le choix de
prévoir un volet répressif dissuasif que
vaudrait une telle loi sans sanction
nous serons surtout attentifs au
maintien de l'amende de 2 % du chiffre
d'affaires mondial du cabinet en cas de
manquement vous l'aurez compris notre
groupe votera résolument pour ce texte
qui fait état d'une belle
avancée madame Emmanuel Ménard pour une
durée de 2
minutes merci monsieur le Président le
18 octobre 2022 le Sénat voté donc cette
proposition de loi destinée à encadrer
l'intervention des cabinets de conseil
privé dans les politiques publiques et
en juillet dernier c'est la cour des
compte qui épinglé une forte
augmentation des dépenses de recours à
des cabinets de conseil par l'État entre
2017 et 2021 de 11 millions d'euros en
2014 elles sont passé à 100 millions en
2018 et 230 millions en 2021 avant un
tassement à 200 million d'euros en 2022
bref si elle ne constitue qu'une part
minime des dépenses de l'État 0,04 %
selon la Cour des comptes elles ont
quand même triplé entre 2017 et 2021 ces
dépenses sont loin d'être anodines et
doivent être contrôlé avec sérieux d'une
part parce qu'il s'agit de l'argent des
contribuables et que les Français à
juste titre sans souci mais aussi parce
qu'elle pose la question des compét et
de l'indépendance de nos institutions je
souhaite pourtant souligner que sur
certains sujets très techniques nos
collectivités locales et même si elles
ne sont pas visées par ce texte ont
besoin de recourir à des cabinets de
conseil et tout n'est donc pas àjeté
fort de ces constatations le texte que
nous étudions aujourd'hui a pour
objectif de renforcer l'encadrement des
prestations et de les rendre plus
transparentes et de prévenir les
conflits d'intérêts il propose également
d'en finir avec l'opacité des
prestations de conseil et interdit les
prestations à titre gracieux sauf dans
des cas spécifiques comme lorsqu'il
s'agit par exemple de fondation reconnu
d'utilité publique cette proposition de
loi propose également de renforcer les
pouvoirs de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique et
prévoit d'encadrer les aller-retours de
personnel entre administration et
cabinet privé tout cela me semble plutôt
positif le recours à ces prestations
externes ne doit pas ne doit plus
constituer une modalité inévitable et
coûteuse de mise en œuvre et parfois il
faut bien le dire de conception de nos
politiques publiques au contraire il
doit retrouver sa juste place parmi tous
les instruments qui sont à la
disposition de nos administrations pour
conduire à bien leur mission de service
public j'aurais quelques amendements à
proposer en ce sens en commission et en
séance je vous remercie messieurs les
rapporteurs pour vos
réponses merci président juste de deux
trois réponses globales on va pas
répondre orateur par orateur mais juste
monsieur le Président vous avez posé des
questions extrêmement pertinente sur le
champ d'application
notamment les prestations informatiques
je crois que on on a une question à se
poser il y a le débat en commission il y
a le débat en séance il y a la navette
ça doit nous permettre de de préciser ce
champ d'application ensuite la question
la question des collectivités je vais
revenir parce que c'est c'est venu sur
tous les bancs pour contre quelle a été
notre philosophie les collectivités ce
ne peut pas être mis sur le même plan
que les administrations centrales la
proposition de loi ça a été dit par
plein de d'entre vous est venu parce
qu'on a vu qu'il y avait des manquements
au sein d'administration centrale où il
y avait un manque de transparence et où
d'ailleurs euh ceux qui commandent qui
commandent la prestation n'ont aucun
compte à rendre ce qui n'est pas le cas
des collectivités territorial quand vous
commandez une prestation vous passez par
l'assemblée délibérante vous passez si
c'est une procédure formalisée par un
marché par un appel d'offre vous avez le
contrôle de l'égalité vous avez la
chambre régionale des comptes vous avez
un compte administratif donc il y a déjà
des des documents il n'empêche que il
faudra trouver une solution pour que les
collectivités territoriales mettent plus
de transparence et de règles
déontologiques c'estàdire qu'on
prévienne aussi les conflits d'intérêts
d'ailleurs pour pour préserver nos élus
locaux c'est aussi c'est aussi un des
une des une des conditions pour
préserver nos élus locaux donc
aujourd'hui je le dis très
tranquillement à à tous mes collègues et
notamment aux collègues avec qui je
travaille régulièrement
intégrer les collectivités
directement comme cela en en prenant les
mêmes dispositions c'est-à-dire en ayant
par exemple un document qui intègre le
les prestations de l'État avec les
prestations des collectivités ça n'a pas
de sens à mon avis parce que c'est on a
par exemple sur le jaune budgétaire de
l'État ce qui est dépensé par l'État on
peut avoir un jaune budgétaire sur les
relations de l'État avec les
collectivités territoriales mais on n
pas les budgets des collectivités sur un
jaune budgétaire de l'État c'est pas
vrai donc il faut à tout prix il faut à
tout prix qu'on trouve une solution
cette solution elle ne se fera pas sans
les élus elle se fera encore moins
contre les élus donc ça veut dire que il
faut reprendre notre bâton de pèlerin
sur faire un diagnostic précis une
évaluation précise du marché du Conseil
Local ça a été dit par quelques un
comment on fait en sorte de ne
pas rigidifier le marché pour du conseil
pour les petites structures et faut
regarder aussi comment on fait pour que
les collectivités locales ce soient pas
trop lourd mais que ce soit transparent
c'est ça
l'objectif donc pour ma part j'avais
plaidé et ça a été rappelé par notre
collègue goselin et par par le président
Houlier j'avais plaidé à la fin de la
mission flash pour une évaluation faite
par la délégation au collectivité elle
n'a pas eu lieu et bien on se retrouve
dans la même dans la même situation donc
j'ai j'appelle vraiment tout le monde à
se dire aujourd'hui les collectivités il
faut le traiter par la délégation au
collectivités par une mission
d'information ou par un rapport
gouvernemental mais en tout cas on peut
pas le régler comme ça je rappelle aussi
qu'il y a quand même l'article de la
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales et que si on pense qu'un
seuil de population est une solution ce
n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas vrai parce
qu'il va y avoir rupture d'égalité il va
y avoir rupture d'égalité c'est pour ça
qu'on a cherché avec avec Bruno milien à
trouver une solution par les seuils de
marché publics c'est-à-dire est-ce que
de gré à gré il y a peu de peu de de
d'exigence et puis quand on est en
procédure formalisée bien on demande
plus d'exigen c'est en tout cas une des
pistes qu'on avait étudié je pense
qu'elle n'est pas mûre donc moi je vous
invite sur les collectivités à aussi
faire confiance aux collectivités mais
faire confiance aussi je l'espère à la
dégélation aux collectivités territorial
pour prendre ce sujet à bras le corp
voilà ce que je voulais dire sur les
collectivités et puis n'oublions pas
n'oublions pas que ce ce texte qui sort
du Sénat qui est
transpartisan on a besoin de rester à
peu près dans l'épure de ce qui est
sorti du
Sénat et là je vais je vais répondre à à
Frédéric Mathieu un petit pas vaut mieux
que 1000 programmes qu disait Lénine
donc n'oublions jamais nou non je fais
exprès faut bien faut bien que je les
amuse et
donc ah c'était juste et et je pense que
il faut faut que sur cette question de
la transparence de la
déontologie et et de et de du contrôle
on soit à même de sortir quelque chose
qui soit opérant
merci allez donc on va pouvoir pardon
monsieur le rapporteur Milan allez-y oui
merci monsieur le Président je vais être
assez bref non vous voyez bien l'esprit
qui nous a animé avec Nicolas et je le
remercie encore une fois parce qu'on a
travaillé en bonne intelligence et de
manière très réaliste et objective je
pas en remettre une couche sur les
collectivités territoriales mais
franchement des amendements que j'ai vu
les amendements qui ont été posés qui se
basaient sur les seuils de population ne
tiennent pas on a tourné les choses dans
tous les sens on avait trouvé Nicolas
l'a dit une une une une une demi-olution
mais la demi-olution nécessite plus
encore je vous sign quand même que pour
appliquer ce texte de loi à l'état il y
a eu une commission d'enquête il y a eu
une mission flash enfin on se base pas
sur n'importe quoi et vous pouvez me
croire je m'adresse notamment madame
huntermer vous pouvez me croire Madame
huntermerer parce que quand on est
arrivé au moment de travailler ensemble
le le plus fervant partisan d'inclure
les collectivités territoriales c'était
moi donc si vraiment c'est pas une
reculade si vraiment je dis qu'il faut
qu'on s'intéresse à la question que la
délégation collectivité territoriale
doit impérativement s'emparer du sujet
que je demande aussi à l'état de
produire un rapport là-dessus c'est
parce qu'effectivement il nous faut plus
de transparence on le sait mais le texte
tel qu'il est issu du Sénat ne peut en
aucun cas être applicable comme il est
écrit aux collectivités territoriales ça
n'a pas de sens faut que soit un texte à
part bon je reviendrai pas sur sur
toutes les toutes les questions toutes
les remarques que vous nous avez fait
quelques remarques quand même je
voudrais vous signaler que mainse est
sorti des cabinets de conseil qui
travaill avec l'État monsieur housoussin
moi j'aimerais être sûr que Monsieur Mac
Poutine est sorti aussi de vos cabinet
de conseil voilà c'est juste comme ça au
passage donc ne basez pas tout votre
argumentaire sur minse minse n'existe
plus dans les administrations ni à
l'état je voudrais vous signaler quand
même aussi que depuis la commission
d'enquête et ça sa très grande grande
force aussi la commission d'enquête et
ce texte de loi fait par les sénateurs
l'État n'est pas resté sans rien faire
je crois que c'est Madame Miller qui l'a
rappelé la circulaire Castex la
circulaire borne et mais le but ce n'est
pas d'interdire les cabinets de conseil
encore une fois c'est de voir comment on
peut mieux encadrer leur activité en
terme de transparence et déontologie
sans mettre à mal non plus je tiens à le
préciser sans mettre à mal non plus le
travail de nos fonctionnaires il est pas
question de faire peser une charge sur
nos fonctionnaires qu'il ne pourrai pas
tenir voilà c'est l'esprit que qui nous
a habité pendant toute l'étude de ce
texte et j'espère que les nombreux
amendements qu'on va poser sur ce texte
qui ne dénature pas l'esprit du texte
des sénateur mais qui date quand même un
petit peu il y a eu des choses qui ont
été faites depuis vous conviendra et que
ce texte sera voté par la Commission et
ensuite dans l'hémicycle
merci on va pouvoir appeler les
amendements sur ce texte on commence par
l'amendement avant l'article 1er
messieurs les rapporteurs c'est un
rédactionnel le 109
défendu je le mets au voix qui vote pour
contre adopté à l'article 1er monsieur
Pradal vous avez un amendement allez-y
oui oui monsieur le Président merci il
s'agit en fait de préciser le champ
d'application de la loi en visant
seulement les conseils qui visent à
éclairer illustrer ou accompagner
l'élaboration des politiques
publiques monsieur les rapporteur oui
monsieur praval l'objet de votre
amendement si j'ai bien compris c'est
vous l'avez rappelé c'est de préciser la
de prestation de conseil votre
amendement limiterait en revanche
considérablement le champ du texte alors
je vois bien qu'il a été travaillé avec
Satec ça m'étonne pas avec SYTEC conseil
donc ne serait plus concerné ne serait
plus concerné que les prestations les
plus stratégique dans lesquel
l'administration demande un appui dans
l'élaboration d'une politique publique
bon nous pensons que les obligations de
transparence et les règlesentologique
doivent s'appliquer au-delà de ce champ
donc j'ai met un avis
défavorable alors je vais mettre au voix
cet amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
rejetéamendement suivant le 110 monsieur
le
rapporteuryysieur c'est bon
pard nous avons
souhaité restreindre le champ
d'application aux établissements publics
qui ont plus de 60 million d'euros de
budget parce qu'il nousble que les tout
petits issement et il y en a 800 he qui
sont qui sont concernés aujourd'hui par
par par la
PPL les tout petits établissements ça
n'a pas ça n'a pas de sens voilà je je
le dis tel quel et on voit bien que la
question c'est essentiellement au sein
des administrations centrale et
notamment dans le cadre des accords
cadres donc si on veut rester dans
l'esprit de la loi ça ne change rien et
et ça permet notamment je le dis parce
qu'il y a les petits épades adossés aux
hôpitaux qui étaient concernés par
exemple petits épades qui peuvent avoir
7 8 10 millions d'euros de budget ça me
semblait excessif ça nous semblait
excessif de mettre les mêmes règles que
pour une administration centrale qui
vient voir si faut changer le métier
d'enseignant alors a un amendement
identique de Madame poussier
vincebac il est défendu avec avis
favorable des rapporteurs donc je le
mets au voix qui vote pour pardon
monsieur gosin excusez-moi monsieur
gosin vous avez pas vu oui petite petite
intervention monsieur le Président parce
que ce seuil de de 60 millions voilà bon
il est pris sur le les approches
commande publique et cetera n'a pas
vraiment de de cohérence en tant que tel
pourquoi 60 pourquoi pas 50 pourquoi pas
100 c'est quand même la la la la
difficulté puis sur le fond en réalité
on ne connaît pas la liste des
établissements publics qui qui qui
pourrait être ainsi exclu alors on sait
qu'on peut en mentionner quelques-uns
bon très bien mais pour le reste
honnêtement c'est pas très clair là je
trouve que sur un tel amendement on est
un peu à l'aveugle je suis pas
arquebouté dessus mais mais voilà ça
sort du chapeau quand même al monsieur
rapporteur sensu non ça s pas du chapeau
ça a été déjà discuté au Sénat euh donc
ça avait été ça a été exclu au Sénat on
se rend compte quand même qu'on on
intègre tout un tas de tout petits
établissements publics qui nous semble
difficile et puis c'est un seuil qui est
déjà
connu dans le cadre de des avances qui
sont versées dans le cadre de marché
c'est tout alors après rien à voir ave
attendez c'est pas pas mais après euh
notre question c'est est-ce qu'on garde
les 800 ou 1000 établissements y compris
les tout petits musées qui peuvent avoir
besoin de de refaire une petite
politique de communication avec un
marché à 10000 € et qui vont être soumis
aux mêmes règles que que Boston
Consulting Group qui va travailler pour
le ministère des Finances je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit très
opérant donc je mets au voix les
amendements identiques qui vote
pour qui vote contre sont
adoptés alors le suivant est un
amendement rapporteur monsieur men oui
merci Monsieur le le président cet
amendement vise à supprimer l' l'alinéa
4 euh c'est un amendement qui propose
donc d'exclure la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation du champ des
administrations bénéficiaires parce que
si c'est un établissement public c'est
un établissement public très particulier
on s'en explique plus tard dans le texte
on a deux amendements c'est-à-dire
concernant la la caiss des dépôts qui
leur convient mieux que le champ
d'application qu'on a là donc c'est pour
ça que je vous propose l'adoption de la
suppression d'alinaak on reviendra sur
la Caisse des Dépôts après avec deux
amendements que nous portons plus loin
et qui les concernne
directement tu veux Nicolas ou pas non
alors Monsieur bernalissis
oui merci alors moi je vois pas pourquoi
on on exclurait la Caisse des dépôts ou
qu'on leur ferait quelque chose de plus
sur mesure euh sauf à à avoir des normes
plus contraignantes pour la Caisse de
dépôt et consignation parce que c'est
peut-être un secteur encore plus
sensible en réalité euh à encadrer et
aller regarder de plus près parce que
ils ont des activités financières
économiques sur le champ concurrentiel
qui touche encore plus à la porosité
avec la sphère la sphère privée donc se
voir conseiller par des gens qui sont
eux-mêmes dans la sphère privée qui ont
des intérêts économiques pour faire des
opérations certes a priori pour le
compte de l'État je suis pas sûr que
l'exclure de ce genre de dispositif ce
soit le mieux indiqué justement la
spécificité de la la Caisse des Dépôts
et Consignation pousse à ce que elle
soit bien dans le dispositif pour
l'exclure des cabinets conseil du fait
de la sensibilité et peut-être même du
potentiel corruptif bien monsieur Bernal
si j'entends ce que vous dites mais un
la Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation il
y a un comité de surveillance dans
lequel siège des sénateurs et des
députés donc c'est quand même un
établissement public dont le contrôle
est fait par nos assemblées c'est quand
même peut-être mieux que ce que vous
espériez mais alors ou alors vous mettez
en cause effectivement les uté d'une
part d'autre part d'autre
part d'autre part d'autre part d'autre
part cet établissement public comprend
dans ses personnels à la fois des
personnes de droit privé et des
personnes de droit public mais si vous
voulez pas écouter ce que je dis je
m'arrête
là bien donc je mets au voix
l'amendement du rapporteur qui vote pour
ah pardon Monsieur S vouz excusez-moi
monsieur le Président juste pour pour on
a un problème avec les établissement
public CAE de dépôts qui est suigénérie
voilà c'est il y a un sujet il y a un
sujet de droit alors j'entends hein
l'obligation de
transparence de contrôle de déontologie
qui soit la même chose mais euh je je
pense que il faut trouver une solution
adaptée qui ne soit pas avec c'est pas
un établissement public de l'État c'est
pas un EPA c'est pas un épique c'est un
établissement public suit générique donc
qui n'a qui n'a pas de contrôle de
l'État alors ça veut dire que l'intégrer
dans l'article 1 me semble complètement
faux mais peut-être que on peut trouver
une solution c'est pour ça qu'on propose
un amendement spécifique à l'article
après l'article 3 je crois après
l'article 3 qui demande à la Caisse des
dépôts de faire un rapport au Parlement
sur la question des cabinets conseil
reprenant les obligations de l'article 3
sur toute la transparence et et et
reprenant des règles déontologiques
sachant qu'ils ont évidemment aussi un
déontologue et avec les les mêmes
obligations mais qui soit au Parlement
et non pas et non pas dans ce voilà
c'est c'est ce qui c'est ce qui nous a
conduit à proposer ce
retrait donc cette fois-ci on va voter
qui vote pour qui vot
contre qu' est adopté
oui il est largement adopté madameille
le
11 madame l'amendement numéro 11 oui
merci monsieur le Président excusez-moi
en fait c'est c'est un sujet dont nous
avons beaucoup parler nous avons déposé
un amendement c'est vrai que 100000
100000 habitants n'est peut-être pas la
la la la la
solution mais il me semble extrêmement
difficile d'examiner un tel texte sans
intégrer les
collectivité les collectivités
territoriales ça n'est pas possible
l'État a fait d'une commission d'enquête
il y a une circulaire on est déjà dans
la régulation avec l'État et il me
semble qu'il faut absolument qu'on
envoie sinon des mesures coercitives en
tout cas un message aux collectivités
territoriales il faut qu'on travaille
pour la séance parce que je sais que cet
amendement sera rejeté mais il est
évident que nous devons travailler sur
ce sujet on ne peut pas imaginer
ostraciser l'État et laisser de côté
tout le pan de l'action publique porté
par les collectivités territoriales en
considérant que la
DGCL qui est elle-même pourvoyeuse de
cabinet de conseil auprès des
collectivités locales va nous donner la
solution nous devons et c'est notre
travail de législateur quelquefois c'est
difficile mais nous ne pouvons pas
rebondir de mission en rapport pour
régler cette question c'est pourquoi
nous maintenons bien sûr cette cette cet
amendement nous en proposerons sans
doute un autre à la séance en majorant
le seuil parce que 100000 ça me paraît à
la réflexion effectivement peut-être
excessif c'est pas la question du seuil
mais c'est quand la question dupe de la
transparence c'est quand même plus grave
d'abandonner l'idée de transparence pour
les collectivités local que d'afficher
un se qui n'est pas parfait voilà la
raison pour laquelle nous défendons cet
amendement alors qui défendamendement
madame l rassemblement
national c'est Monsieur Ramb allez-y
monsieuramb alors attendez je vousends
la parole pasoup son micro
allez-ys allezyy
l'amendement dont il est question ici
vise à étendre cette loi régissant les
prestations de conseil réalisé par les
prestataires et les consultants aux
collectivités territoriales pour les
communes comptant plus de 350000
habitants à l'occasion de leur mission
flash sur le champ d'application de la
proposition de loi encadrant
l'intervention des cabinets de conseil
privé dans les politiques publiques les
sénateurs Lebec et sensu ont remarqué
que la nature des prestations de conseil
aux collectivités locales
recouvrait une très grande diversité en
raison de la variété de leurs
compétences dans cette perspective les
prestations au profit des collectivités
territoriales peuvent apparaître
particulièrement flou et il semble
nécessaire que la loi encadre leur usage
au moins pour les communes du taille
d'une taille importante cet encadrement
permettrait de limiter d'éventuelles
situations de conflit d'intérêt mais
aussi de faire la lumière sur l'absence
de transparence relative au coût des
missions commandées
alors monsieur housoussin vous avez un
amendement également dans la discussion
commune je précise tout de suite que les
amendements identiques ne sont pas dans
la discussion commune ils pent sur un
alinéa
suivant allez-y monsieurin monsieur
Rambo allez c'est bon c'est où ça tac
voilà c'est allumé merci monsieur le
Président oui on a déjà eu ce ce débat
un petit peu en audition on l'a déjà eu
plusieurs fois aujourd'hui de savoir
s'il fallait ajouter ou non à ce texte
les collectivités locales on aé que
c'était compliqué d'ajouter notamment
des milliers de de communes à un système
qui est quand même complexe des communes
qui ont souvent plutôt recours à des
petits cabinés locaux qui prennent pas
forcément des décisions qui sont très
politiques qui font beaucoup aussi
recours à du conseil pour de la
passation de marché on avait un risque
d'en liser le texte par contre le
constat nous semble quand même
relativement différent pour ce qui est
des régions et des départements donc ce
ce cet amendement propose d'ajouter les
régions et les
départements puisqu'ils ont des budgets
en milliards euros ou en centaines de
millions qu'ils ont des services
internes qui sont importants qu'ils
prennent des décisions qu'ils sont plus
politiques et puis qu'ils ont des
budgets relativement comparables le le
ministère de la Santé grosso modo c'est
2 milliards et demi la culture c'est 4
milliards le département du Nord c'est 4
milliards aussi de budget le grand test
4 milliards et demi donc on ne voit pas
pourquoi on exclurait les départements
et les régions je vais juste revenir de
minutes sur l'amendement 11 qui nous a
été proposé et qui fixait un seuil de
100000 habitants c'est un amendement sur
lequel on est philosophiquement plutôt
favorable mais ce qui nous fait peur
c'est le risque de retarder voire
d'empêcher l'adoption de ce texte
important par les deux chambre donc on y
sera pas forcément favorable mais il
doit y avoir des travaux sur
l'encadrement des du recours au
Conseil des collectivité local ça peut
être l'objet soit d'une mission
d'information soit d'une commission
d'enquête alors messieurs les rapporteur
sur ces trois amendements oui rapidement
monsieur le Président parce qu'on a déjà
beaucoup discuté sincèrement pour avoir
étudié avec Nicolas sensu les les seuils
en nombre d'habitants franchement ça
vole pas vous pouvez avoir pouvez avoir
une collectivité à 50000 une
collectivité à 100000 celles qui sont
pas ou 500000 celles qui ne sont pas
concerné par les seuils que vous mettez
pourrait avoir à faire appel à des des
amo par exemple pour des sommes bien
plus importantes que des petites choses
faites sur les communes à 100000 ou à
500000 habitants ou sur les
collectivités à 100000 500000 qui elle
serait obligé de fournir tous les tous
les les dispositifs prévus dans la loi
ce qui n'est pas possible ce qui n'est
pas possible c'est pour ça qu'on a on a
trouvé d'ailleurs enfin on a trouvé
cette solution en passant par le seuil
de la commande publique même si elle
était pas je vous l'avoue franchement
euh plébiscité par les associations
d'élus je vais être très frond avec vous
en tout cas leur semblait être la
solution la plus adaptée donc il y a
peut-être une piste là-dessus donc je
veux franchement l'idée madame termerer
ce n'est pas d'abandonner l'histoire sur
les collectivités territoriales d'où la
demande de rapport effectivement dans le
qu'on demande dans ce dans cette
proposition de loi et d'où la demande
réitérée je sais pas si David Valence
nous entend mais à la délégation
collectivités territorial pour qu'on
approfondisse les choses et qu'on puisse
faire quelque chose ce qui régit nos
collectivités territoriales avec tous
les contrôles qu'il y a n'a rien à voir
avec ce qui régit l'état donc faisons
les choses en fonction de la réalité de
ce qu'il y a sur le terrain et pas en
fonction de quelque chose qu'on veut et
que beaucoup veulent mais simplement
calquer sur un texte qui n'est
absolument pas adapté à ce pour les
collectivités territoriales voilà donc
je serais évidemment défavorable à tous
ces amendements ou retrait ou
retrait monsur rapporteur moi j'entends
bien votre votre volonté de de
transparence et je pense qu'on la
partage tous et et la volonté de ne pas
exclure les collectivités du champ de ce
texte au-delà on pourrait imaginer comme
ça ça pratique comme ça se pratique
pardon pour d'autres thématique non pas
une délibération dans les collectivités
territoriales une délibération qui
devrait être votée mais à minima un
rapport
annuel un rapport annuel obligatoire qui
permettrait en toute transparence
d'indiquer à quel moment les maires les
présidents de conseil départementaux
régionaux ont fait appel à des cabinets
conseil pour faire quoi alors après
c'est tout à fait compréhensible j'en
discutis à l'instant avec ma collègue
céciletermerer la technici C qui est
demandé aujourd'hui aux agents des
collectivités territoriales est telle
que à un moment donné bien sûr nous
pensons qu'il qu' qu'il est légitime de
faire appel à des cabinets conseil donc
pourquoi ne pas tout si on est d'accord
pourquoi ne pas tout simplement dans cet
esprit de
transparence imposer un rapport annuel
qui explique quel cabinet conseil ont
été sollicités pour quel montant et sur
quelle thématique
etz-mexpression tout le monde serait
content
merci monsieur le Président juste pour
préciser ces informations là existent il
faut juste les mettre en avant vous avez
un compte administratif où de facto les
voilà donc j'avais proposé dans le cadre
des auditions je j'avais poser cette
question est-ce que lors du document
d'orientation budgétaire on peut pas
avoir un paragraphe qui explique où
est-ce qu'on fait appel au recours au
cabinet conseil et pourquoi et puis en
compte administratif de faire une page
spécifique sur cette questionl donc ça
c'est possible le problème c'est que
c'est pas la même chose que ce qu'on
alors après on peut avoir les mêmes
obligations he après on a un vrai
problème sur les déclarations d'intérêt
si vous avez des des des des dizaines et
des dizaines de déclarations de sur
l'honneur de non conflit d'intérêts de
ceux qui interviennent dans les
collectivités comment vous faites avec
le centre de gestion qui fait la
déontologie on a tout un tas de problème
qu'il faut gérer je je le dis c'est on
n'est pas il y a 35000 communes si on
décide si on décide que toutes sont sont
sont concerné en fonction du seuil de de
marché public mais comme l'a dit mon
collègue si vous avez un un logo dans un
centre social de la Mairie de Paris qui
coûte 1500 balles 1500 € et que vous
avez euh un un PLU un PLU 400000 si si
si si si ça rentre non non non ça rentre
c'est c'est dedans aujourd'hui c'est
dans le champ d'application et si vous
avez un un cabinet conseil sur le plui à
400000 € dans une dans une
intercommunalité de 30000 habitants on
peut pas avoir la question du seuil de
population c'est tout simplement ça donc
je pense que ce serait ce serait faire
erreur que de vouloir forcer le passage
sur les collectivités tout de suite et
je vais même vous dire je je pense que
ça risquerait de faire tomber tout le
texte donc moi je je me dis que on va
pas lâcher la proie pour l'ombre et que
on travaille sur ce sujet qui a été
identifié par les sénateurs et on
continue le travail sur les
collectivités pour faire quelque chose
de propre à l'issue d'un travail de de
notre délégation
collectivité alors d'abord monsieur
Pradal Monsieur goselin Madame et ensite
monsieur Paris VO oui merci monsieur le
Président sur ce sujet pour les
collectivités non pas les plus
importantes mais les plus peuplé ou les
régions et les départements comment se
passeattribution d'un marché public
d'abord l'assemblée délibérante elle va
autoriser la conclusion du marché ensite
il va y avoir une commission d'appel
d'offre dans laquelle dans ces
collectivités l'opposition est
représentée dès lors que la commission
d'appel d'offre a statué le marché est
transmis au contrôle de l'égalité qui
est exercé par les services de l'État
puis ensuite une fois par an et vous
avez bien fait de le rappeler monsieur
le rapporteur je remercie monsieur le
rapporteur sensu un document est publié
dans la presse locale et dans la presse
nationale et également fourni au conseil
municipal ou à l'assemblée délibérante
pour les régions et les départements qui
fait la liste de tous les marchés en
indiquant en clair l'objet de la
prestation pour les marchés de
prestation puis nous avons les contrôles
de la chambre régionale des comptes que
voulons-nous de plus à part un effet qui
pourrait être obtenu qui serait que seul
les prestataires les plus importants
fourniront clé en main les informations
supplémentaires qui doivent être
fournies par les collectivités diront
ainsi à l'éviction de ceux qui font le
service au plus près et de ces cabinets
de conseil qui interviennent parfois sur
une politique culturelle qui
interviennent parfois sur
l'accompagnement d'une politique
sportive et qui ferait ainsi disparaître
du paysage ceux qui travaillent le plus
sérieusement au plus près et depuis
longtemps au service des collectivités
nous sommes farouchement opposés et je
suis d'accord avec vous messieurs les
rapporteurs si une disposition de ce
type était adopté cela remettrait en
cause l'équilibre du texte en tout cas
le vote de notre groupe monsieur goselin
oui je crois que il y a il y a un souci
de transparence qui est louable et que
l'on partage tous il y a pas de de
difficulté et les collectivité local ne
peuvent pas soustraire un certain nombre
d'obligations mais justement ces
obligations et Philippe Pradal vient de
le rappeler pour une part elles existent
déjà on a les contrôles des chambres
régionales des comptes les contrôles des
comptable public hein je je rappelle
qu'on a le compte de gestion et et et le
compte administratif
qui doivent être concordants et qui sont
adoptés chaque année après l'exécution
budgétaire on a les rapports annuels qui
ont été évoqués par Philippe Pradal on a
les élus d'opposition qui ont un rôle de
proximité qui est aussi parfois de grat
poil ça peut créer quelques difficultés
mais c'est quand même un un
fonctionnement plus simple dans nos
collectivités en général qu'au Parlement
soyons soyons clair donc je crois qu'en
réalité
on a déjà un ensemble conséquent
aujourd'hui aller au-delà sans une
expertise supplémentaire me paraît
complètement dangereux mais non il y a
pas eu Cécile un termailleur il y a pas
eu Cécile de de rapport de la délégation
par exemple aux collectivités ou de la
commission des lois sur les
collectivités et et je crois que si
c'est une autre étape il faut préparer
cette étape avec des documents qui
permettent d'évaluer les montants les
conditions les manquements le le le le
les conflits de règles de transparence
le cas échéant mais aujourd'hui
honnêtement on a rien donc moi je veux
bien qu'on qu' qu'on mette beaucoup mais
il y a déjà pas mal de choses sur les
collectivités locales ce n'est pas si
simple et pour terminer la règle des des
des 100000 habitants on en revient
toujours aux effets de seuil alors je je
dis pas que ça soit le mal absolu on a
bien dans le CGCT dans le Code général
des collectivités territoriales des des
seuils et cetera de 3500 10000 100000
bref mais c'est pas parce qu'on a une
collect
é je ve dire la proposition qui est
faite par ROG VI ellemane de quelqu'un
qui a été maire pendant 10 ans qui sait
comment ça marche dans une collectivité
locale je veux dire la proposition que
nous faisons qui est plus dans la
communication par que les chiffres il
existent sinon onurait pas découvert
sait les chiffres existent mais par
contre ils ne sont lus par personne nous
nous sommes dans un souci de
communication et de restaurer la
confiance entre les collectivités aussi
parce qu'elles connaissent ce souci-là
et le citoyen par une transparence et
une opération de communication on vous
demande pas d'aller dans un jaune
budgétaire personne va le lire le jaune
budgétaire on va on vous demande il
n'existe pas dans les collectivités
locales mais un rapport annuel de
synthèse des des communes des
collectivités locales
pas pas de 100000 habitants toutes les
collectivités locales pour information
de la population non ça n'existe pas
c'est il faut que la loi identifie il
faut que la loi identifie une obligation
pour les collectivités locales de de
d'informer leur population d'un recours
au cabinet de conseil non pas que ce
soit une chose mauvaise ou interdite et
et malsine mais parce que on est dans
une exigence de transparence que on
s'applique on applique à l'état et qu'on
doit appliquer au collectivités
locale alors Monsieur Paris
oui merci monsieur le Président moi sur
le fond je suis vraiment pas persuadé
que le moment soit opportun pour ajouter
des couches et des pressions aux
collectivités territoriales et je
rejoins très volontiers les propos de
Philippe Pradal et Philippe goselin dans
le sens où la différence entre un
ministère et une collectivité c'est que
vous avez une opposition dans une
collectivité plus la collectivité est
grande plus l'opposition est structurée
et dynamique donc en réalité l'ensemble
emble des dispositions de contrôle comme
ça a été très bien rappelé par monsieur
le rapporteur sont déjà à la disposition
des éléments politiques de contrôle qui
s'agisse de de de de la publication des
marchés publics qui s'agisse de
l'analyse de des des des comptes
annuels on a tous travaillé dans ces
conditions là on sait très exactement
les comment les choses se déroulent et
il faut évidemment ajouter ça a été
rappelé je vais pas le faire dans le
détail mais les chambres régionales des
compte le contrôle de l'égalité j'étaéis
danscore préfectural je sais comment ça
marche enfin bon ne rajoutons pas dans
ce dans ce contexte et avec aussi peu de
travail préparatoire sur une question
aussi lourde au plan politique visé des
collectivités territoriales des
dispositions qui ne rajouteraient
strictement rien en terme de capacité
d'auto d'autocensure ou d'auto gestion
ou d'autocontrôle de leur propre part
voilà c'est donc la vie queon apporte
compris au plan du groupe
majoritaire le rapporteur oui merci
monsieur le Président très rapidement je
pense que c'est un débat qu'on aura
encore dans l'hémicycle mais madame
ununtermerer je je vous assure que le
but des rapporteurs n'était pas
d'écarter les collectivités
territoriales comme vous semblz le faire
mais d'arriver à faire un travail précis
au regard de ce qu'on connaît de qu de
ce qu'elles sont obligé de déclarer
d'une information qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui si on cherche un peu vous
avez raison de dire personne non mais
attendez mais vous pouvez pas dire que
l'information n'existe pas vous ne
pouvez pas dire que les collectivités
territoriales ne sont pas contrôlées ni
par le contrôle de l'égalité ni par la
chambre régionale des comptes ni par les
oppositions ni par les oppositions donc
elles sont contrôlées je je tiens à ce
qu'on le Fass et je le répète encore une
fois vous savez de quel territoire je
suis élu c'est peut-être pour ça aussi
que je tiens à ce que ce soit fait donc
voilà mais mais franchement on ne peut
pas y aller juste comme ça avec un petit
amendement ou deux petits amendements en
disant on a mis un coinut je vous assure
qu'il faut faire le travail très
sérieusement avec avec des missions une
mission de la mais je vous le promets à
la délégation collectivité territoriale
moi quand j'ai rejoint Nicolas encore
une fois je vous le rappelle c'était
pour les inclure franchement on aurait
rajouté un mois de plus à nos travaux on
y serait pas arrivé il nous faut
vraiment alors là ça peut être
transpartisan il nous faut vraiment
faire une une étude complémentaire
là-dessus pour avoir quelque chose qui
s'applique spécifiquement au
collectivité territoriale mais qui peut
pas être tiré du du texte qui s'appelle
aux administrations et à l'état c'est
pas possible donc avec toute franchement
je vous le dis avec avec sincérité et
c'est pas pour aller contre donc je
réitère demande de retrait ou alors
défavorable bon je mettre au voix ses
amendements on commence par l'amendement
numéro 11 de madamemeilleur qui vote
pour quiote contre il est
rejeté l'amendement 70 de madame lerau
qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté le 75 de
Monsieur Housin pour contre rejeté le 97
madame
Miller et voilà merci monsieur le
Président alors en fait très rapidement
depuis la loi du 21 juillet 2009 qui
porte sur la réforme de l'hôpital et
relative aux patients à la santé et au
territoire qui a modifié les articles L
6141-1 et suivant du code de la santé
publique tous les établissements publics
de santé sont bien des établissements
publics de l'État l'AL 5 est donc
superfl c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous proposons tout simplement de le
supprimer oui on a exactement le même
amendement madame effectivement s aperçu
dans ce texte que cet amendement ne
servait à rien donc on propose cet aliné
ne servait à rien donc on propose de le
supprimer donc excessivement
favorable au vo qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté le
suivant monsieur pr numéro
2 oui merci Monsieur le présidentj
amendement et de renvoyer un décret les
prestations de conseil qui se révisé par
la loi en effet euh et de la Ve même des
rapporteurs il s'agit d'être le plus
possible dans l'exhaustivité or il me
semble que la loi n'est pas le véhicule
le plus adapté à la fois pour
l'exhaustivité et la réactivité qu'il
faut chercher à avoir si demain un type
de prestation nouveau arrive faudra-t-il
à nouveau un débat au Parlement pour
l'inclure dans le périmètre c'est pour
cela que je propose par cet amendement
de renvoyer au décret la définition des
prestations en prend d'application de la
loi monsieur le rapporteur euh
oui monsieur le Président euh
faut je je ne voudrais pas voir de Malis
derrière cet amendement mais confier au
gouvernement le soin de définir ce qui
va être contrôlé comme prestation de
conseil je pense qu'il aurait peut-être
une petite tendance à diminuer le champ
des prestations et même à en faire une
coquille vide donc il nous semble que le
législateur est mieux placé de pour le
faire et et les prestations qui sont
aujourd'hui incluses ont été celles qui
ont été discutées au Sénat elles me
semble bonnes et dans l'esprit de la loi
préservons
cela cet amendement qui vote pour qui
vote contre rejeté le 49 madame pano
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui propose de revenir sur
l'exclusion des prestations
informatiques et de maintenance en
informatique qui avait été exclus du
champ de de cette proposition de loi bon
d'abord parce que c'est des montants
énormes en 2021 c'était 448 millions
d'euros soit la moitié des prestations
de conseil qui sont des prestations
informatiques ensuite parce que ces
prestations explosent entre 2018 et 2021
le conseil en stratégie des systèmes
d'information a été multiplié par 5,8 et
d'ailleurs le rapport du Sénat Poé
lui-même dans la relation de dépendance
la la particularité sur le domaine
informatique il se trouve que dans le le
le livre des de Mathieu Haron et
Caroline Mel Michel hair pardon Les
Infiltrés il révèle que près de 90 % des
grands projets numériques sont au mains
de cabinet qui sont la plupart du temps
étrangers ce qui pose évidemment un
problème avec des contrats qui sont des
pièges puisque on fabrique des
applications de mauvaise qualité puis
ensuite il y a un tarif de maintenance
exorbitant qui sont augmentés quand
l'État est devenu prisonnier du
prestataire donc je crois qu'il est très
important de revenir sur cette exclusion
d'autant que c'est à l'Agence nationale
de la sécurité des systèmes
d'information de soutenir les directions
en manque d'effectifs qui ont des
recrutements insuffisants donc c'est
pour paser au manque de recrutement donc
il faut augmenter le nombre de
fonctionnaires et réintroduire les
prestations
informatiques alors madame Miller pour
le
98 merci monsieur le Président les
prestations d'expertise technique et
informatique sont assez particulières et
nécessite un régime juridique distinct
ou au moins quelques spécificités on
suggère donc de laisser s'appliquer la
circulaire de la première ministre donc
du 8 février 2023 relative au pilotage
et à l'encadrement du recours aux
prestations intellectuelles informatique
et d'éventuellement légiférer à
postériori si la circulaire n'est pas
efficiente monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
sur l'amendement 49 madame Panau
l'exclusion des prestations de
programmation et de maintenance c'est
quelque chose qui a été proposé par la
rapporteur du texte au Sénat et qui étit
souhaité par les auteurs du texte il
s'agit de prestations courantes qui ne
sont pas de nature à influencer la
décision publique en revanche et vous
l'avez constaté j'en suis sûr le Sénat a
maintenu le conseil stratégique en
informatique dans le champ du texte en
cohérence avec les constats d'ailleurs
de sa commission d'enquête donc là on
est raccord donc ce sera un avis
défavorable sur le vote et Madame Miller
ça serait une demande de retrait ou
sinon défavorable parce que votre
amendement a pour effet d'exclure du
champ du texte les prestations d'appuis
et d'expertise technique et de
réalisation informatique ça limite donc
un peu quand même le champ d'application
du texte soyons clair au conseil en
stratégie numérique ou en stratégie
numérique des politiques publiques ce
sont aussi des prestations stratégiques
qui peuvent présenter un risque
d'influence sur la décision publique et
qu'il faut contrôler plus fortement donc
voilà je je je
c'est pour les deux finalement je suis
assez défavorable il y en a une demande
de retrait pareil pour vous Madame c'est
je fais mon centriste
voilà merci monsieur le Président sur
l'amendement 49 le groupe nationale sera
plutôt favorable pour nous il y a il y a
un vrai sujet au vu des chiffres ces
prestations elles représentent quand
même 450 millions d'euros par an ce qui
est considérable on sait que le
ministère de la Justice assure en
interne seulement 9 % de ses prestations
informatiques les affaires étrangères 10
% la culture 14 % la direction
interministérielle du numérique
auditionnée par la commission d'enquête
du Sénat affirmé que 90 à 95 % de la
maîtrise des grands projets
informatiques ou des technologies est
externalisé ce qui nous pose aussi un
problème de coût surtout qu'on a
beaucoup recours aussi à des cabinets
étrangers il y a le sujet aussi des
contrats de TMA c'est-à-dire de tierce
maintenance applicative on fait appel à
des consultants qui font une application
puis ils sont ensuite les seuls à en
maîtriser la maintenance et ça pour nous
un coup faramineux donc inclure les
prestations de programmation et de
maintenance nous semble plutôt une bonne
idée monsieur Mathieu
oui monsieur le Président pour
intervenir au soutien de de l'amendement
présenté par ma camarade panneau il faut
pas non plus
se méprendre sur la qualité des
prestations informatiques aujourd'hui on
est passé d'une fonction support à une
fonction stratégique et là je remets la
cascade que j'avais la semaine dernière
à cette heure-ci en tant que rapporteur
d'une mission sur la
cybersécurité la la stratégie
informatique la structure informatique
influenceorganisation même des pouvoirs
publics et donc la menée des politiques
publiques donc ça n'est pas un petit
sujet ça n'est pas un sujet annexe et de
dire que ça n'influence pas
l'organisation des politiques publiques
ou la décision publique c'est
profondément faux vous rajoutter à ça
qu'on est dans un environnement gafam
euh on est relié directement à des
questions de souveraineté en ce qui
concerne les ministère donc il faut
prendre en compte cette réalité la
fonction informatique est une fonction
stratégique et devrait rentrer donc dans
le champ d'application de la
loi alors Monsieur goselin
oui je crois qu'on doit quand même
garder cette
distinction entre ce qui est stratégique
et et ce qui est plus du fonctionnement
quotidien alors évidemment la ligne est
est et parfois compliqué hein la ligne
de partage des EAU n'apparaît pas
toujours de façon très claire parce que
une une stratégie donné peut induire
évidemment des équipements particuliers
des logiciels particuliers et donc des
maintenances et cetera particulières ou
la possibilité d'avoir des
parfeux de de lutter contre les
cyberataques et cetera mais je crois
quand même et si le numérique occupe
pratiquement la moitié des cabinets de
conseil je crois quand même qu'on doit
distinguer
ce qui est vraiment de la stratégie de
ce qui pourrait être considéré comme un
accompagnement une vente de de produits
et cetera donc je suis un peu ennuyé
aussi par par par cet amendement il met
le doigt sur un point c'est vrai qu'
n'est pas anodin mais je crois que la
rédaction telle telle qu'elle est faite
en fait est très binaire c'est oui ou
non et du coup on se trouve à à englober
plus largement qu'on ne le souhaiterait
donc c'est ce qui m'amènera un peu par
précaution à à à voter contre mais je
sais pas si on peut retravailler ça pour
pour la séance c'est peut-être illusoire
de le penser mais il y a un sujet mais
qui n qui est pas résolu par ce par cet
amendement monsieur le rapporteur s oui
merci président juste pour pour dire que
je je partage une petite inquiétude
c'est le droit de suite c'est-à-dire
quand un conseil en informatique vous
fait l'architecture de votre réseau
évidemment il est compris dans dans le
dans le dans le champ d'application de
la proposition de loi mais si après il y
a un droit de suite c'estàd qu'il vous
vend un logiciel et qu'il le il fait la
maintenance ça continue à être de la
stratégie donc c'est le c'est le sujet
donc moi je suis d'accord avec Philippe
goselin tout ne peut pas rentrer dans le
dans le champ d'application de la PPL
mais en tout cas on en rate quand même
donc
j'invite parce que pour la séance on
trouve une solution c'est pour ça que
l'article l'amendement 49 me semble pas
me semble utile en tout cas donc après
regardons comment on peut appliquer pour
que tout ne rentre pas parce que c'est
vrai quand il y a une cyber attaque à un
moment faut que quelqu'un intervienne
tout de suite c'est comme ça donc je je
pense qu'il faut peut-être le rédiger
pour la séance et et qu'on trouve un
accord làdessus alors je mettre au voix
l'amendement 49 qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté le 98 qui
vote
pour 1 2 3 4 5
6 qui votre
contre il est
adopté alors l'amendement suivant le 54
monsieur Mathieu oui monsieur le
Président en fait il s'agit de
réintégrer al nous on considère que en
fait il y a une peut-être une erreur de
de de rédaction dans le texte original
c'est-à-dire que le ce qui a été traité
au niveau des avocats experts comptables
et commissair au compte ça a été sous le
prisme de la profession et non pas des
fonctions or euh on le sait
historiquement les cabinets de conseil
sont nés dans ces profession là donc il
y a une très grande connexité entre les
d'ailleurs il y a je crois il y a des
députés qui siègent aujourd'hui qui sont
des anciens avocats et qui ont fait tout
tout partie de leur carrière d'ailleurs
dans des cabinets conseil ils pourront
le confirmer une très grande connexité
historique et euh aller uniquement sur
la prof la profession pour parler d'une
exclusion euh c'est travailler un angle
mort donc nous ce que nous proposons
c'est d'aller plutôt sur les fonctions
par exemple un avocat dans ses fonctions
juridictionnelles entendu au sens large
pas simplement la playirie mais à partir
du moment où un avocat prend une affaire
et va jusqu'au bout de du suivi de
l'exécution d'un jugement devenu
définitif donc c'est beaucoup plus large
ça en effet ça doit être exclu mais à
partir du moment où l'avocat prend une
casquette simplement de conseil comme on
trouve plein d'avocats dans des cabinets
conseil et bien cette fonction doit être
réintégré donc j'espère être clair voilà
sur ces professions là avocat
commissaire au compte expert compable on
fait le départ entre les différentes
fonctions on exclut les fonctions
naturelles de conseil enfin d'expertise
comptable de commiss au compte de meniee
juridictionnelle et par contre le
Conseil pur et bien rentre dans le champ
d'application de la loi tel est le sens
de cet amendement que nous considérons
être un amendement de précision du
textes le suivant monsieur
Lucas merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement de notre collègue reg vise à
revenir à la version initiale de la la
proposition de loi de nos collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs en
rétablissement la rédaction de l'alinéa
12 de l'article 1er en effet la la
rédaction qui nous est proposée ici
exclut tout un ensemble de professions
notamment les avocats et ceux alors même
que ces derniers peuvent être amenés à
exercer des missions de conseil hors de
toute activité liée à à un contentieux
mission que la proposition de loi
cherche précisément à encadrer à titre
d'exemple il est possible de citer le le
cabinet d'avocat dentons qui a réalisé
l'étude d'impact et l'exposé des motifs
de la loi d'orientation des mobilité en
2019 comme l'avaient relevé nos nos
collègues sénateurs dans leur rapport en
sachant que bien d'autres cabinets
d'avocats effectuent ce type de mission
pour l'État la rédaction proposée par
cet amendement permet donc de soumettre
aux obligations de la présente loi ses
activités de conseil de cabinet d'avocat
ou d'autres professions juridiques au
même titre que les activités de conseil
réalisées par des cabinets traditionnels
sans pour autant compromettre le secret
professionnel qui reste notamment
garanti et c'est normal dans un état de
droit pour les activités de
représentation ou d'assistance devant
les
juridictions monsieur housoussin le 76
oui il s'agit euh aussi avec cet
amendement de revenir à la rédaction
initiale de l'alinéa 12 de l'article 1
c'est-à-dire d'exclure du dispositif les
avocats lorsqu'ils ont une mission de
représentation des partis d'exclure
aussi les experts comptables et les
commissaires au compte lorsqu'ils ont
une mission d'expertise ou de
commissariat au compte mais d'inclure
ces corps de métier lorsqu'ils ont une
mission de conseil c'était euh la
rédaction initiale du texte et on ne
sait pas on n'a pas eu d'explication
réell en audition sur le la raison pour
laquelle ce cette rédaction avait été
modifiée le 12 madame
unmeiller défendu messieur les
rapporteurs
oui merci monsieur le Président donc sur
ces amendements qui sont en commun avec
deux amendements communs identiques
pardon sur le 54 de Monsieur Mathieu sur
le 63 de Madame régol et sur le 76 de
Monsieur housoussin ces amend propos de
réintroduire en fait ce qui avait été
exclu les professions juridiques
réglementées et notamment les activités
de conseil réalisées par les avocats
dans le champ d'application du texte le
54 prévoit si je ne m'abuse une
précision supplémentaire mais qui ne
change pas la portée de sa rédaction
l'amendement 12 de madame unemmerer
propose le retour au texte initial et
propose en plus d'inclure l'expertise
comptable dans le champ des obligations
je n'y suis pas favorable à tous ces
amendements parce que ces professions
sont réglementées c'est des professions
réglementées du droit les experts
comptables et les commissaires au compes
disposent de leur propres ontologique
sanctionné par l'ordre de la profession
ou dans le cas des commissaires au
compte d'ailleurs par une autorité
administrative indépendante le Haut
Conseil au commissariat au compte donc
ça me paraît pas pertinent d'appliquer à
ces professions des obligations
déontologiques supplémentaires
maintenant j'entends vos remarques
peut-être qu'il faut je sais pas
retravailler ça avec la navette ou d'ici
la séance mais à ce stade je donne un
avis défavorable sur tous ces
amendements alors Monsieur
Paris
non c'est bon merci
président comme vient de le dire le
rapporteur il s'agit de profession
réglementé donc avec leur propres
règlesontologique s'agissant des avocats
par exemple c'est le bâtonnier qui
intervient sur ces questions et la
crainte qu'on pourrait avoir assez assez
naturelle c'est celle d'un d'une
opposition de norme entre la h TVP par
exemple et le bâtonnier qui
interviendrait donc je pense qu'on n'est
pas suffisamment clair sur ce texte pour
en tirer des conséquences directes
répondant d'ailleurs à une des
observations c'est la rapporteur du
Sénat elle-même qui avait déposé un
amendement pour retirer les professions
réglementées du texte alors qu'iles y
figuraient initialement deuxième élément
on a parlé du secret professionnel c'est
pas la première fois qu'on parle du
secret professionnel des avocats ça nous
a très souvent occupé et quand j'entends
les distinctions qui sont faites entre
les phases contentieuses qui seraient
couvertes par le secret professionnel et
et le reste qui ne saait pas les bras m
tomb c'est tout à fait faux c'estàd que
les avocats ont un secret professionnel
qui doit leur être absolument garanti et
intervenir dans ce texte par ce biais là
me paraît tout à fait tout à fait je
sais pas quel titre ou quel quel nom
utilisé et j'irai pas plus loin mais je
suis fondamentalement opposé je pense
que l'ensemble des avocats et des
professions réglementées en général
serait foncièrement choqué si nous
allions jusqu'à ce point-là dans le
texte
alors madamemè me dit qu'elle retire
l'amendement numéro 12 Monsieur goselin
Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE oui quelques mots
effectivement c'est c'est toujours
tentant de de balayer très large en
disant on couvre tous les cas de de
figure mais là en effet je reprends ce
que vient de dire Didier Paris on on on
est sur des professions qui sont pour
l'essentiel réglementé qui ont leur
propre déontologie et et je rappelle que
pour les avocats en particulier je ne
suis pas avocat je le rappelle il y a un
risque de de de porter atteinte au
secret professionnel et et et et il y a
déjà un certain nombre d'éléments avec
effectivement les bâtonniers mais pas
que on a le règlement intérieur national
qui le précise on a aussi la loi du 31
décembre 71 sur les avocats et et et le
nouveau cadre juridique qui revient
dessus à l'article 66
5-5 donc je crois qu'on a déjà un
environnement juridique de de de
contrôle
d'autocontrôle de sanction le cas
échéant et aller au-delà sans évaluation
sans étude d'impact me paraît
honnêtement hasardeux et et rond un peu
l'équilibre de du texte donc je ne m'y
engouffreraai pas alors Monsieur Mathieu
euh oui alors la circonstance qu'il y a
des professions réglementées à mon avis
ne fait pas obstacle à l'adoption de cet
amendement faut pas oublier que la
déontologie c'est surtout un droit
disciplinaire du membre d'une profession
réglementée vis-à-vis du corps qui est
sa profession et il y a pas il y a pas
de d'opposition il y a pas d'opposition
à la à la cohabitation entre des blocs
de normes qui sont concomitants par
exemple la profession de médecin est
extrêmement réglementée pour autant ça
n'empêche pas un médecin de se retrouver
justiciable au titre du code pénal pour
des crimes et des lits qu'il aurait pu
commettre dans le cadre de l'exercice de
ses fonctions donc je pense que c'est
cet argument en fait de l'opposition de
bloc de normes qui viendrait rentrer en
contradiction c'est quelque chose en
fait qui est très habituel dans le droit
français qui est encore plus vieille que
je pense l'État lui-même ou alors
concomitante à l'existence de l'État
raisonnable en fait sur les sur les
arguments là on peut pas on peut pas
partir confondre la déontologie avec le
droit originel que nous nous promouvons
ici c'est pas possible c'est pas la même
chose et enfin la parole est à Monsieur
Houssin monsieuroussin alors très bien
je mets donc au voix les amendements
identiques qui V alors pardon d'abord le
l'amendement numéro 54 de Monsieur
Mathieu qui vote
pour
contre rejeté et les amendements
identiques 636 qui vote
pour contre rejeté euh on en vient à une
nouvelle série d'amendements identique
le 99 madame mer oui merci monsieur le
Président c'est un amendement de
précision qui vise à substituer au mot à
titre individuel les mots en qualité
d'indépendant cette précision elle
paraît importante au vu de l'objectif de
cette proposition de loi nous voulons
réguler les prestations qui viennent du
privé et non celles qui sont effectuées
entre administration la situation dans
laquelle un vacataire ou un agent sous
contrat de dooit privé se verra
appliquer certaines des obligations de
la proposition de loi serait en effet
particulièrement absurde
ouais merci Madame mer c'est un
amendement de bon sens nous avions le
même donc excessivement
favorable je mets au voix qui vot pour
qui vote
pour contre
adopté suivant 113 monsieur
milen
allezy je je vais proposer que madame
meriller qui elle-même le défende
identique merci monsieur le Président
c'est un amendement qui vise à supprimer
l'alinéa 18 la pratique montre en effet
mais aussi les auditions qui on ét ont
été mené par les parties prenantes
concerné qu'un grand nombre de
prestations n'appelle pas à
l'élaboration de plusieurs scénarios en
l'état l'article 1er faisait peser une
forme de contrainte disproportionnée sur
les cabinets de
conseil
alors Monsieur
housoussin oui moi quand je lis l'exposé
des motifs de d'amendement de Monsieur
milen je suis d'accord il propose de
supprimer l'obligation de proposer
plusurs scénarios aux administrations
bénéficiaires et ils disent que cette
obligation peut sembler pertinente
concernant les cabinets de conseil en
stratégie en organisation mais elle
s'applique mal à d'autres types de
prestations et notamment aux prestations
de conseil informatique ce qui est vrai
mais dans ce cas-là pourquoi supprimer
l'ensemble et pas amender dans le sens
d'une précision pour ne concerner que
les cabinet de conseil en stratégie et
en
organisation monsieur le rapporteur oui
euh il me semble que c'est la logique
qu'un conseil un stratégie fasse l'objet
de plusieurs scénarios ou en tout cas
par itération qu'on arrive au scénario
final donc je je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit très opérant
voilà donc je monsieur coulom et ensuite
on
votera
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais juste préciser que puisque le
c'est le la prestation de conseil
informatique qui a servi de base à la
rédaction de enin qui a motivé cet
amendement c'est faux en informatique
aussi comme dans les autres domaines on
peut avoir plusieurs scénarios plusieurs
technologies plusieurs supports
plusieurs langages informatiqu on peut
avoir des bases distribué on peut avoir
des bases rassemblé bref il nous faut
aussi dans ce domaine là avoir plusieurs
scénarios parce que les coûtes ne sont
pas pas les mêmes parce qu'ensuite
l'avenir des systèmes informatiques
fournis n'est pas le même leur
possibilité de déploiement non plus donc
il n'y a aucune raison valable de
d'exclure les prestations de conseil
informatiqu du dispositif alors Monsieur
Houssin oui le le problème c'est que si
on reste à un seul scénario finalement
bah c'est ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure on arrive à une privatisation de
la décision publique il y a plus de
décisions qui sont pris c'est plus un
conseil ça devient une
consigne alors Monsieur sensu oui alors
pensez parce qu'il y a plusieurs
scénario ça va changer quelque chose ça
me semble complètement incroyable mais
je je vous rappelle c'est le cahier des
charges qui prévoit ça quand on fait un
quand on fait une
consultation pour pour l'administration
centrale il peut y avoir une demande de
trois scénaris différents il peut y
avoir une demande de justement aller
vers telre chose c'est le cahier des
charges de la prestation demandée qui
prévoit ça n'allons pas mettre ça dans
la loi l'exigence de plusieurs scénio ça
me paraî quand même être un peu
superfatoire alors je mets au voit les
amendements numéro 113 et 100 qui vote
pour qui vote contre ils sont adoptés
ils font tomber le
52 le
13 et donc madame vous avez la parole
pour le 14 peut-être 14 et 15 enentation
commune oui alors rapidement le
14 vise à permettre l'intégration ou et
la participation d'un agent public dans
l'intervention d'un prestateur de
conseil ou d'un consultant auprès d'une
administration alors vous allez me dire
que le cahier des charges peut prévoir
cela voilà mais je pense que c'est mieux
en le disant et le
15 et
[Musique]
bien oui formaliser distinction déjà
existante dans la pratique en précisant
que les cabinets de conseil qui
contractualisent avec l'État ont
l'interdiction d'effectuer toute action
de représentation d'intérêt auprès des
pouvoirs publics au nom des tiers que
constituent leur clients privés cette
interdiction n'excluant pas la
possibilité que ces cabinets effectuent
des actions de représentation d'intérêt
en leur nom propre ou via leur
association professionnelle je précise
que c'est un amendement suggéré par
l'association transpareny International
France messieur les
rapporteurs madametermerer sur le
premier je vous donnerai un avis
favorable sur le deuxè je serai plutôt
défavorable
euh parce qu'en fait dans une dans la
situation que vous vous décrivez en fait
le cabinet de conseil serait de fait en
situation de conflit d'intérêts il soit
donc pass possible de sanction de la
part de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique en
revanche le cabinet de conseil effectue
une mission de conseil pour
l'administration sur un sujet une action
de lobbying pour le compte de tiers sur
un tout autre sujet vous voyez que là ça
on atteint les limites de l'exercice
donc je suis défavorable ou
retrait favorable sur le prier alors
retrait du 15 m VO le 14 qui vote
pour
contre adopté je mets au voix l'article
1er qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté après
l'article 1er le 16 madame
monsieur le rapporteur oui merci merci
Madame j'y suis je vais vous demander ça
sera une demande de retrait parce que en
l'état rien n'empêche le bureau de
chaque assemblée parlementaire de mettre
en place ses propres règles donc voilà
il est retiré merci retirer monsieur le
rapporteur sensu
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
oui l'amendement 149 est est
l'amendement qui permet
de de mettre quelque chose sur les
collectivités territoriales au sein de
notre texte puisqu'il s'agit là de de
demander au gouvernement un rapport au
Parlement avant le 31 décembre 2024 et
après consultation des association
nationale d'élus locaux pour l'impact de
l'extension des dispositions de la
présente loi au collectivité territorial
à groupement et sur le fonctionnement et
ainsi que sur le marché du conseil au
secteur public local je le je le redis
alors on va pas refaire le débat il faut
il faut à tout prix qu'on ait cette
évaluation préalable elle peut être
faite au sein de notre assemblée je
pense que ce serait de bonne politique
que de le faire mais en posant cet
amendement je pense qu'on on met un acte
aussi qui permet que pour l'avenir on
ait des disposition qui soit adapté le
36 monsieur
Rambo
ouis en cours allez-y monsieur
en considère qu'il est défendu alors non
non j'arrive
j'arrive cet amendement rejoint
l'amendement 70 déposé à l'article 1er
par ma collègue mariefance laurau il
entend encourager la Cour des comptes à
établir un rapport annuel pour estimer
le coût global des prestations de
conseil réalisé au bénéfice des
collectivités locales au cours de la
mission
flash des sénateurs que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'évoquer nos collègues ont
souligné qu'aucune donnée suffisamment
précise n'existe actuellement pour
estimer le montant global des
prestations de conseil effectivement
réalisé au bénéfice des collectivités
locales cette absence complète de
données soulève des interrogations
quelle part de leur budget les
collectivités allouell à de telles
prestations les collectivités
emploient-elles de manière suffisamment
complète la main- d'œuvre dont elle
dispose insitu au regard de la
potentielle importance que Reva une
telle dépense publique il nous semble de
bonne à loi de proposer l'établissement
d'un rapport issu de la Cour des comptes
qui pourrait être intégré au rapport
annuel sur les finances
locales monsieur sensu ou monsieur
milien oui merci monsieur le Président
évidemment sur le 149 puisqu'ils sont en
discussion commune je suis favorable
puisque c'est le nôre d'amendement donc
il serait quand même assez bizarre que
je sois défavorable monsieur monsieur
Rambo moi je
sincèrement je trouve pas ça pertinent
d'imposer la Cour des comptes un tel
rapport d'abord parce que vous avez vu
l'amendement qu'on a posé déjà et qu
nous avons proposé au
gouvernement nous avons adopté le
principe d'un rapport du gouvernement
par sur l'extension du texte aux
collectivité donc ça va bien faire
l'objet d'une étude on va redemander je
redis encore une fois une mission à la
délégation collectivité territoriale et
puis c'est pas pertinant tout simplement
parce que la Cour des comptes peut
elle-même se saisir du sujet et réaliser
un rapport si le juge pertinent donc
défavorable à votre amendement et bien
sûr favorable au alors Monsieur goselin
allez-y
pardon merci de me donner la parole euh
oui quelques mots effectivement on
comprends bien le le le le souci des des
des collègues d'avoir plus de
transparence et c'est ce qu'on évoque
depuis le le le début de de nos travaux
ce matin mais euh d'une part avoir un un
bilan annuel euh sans en tirer des
conclusions ça donne pas nécessairement
grand-chose moi je préfère que l'on ait
une mission délégation collectivité ou
mission de la commission des lois qui
permet permettra d'éclairer et le cas
échéant d'intégrer si besoin était pour
toutes ou partie les collectivités là je
je je trouve qu'éventuellement on met la
la charue un petit peu avant les bœfs le
le rapport annuel pourrait être
intéressant si il y avait d'autres
disposition et puis après je suis pas
sûr que ça relève effectivement de la
Cour des comptes je je pense que ça
relèverait peut-être plutôt d'un travail
des chambres régionales des comptes
consolidées puisque ce sont les chambres
régionales des comptes qui ont la
compétence
les colleités local moins la cour même
si la Cour a parfois évidemment eu des
travaux aussi sur les collectivités mais
je crois que ça serait plus logique en
tout cas alors on met au voix d'abord
l'amendement 149 des rapporteurs qui
votent pour contre il est adopté il fait
pas tomber le second voilà l'amendement
36 qui vot pour contre il est rejeté
additionnel avant l'article 2 c'est un
rédactionnel du rapporteur qui vote pour
contre adopté le 115 est un additionnel
du rapporteur qui vote pour contre
adopté le 150 monsieur le rapporteur
ouais c'est alors vous savez dans dans
la proposition de loi du Sénat il y a
interdiction d'utiliser une adresse mail
de
l'administration pour le prestataire a
interdiction l'utiliser pour pour faire
ses travaux il se trouve que pour
certains travaux notamment informatiqu
il y a
parfois une pertinence à utiliser une
adresse mail de l'administration pour
éviter justement les attaques les
attaques cyber et et le fait que ça
passe par le prestataire c'estàdire que
et donc l'idée c'est de permettre
lorsque l'administration le demande
notamment dans le casre de prestation
informatique d'avoir une adresse de
l'administration monsieur attendez
monsieurousin d'abord
oui c'est c'est un sous-amendement qui
vise à garder l'esprit initial du texte
donc on bien on comprend bien à quoi
sert cet amendement l'usage que vous
décrivez est utile on voudrait pas qu'il
y en ait d'autres donc il convient pour
nous que le consultant ne puisse pas
avoir d'adresse email de type en gros
prénom. nom adgof.fr c'estàd rien de
nominatif mais une adresse
fonctionnelle avec un identifiant par
exemple consultant du cabinet x @ gof.fr
qu'on retourne pas à une à une adresse
nominative parce que sinon on pourrait
retomber dans les travers qu'on on
essayer de dénoncer précédemmentilien
oui j'entends bien j'entends bien ce que
vous voulez dire monsieur housoussin
mais la rédaction de votre amendement à
mon sens ne fonctionne pas ça donnerait
l'attribution d'une telle adresse
électronique non nominative alors que
l'interdiction mentionnée juste avant
porte sur tous les types d'adresses quel
soit nominative ou pas je voudrais en
plus vous signaler pour pour
l'amendement qu'on a déposé avec Nicolas
ens l'utilisation d'une adresse de de de
d'une administration peut aussi se faire
tout à fait dans le cas où est prêté au
prestataire ou au consultant du matériel
de l'administration justement pour
sécuriser un petit peu plus les choses
donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a qu'on a
posé cet amendement donc défavorable à
votre sousamendement monsieur oussin
vous le retirer sinon
défavorable donc je mets au voie d'Abir
le sous-amendement qui vote pour contre
rejeter l'amendement du rapporteur qui
vote pour contre adopté le 17 madame non
qu'est-ce qu' dit Madame
oui c'est un amendement qui vise à faire
en sorte que l'administration qui est
bénéficiaire d'une prestation de conseil
informe l'ensemble de ses agents du
début de son exécution et cette
information précise l'objet résumé de la
prestation et sa période d'exécution
c'est une manière d'internaliser en
quelque sorte le rôle que qui va être
joué par le cabinet de conseil au sein
de cette administration et de respect
vis-à-vis des agents de cette
administration monsieur le rapporteur
madame mailleur je comprends tout à fait
euh ce que vous voulez viser au travers
de cet amendement bon admettons que le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale fasse
une prestation de conseil qu'elle soit
retenue et qu'ils doivent en en informer
tous ces agents ça fait
beaucoup non mais ça fait beaucoup quand
même on pouveit pas faire enfin voilà il
y a des agents qui sont quand même pas
concerné bah complètement par par les
prestations de de conseil retenu euh
voilà donc je trouve que c'est un petit
peu beaucoup quoi si vous prenez tout
toutes les administrations on serait
donc on informe 5500000 agents dont
certains voilà ça me paraît un petit peu
exhaustif donc défavorable en ce qui
concerne juste juste pour préciser on
aura on aura des amendements tout à
l'heure sur qui est destinataire du
rapport et des et des
informations certains souhaitent enlever
les organisations syndicales moi j'ai
souhaité qu' les organisations
syndicales représentatives justement
pour
pouvoir assurer la transparence aussi
auprès des salariés par le biais de
leurs représentants et je pense que
c'est aussi une des une des façons de de
faire ce cette cette transparence auprès
des salariés des administrations
monsieur
ça j'avais effectivement demandé la
parole mais parce que j'avais exactement
le même argument que monsieur le
rapporteur avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur effectivement contacter tous
les agents semblaient disproportionnés
Bienal 6
oui c'est juste une une information mais
même quand on met l'administration
bénéficiaire c'est pas forcément tout le
ministère on pe peut dire que c'est
l'administration centrale ou la
direction concernée ou et cetera
donc bah vous avez vous avez une
définition à maxima parce que ça vous
arrange dans votre argumentation de dire
que c'est disproportionné mais bon après
vous savez ah il y a des circulaires
d'application ce genre de chos sé si
vous voulez monsieur alors je mets au vo
l'amendement qui vote pour contre rejeté
le 151 monsieur miien
oui merci monsieur le Président l'objet
de cet amendement c'est d'exclure
certaines prestations de communication
de l'obligation de mentionner la
participation du consultant sur document
produit en effet l'article 2 prévoit
l'interdiction d'utiliser tout signe
distinctif de l'administration sur le
documents que produisent les
prestataires de conseil et l'obligation
de mentionner la participation de cons
sur tout document rédigés avec leur
participation directe ou indirecte mon
amendement donc propose d'exclure les
documents destinés à l'information du
public réalisé dans le cadre de
prestation de conseil en communication
de ces obligations et interdictions dans
le cas contraire l'article empêchera en
pratique la réalisation par une agence
de toute prestation de communication ou
de publicité pour une administration
publique ça me paraît un petit peu trop
fort voilà qui vote
pour contre adopé l'article 2 qui vote
pour contre adopté article 3 Le 116 un
rédactionnel du rapporteur qui vote pour
pour contre adopté le 37 n'est pas
défendu le 117 rédactionnel qui vote
pour contre adopté le 96 monsieur
Houssin oui merci monsieur le Président
alors l'article 5 interdit les
prestation de conseil à titre gratuit
l'article 19 prévoyant que celle en
cours cesse de plein droit à compter de
la promulgation du texte il est dans
cette mesure normale comme le prévoit
l'article 3 que le rapport annuel
relatif au recours aux prestations de
conseil ne concerne pas de telle
prestation de conseil à titre gratuit
pour ce qui est des années postérieures
à la promulgation de la loi toutefois
dans la mesure où cette interdiction
n'existait pas avant cette date et dès
lors que le rapport s'étend aux 5
dernières années il convient d'intégrer
l'ensemble des prestations de conseil à
titre gratuit qui ont pu être réalisé au
bénéfice de l'administration auin
d'avoir une vue rétrospective complète
du recours au pration de conseil dans
les politiques
publiques monsieur
rapporteur alors défavorable parce qu'en
fait vous faites une distinction il
faudrait déclarer ce qu'on a fait avant
mais pas ce qu'on va faire après ce qui
c'est interdit attendez c'est interdit
c'est interdit sauf le mesenat
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y a un sujet
sur le mesénat et votre votre amendement
interdit également ménade après c'est il
y a un vrai sujet sur le sur le tout à
l'heure qui viendra puisqu'il y a des
amendements sur ce sujet mais
aujourd'hui tel qu'il est rédigé il
interdit le probonau mais aussi le
messéna alors Monsieur Houssin allez-y
non mais c'est pas du tout ce que dit
mon amendement il y a des prestations à
titre gratuit qui vont être
interdites à postériori ce qui
maintenant dans le rapport on va nous
dire dans le rapport qu'on éétudiera pas
en fait le type de prestation qui a été
interdite ce qui est logique puisque à
l'avenir il y en aura plus mais quand on
va commencer par exemple en 2025 à
étudier 2020 à 2025 et ben on éétudiera
pas ces prestations à titre gratuit
qu'on a interdit mais qui n'étit pas
interdit de 2020 à 2025 c'est exactement
ça que dit l'amendement donc en fait on
va avoir un vide dans
l'étude alors je mets au voie
l'amendement qui vre pour contre rejeter
le suivant monsieur 79 monsieur
houss c'est quand même incroyable je
m'excuse he d'avoir des des réponses à
des amendements qui en fait ont rien à
voir avec ce que propose l'amendement et
quand on réexplique l'amendement d'avoir
aucune réponse non plus alors le
l'amendement numéro 79 il correspond
aussi à ce que proposait monsieur di
Filippo dans l'amendement 37 et qui quia
pas défendu
c'est que la première année le rapport
comprenne la liste des prestations
mentionnées au 2e alinéa depuis l'année
2017 en effet cet amendement vise à
faire en sorte que le premier rapport
rendu à compté de la promulgation de la
loi couvre la période écoulée depuis
2017 le rapport de la commission
d'enquête sur l'influence croissante des
cabinets de conseil privé sur les
politiques publiques a révélé que cette
influence croissante date du début du
quinquénat d'Emmanuel Macron au au cours
duquel le montant des contrats passés
avec ses cabinets a été multiplié par
3,5 ça nous permettra d'étudier aussi
bah les années covid de voir le
glissement qui a pu y avoir et puis la
commission d'enquête elle a commencé
début 2022 si on avait s'était arrêté à
cette date on aurait pu étudier à partir
de début 2017 mais le Sénat lui a voté
en octobre 2022 nous on se penseche sur
le sujet en 2024 et petit à petit ben on
décale en fait l'année du début de de ce
rapport monsieur le rapporteur oui
monsieur Houssin permettez-moi de de
pointer quand même la date que vous avez
choisie ah ben elle est pas au hasard on
est d'accord oui on est bien d'accord
bon donc sur le fond maintenant de votre
amendement la période couverte par le
rapport est déjà largement suffisante je
vais vous explique pourquoi les rapports
de l'Assemblée nationale du Sénat de la
Cour des Comptes publié en 2022 et 2023
ont déjà fait ce travail en partie il
présenteent les données disponibles pour
2014 et depuis 2018 ils ont surtout
insisté sur la nécessaire fiabilisation
des données dont dispose
l'administration en matière de
prestation de conseil l'enjeu n'est pas
tellement d'avoir des données brutes ça
je veux dire toutes les enquêtes les
donnent ces données-l et vous êtes tout
le monde est au courant de ces données
brutes c'est d'avoir des données fiables
et l'administration travaille à
améliorer la qualité de l'information
financière à venir il ne s'est pas rien
passé monsieur housoussin depuis 2022
loin sans faut l'administration a
travaillé et les choses sont fiabilisées
et euh la transparence est quand même
faite donc avis
défavorable
monsieurousin ah pardon Monsieur Je en
prie vous avez raison le choix de
l'année n'est pas innocent mais il a
surtout pour but de garder l'esprit de
la commission d'enquête puisque quand la
commission d'enquête dit en 2022 je veut
qu'on étudie les 5 dernières années elle
parle en 2022 donc elle elle commence en
2017 maintenant s'il y a eu 15 mois
entre l'adoption et Sénat et au Sénat et
le fait qu'on l'étudie à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pas de ma responsabilité
donc en fait l'esprit de la commission
d'enquête c'était de dire qu'on commence
à étudier en 2017 je mets au vois qui
vote pour contre rejeté le 38
madame oui rapidement monsieur le
Président il s'agit en fait que
l'efficacité de la loi ne se heurte pas
totalement à la question du secret
notamment de la Défense nationale de la
sécurité des personnes et cetera et il
nous paraît important que ces
administration ne soit pas totalement
écarté dans l'obligation d'information
mais qu'elle soit en capacité bien sûr
d'adapter leur communication au fin de
préserver le secret euh le secret la
protection légale entourant le secret
118 monsieur le rapporteur
ouais je suis monsieur je suis un peu
étonné monsieur le Président que cet
amendement soit en discussion commune
parce que je pense qu'il est
complètement orthogonal à l'autre
puisque je propose d'étendre le champ
des secrets prévu à l'article 3 qui
correspond actuellement à certains des
secrets mentionnés dans le droit commun
de la communication de documents
administratif à l'article L 31-5 du code
des relations entre le public et
l'administration il ajoute le secret des
affaires mentionné à l'article L 31-6 du
même code qui existe déjà en effet en
l'absence de mention du secret des
affaires au sein d'une liste de secret
qui se veut limitative prête à confusion
et pourrait conduire à la publication
d'information couverte par ce secret
c'est précisément parce que il est
orthogonal à celui de madame qui est en
discussion commune ça me surprend
toujours donc c'est un avis défavorable
à celui de madamemeilleur par conséquent
monsieur sensu il il vous aura pas
échappé que je n'ai pas Cigné
l'amendement de Monsieur milienne et que
je je préfère grandement l'amendement de
Cécile lunter mailleur qui qui vise à
avoir une application réelle c'estàdire
que attention à ne pas dépesser petit à
petit l'application et le champ
d'application de la PPL sénatoriale donc
je je pour ma part euh peut-être que si
on en reste là ça peut s'entendre mais
en tout cas il est pas question pour à
mon sens de d'invoquer le secret des les
affaires parce que sinon à un moment on
aura plus jamais plus rien qui entrera
dans le dans la transparence des
missions
accomplies monsieur bernalissis
oui pareil je je je défavorable nous
sommes défavorables avec mon groupe à à
l'amendement du rapporteur milienne qui
qui vise à rajouter ce secret en plus
bon on va dire que c'est de
l'articulation mais la loi prévoyant
déjà le secret des affaires le mettre
ici finalement déjà des entreprises
pourraient déjà le soulever en l'état
actuel de la rédaction de la PPL donc
donc voilà donc c'est pourquoi je suis
d'ailleurs et nous sommes favorables à
l'amendement de la collègue unmer qui
clarifie le fait que certes les secrets
existent mais qui n'empêche pas de faire
un résumé des informations qui qui nous
intéressent ça reste de l'argent
public et donc je je vois pas en quoi le
secret viendrait percuter tout ça et
puis il il y a une question de fond à un
moment donné c'est de se dire il est
donc possible que des choses qui soient
assez secrètes soi mis en partage avec
des des organismes privés style des
cabinets conseil enfin je veux dire déjà
ça pose un petit sujet de Fond de se
dire que si des des choses doivent être
secret peut-être qu'ell doivent être
internaliser et gérer d'une manière un
peu différente que celle du code des
marchés publics alors je vais d'abord
monsieur goselin oui un tout petit mot
si si on doit exclure un certain nombre
de d'informations ça me paraît assez
légitime je pense qu'il faut exclure les
informations qui sont couverte par le
secret défense enfin voilà il y a des
des choses évidentes pour le secret des
affaires évidemment c'est un sujet
toujours un peu délicat qui parfois est
un un peu le paravant ou le le le le le
le Joker qui est qui est proposé et
peut-être qu'il faut avancer mais en
tout cas le secret des affaires ne doit
pas être une façon de de contourner
l'esprit euh de de de de la proposition
de de loi sinon on tape à côté aussi
voilà faut faut trouver un juste
équilibre et ne pas non plus dévoyer le
texte du Sénat il est quand même
essentiel important et je rappelle qu'il
a été voté à l'unanimité donc essayons
de garder aussi l'état d'esprit
oui très rapidement pour dire que il
s'agit pas de lever le secret et que
l'administration garde la main mais que
elle est dans l'obligation quand même de
communiquer dès lors qu'elle a fait
appel à un service externe de donner au
moins le nom de ce service et les
objectifs voilà enfin les raisons c'est
ça reste à la main de l'administration
qui conserve c'est c'est c'est bien sûr
ces prérogatives s'agissant du secret
donc je crois que là on est suffisant
sérieux pour éviter pour permettre
l'efficacité de la loi tout en gardant
cette protection légale alors le vote de
votre amendement d'abord le 38 qui vote
pour contre rejeté et le suivant le 118
qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté bah
oui si si est
adopté
le
alors 57 de précision de Monsieur milien
qui vote pour 157 monsieur milen contre
adopté monsieur housoussin vous avez
trois
suivants en présentation commune
peut-être si vous voulez bien monsieur
le Président je vous présenterai le 80
et puis les deux suivants en
présentation commune parce qu'ils ont à
peu près le le même but alors
l'amendement 80 vise à ajouter au
rapport prévu à l'article 3 la liste des
amendes administratives prononcé au
titre de l'article 13 de façon à mesurer
l'étendue des cas d'abus en matière de
recours au Press de conseil dans le
cadre des politiques publiques l'article
13 que l'on étudiera tout à l'heure vise
à prononcer des amendes administratives
lorsque les principales exigences de ce
texte ne sont pas respectés
l'interdiction du probono les conflits
d'intérêts qui perdurent le refus
d'adresser sa déclaration d'intérêt ou
de fraud manifeste entre autres nous
souhaitons que le rapport remis au
Parlement contienne une liste des
amendes définitivement prononcées ça
nous permettra d'une part dansen
quantifier l'ampleur et puis ça nous
permettra aussi éventuellement
d'identifier des réfractaires régulier
et que l'information soit publique on le
disait tout à l'heure les députés
contrôlent l'action du gouvernement mais
aujourd'hui finalement qui contrôle
l'action des cabinets de
conseil non seulement le 80 pour
l'instant allez-y monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président ça sera
un avis défavorable ou une demande de
retrait parce que vous reprenez des
éléments qui figurent déjà dans le jaune
budgétaire du gouvernement et qui est
également prévu par la proposition de
loi à l'article 8 donc défavorable
retrait ou
défavorable je met je le mets au voix
qui vote pour contre rejeté le 89 et 78
donc en présentation commune alors le 89
r vise à ajouter un alinéa les raisons
pour lesquelles il a été choisi de
recourir à un prestataire de conseil ou
consultant externe à l'administration
bénéficiaire l'objectif de cet
amendement est de préciser dans le
rapport remis par le Gouvernement au
Parlement les raisons pour lesquelles
une administration a fait appel à un
prestataire de conseil ou un consultant
externe dans le cadre d'une prestation
de conseil cette précision peut-être
utile dans la mesure où il est
préférable d'avoir recours aux
ressources internes d'une administration
pour effectuer une mission d'expertise
et puis l'amendement
78 propose lui trois alinéas ce rapport
comprant également pour chaque ministère
premièrement une description de la
stratégie poursuivie en matière de
recours au conseil extérieur
deuxièmement les transferts de
compétences réalisés au bénéfice de
l'administration ainsi que les mesur
mise en œuvre pour développer et
valoriser les compétences de conseil en
interne alors cet amendement-ci il vise
à ajouter au rapport divers éléments et
c'est des éléments qui avaient été
proposés par le gouvernement lors de
l'examen de la précédente proposition de
loi en séance au Sénat il permettait
d'enrichir le rapport par des éléments
utiles pour mieux appréhender l'intérêt
du recours au prestations de conseil en
matière de politique publique il n'avait
pas été adopté au
Sénat les rapporteurs je vais être assez
bref défavorable sur les deux
amendements donc je mets d'abord le 89
au voix qui votre pour contre rejeté le
78 qui vre pour
contre rejeté l'article 3 qui vote pour
contre adopté le 158 monsieur le
rapporteur
ou
c'est c'est le le pendant de la
suppression de l'alinéa qui concerne la
Caisse des Dépôts c'est-à-dire que il y
a un un rapport annuel de la commission
de surveillance sur la direction morale
et sur la situation matérielle de la
Caisse des dépôts et prévoir que ce
rapport fasse état des informations
mentionné à l'article 3 de la
proposition de loi et je rappelle que ce
rapport est remis au Parlement voilà
c'était et l'idée l'idée c'est de ne pas
déstructurer et de ne pas considérer la
Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation comme
un établissement public administratif ou
comme un établissement public industriel
et commercial ce qu'elle n'est pas mais
bien de lui préserver le fait que le
contrôle est assuré par le Parlement et
non pas par
l'exécutif alors je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement qui votre pour contre
adopté
article 4 le 119 monsieur
milen
j'arveur s doute
monsieur donc cet
amendement supprime la publication des
informations prévues à l'article 3 dans
le rapport social unique de
l'administration bénéficiaire pour deux
raisons premièrement ces informations
seront déjà rendu public sous la forme
du rapport au Parlement elle sera
également publié en donnée ouvertes le
fait de de reproduire ces mêmes
informations dans un troisième support
n'ajouterait en fait strictement rien
deuxièmement le rapport social unique
n'a pas vocation à retracer les
informations relatives au cabinet de
conseil l'objet de ce document est
défini par la loi et précisé par le
décret autour de 10 rubriques l'emploi
le recrutement les parcours
professionnel je vais pas tous les faire
vous connaissez tout ça il rassemble
ainsi les éléments et données à partir
desquels sont établies les lignes
directrices de gestion qui détermine la
stratégie pluriannuelle de pilotage des
ressources humaines dans chaque
administration donc voilà suppression de
l'alinéa
4 je met au voix qui pour attendez il y
a pas de débatus ah Benz pas la main
alors Monsieur sens vous voulez dire un
mot je je pense que la suppression pure
et simple de cet alinéa pose problème
c'est-à-dire que comment on on
informe au sein de au sein de
l'administration comment on communique
justement auprès des des salariés et des
organisations syndicales
représentative les les conséquences et
les choix de recours au cabinet conseil
et puis dans le rapport social uni il y
a aussi les questions de formation qui
intègrent comment on réinternalise un
certain nombre de compétences donc cette
questionl elle est intimement lié au
recours ou non à la prestations
extérieur donc je crois que si ce
sujet-là peut être peut paraître
compliqué le Sénat l'avait mis et ça me
semble de bonne à loi de le conserver
quitte à le retrait
travailler donc Madame pas toujours été
d'accord hein madame unant je oui moi je
pense qu'on on a supprimer l'amendement
où je demandais est ce que
l'administration bénéficiaire informe
ses agents je pense que c'est cet
amendement-là auquel vous faisiez
référence donc évidemment je soutiendrai
votre amendement enfin je soutiendrai
votre position monsieur sensu parce que
si on supprime ça ça veut dire que les
agents ne savent rien de ce qui se passe
dans leur administration alors je mets
donc au voix la amendement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre 11 contre 9 il a
adopté le suivant monsieur men le 120 il
est adopté pardon 119 il est adopté par
ouou il est
adopté adopté madame
11 allez-y le 120 bien sur le 120
l'objet de l'amendement en fait c'est
l'application des secrets prévus dans le
droit commun de la communication des
documents administratifs aux données
publiées en données ouvertes en fait il
s'agit ni plus ni moins de mettre en
cohérence le régime de publication en
données ouvertes prévu à l'article 4
avec le droit commun de la communication
des documents administratifs s'agissant
de données publiques il est naturel que
les informations concernées passent par
les mêmes filtres que les informations
dont la communication est possible alors
le texte est assez ambigu à ce sujet il
ne précise pas si la CADA est compétente
et quel secret ça
en l'absence de précision on peut penser
que la CADA ne sera pas compétente et
qu'il faudrait saisir le juge
administratif en cas de refus de
publication peut par ailleurs penser que
le droit commun de la communication des
documents administratifs s'appliquera le
présent amendement clarifie cette
situation il prévoit l'application des
secrets mentionnés aux articles L 31-5
et
l311-6 du code des relations entre le
public et l'administration comme pour
tous les documents administratifs en
parallèle nous avons déposé un
amendement pour étendre par ailleurs la
de la CADA au éventuels refus de
publication ça sera l'amendement 125
merci donc je mets au voix qui vote
pour contre adopté article 4 qui vote
pour contre adopté article additionnel
avant le 5 il y a deux amendement de
Monsieur peutre une présentation génér
commune
pardon
allezy merci je vais retirer le 95 parce
a une coquille dans le dans la rédaction
et donc il perd son sens alors le 94
nous nous estimons que le recours par
l'administration à des prestataire de
conseil ne justifie qu'à titre
subsidiaire lorsqu'elle ne dispose pas
en interne des ressources humaines
nécessaires à la réalisation de la
prestation de conseil dans des délais
utiles dans la mesure où des agents
publics sont aptes à conduire la mission
de conseil envisagé il importe de la
leur confiée or ce texte aujourd'hui
nous l'avons dit il encadre les abus des
cabinets de conseil et les dérives qui a
pu y avoir par par par le passé mais il
reste insuffisant en matière de recours
abusif de la puissance publique au
cabinet de conseil et insuffisant contre
la dérive qui est pour nous la
privatisation finalement de la décision
publique il s'agit par cet amendement
d'inscrire une forme de principe de
subsidiarité et d'encadrer par la loi le
recours au cabinet privé dans les
politiques
publiques alors messieurs les
rapporteurs sur cet amendement 944 je je
comprends l'esprit qui vise à faire une
évaluation exantée euh euh après quand
on fait un cahier des charges pour un
recours au cabinet conseil alors
évidemment on peut dire si on a la
compétence en interne on prend la
compétence en interne et et point barre
sauf que l'État aujourd'hui fait à
recours au cabinet conseil pour des
prestations dont il n'a pas la les
compétences ça ça existe parfois pour
avoir un regard extérieur ça se ça se
discute mais on peut pas interdire le
recours au cabinet conseil et là
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui non non mais si
on on a des accords cadres sur des
sujets c'est bien que la prestation a
été défini que le cahier des charges a
été défini donc je trouve que c'est
c'est c'est pas c'est pas l'objectif
l'objectif c'est de savoir si
l'évaluation expost montre on va dire la
plusvalue amenée par le le recours au
cabinet conseil donc pour ma part ce qui
compte c'est plus la transparence
l'encadrement et la prévention et la
sanction des conflits d'intérêts que de
mettre la suspicion aussi sur tout ce
que pourrait demander les
administrations
centrales
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour contre rejeté à l'article 5
amendement du rapporteur
monsieuren de précision précision madame
Miller oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement cet amendement il
permettra de garder la possibilit pour
les administrations de pouvoir effectuer
des prestations proono entre elles il ne
faudrait pas bloquer en en vérité la
synergie entre nos servic public pour
rappel la proposition de loi elle
poursuit l'objectif de réguler le
recours à des prestations privées et en
laissant l'article 5 en l'état on
dépasserait finalement cet objectif cet
amendement IR opérant l'article 5
puisque les personnes morales énumérées
à l'article 238 bis du code général des
impôts ne relève pas du champ
d'application de la loi pour la plupart
donc c'est une correction légistique je
mets au voix qui vote pour contre adopté
le 53 madame
pano merci euh euh monsieur le Président
donc ça c'est un amendement qui propose
de compléter l'interdiction des
prestations de conseil à titre gracieux
on a commencé en discuter en y intégrant
le M Sénat des cabinets de conseil donc
dans le rapport sénatorial il est c'est
écrit comme ça et je pense que c'est
assez clair quand c'est gratuit c'est
vous euh le le produit avec une une
problématique notamment dans les grandes
écoles qui se multiplient avec des
partenariats euh avec les écoles de
commerce les écoles en lien avec le
service public pour les ingénieurs ou
encore à sciencep Paris avec un effet
ververs qui est évident puisque ce sont
des écoles initialement créées comme
vivier de fonctionnaire pour
l'administration publique qui ont
désormais assaillis par ses cabinets de
conseil qui assument pleinement leur
objectif de messenard c'est-à-dire
recriter les étudiants et l'État perd
ainsi de nombreux potentiels
administrateurs et fonctionnaires au
service justement de l'État le mécanisme
est d'autant plus pervers que ce messena
génère une réduction d'impôts pour les
cabinets entraînant en retour une
diminution des recettes de l'État puis
la baisse des recettes de l'État diminue
sa capacité à embaucher des
fonctionnaires renforçant ainsi la
dépendance au cabinet de conseil qui
grâce au messenat ont un pied dans la
porte et on voit bien l'effet pervers
que cela a donc il est temps je crois de
considérer le messena de d'arrêter de
considérer le messena comme un don
désintéressé il s'assrit dans une
stratégie globale d'affaiblissement de
la fonction publique donc de l'État et à
accroître sa dépendance au cabinet de
conseil c'est l'objet de cet amend
monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
je je je crains que nous n'ayons des
avis divergents avec mon ami Nicolas
sensu bah c'est normal
euh madame Panau oui c'est vrai on a on
a abordé le problème du probono qui
n'est pas le même finalement que les
lesmissions de messena parce que le
probono lui peut être réalisé de manière
totalement sauvage sans encadrement
particulier sans convention de
partenariat avec le cabinet donc sans
obligation déontologique pour le
prestataire et les consultant c'est pas
le cas des missions de mes Sénat qui est
mieux encadré donc nous souhaitons
poursuivre nous souhaitons suivre
l'approche du Sénat et maintenir
l'autorisation pour ma part en tout cas
parce que je ne parle que pour ma part
et maintenir l'autorisation de réaliser
des missions sous le régime du messen ce
qui bénéficierait à des organismes
d'intérêt général faut pas les oublier
vous avez cité des exemples sur lesquels
je peux être d'accord avec vous mais
faut pas oublier les autres qui sont des
organismes d'intérêt général et qui
seraient privé de ce fait par votre
amendement de de ce de ces missions de
mesenat donc c'est une demande de
retrait si je peux me permettre aussi
d'ajouter amendement qui suit après qui
interdit l'émission de conseil après
l'émission de messena c'est ça
madame ah c'est Madame ma donc de les
deux les deux alors ouais tous les deux
bon voilà donc toutes les deux vous avez
aussi donc déposé cet amendement qui
propose d' interterdire les réalisations
de missions de conseil par un cabinet de
conseil qui a déjà réalisé des missions
de mes Sénat auprès d'une entité
publique je pense que c'est une bonne
idée mais je pense qu'il faudra la
précis en vue de la séance d'accord donc
on en parlera au moment où ça viendra
mais quand nous examinerons votre
abinement je trouve que c'est une bonne
idée mais à préciser pour la séance pour
ce qui me concerne Nicolas j'imagine que
tu n'as pas le même
avis non je je pense que il faudrait pas
que le proonau soit remplacé par le
messena pour
obtenir ensuite un certain nombre de de
largesse auprès de auprès de certaines
administrations donc ou ou d'université
par exemple voilà allons-y comme ça donc
donc je crois que je crois qu'il y a la
question du messena euh qui concerne
toutes les entreprises parce que le
problème c'est que c'est pas que les
cabinets conseil qui qui qui font du
messen mais je je crois que le le plus
le le plus opérant c'est ce que c'est
l'amendement de la presse c'està-dire
interdire le les missions de conseil euh
une une fois qu'on a fait du messena et
je crois que comme ça on on va limiter
au moins cette façon de faire pour
obtenir justement des
marchés al je met VO cet amendement qui
vote
pour contre rejeté le suivant le 39
madame AUAU madame pardon interm oui
très rapidement en fait qui s'inscrit
dans le prolongement de de celui de
Madame Panau mais qui veille en fait la
présente loi elle n'interdit pas le
mesénat au cabinet de conseil il
faudrait à minima interdire aux
prestataires et consultants de fournir
des PR de conseil à un client ayant
bénéficié de mesena de leur part dans
les 5 années qui précèdent afin de
prévenir et empêcher
l'instrumentalisation du mesena à des
fins commerciales cela me paraît assez
sage et tout à fait dans le dispositif
de de de contrôle que qu'exerce la hatvp
par exemple par rapport à
des des changements de poste monsieur le
rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président il vous
étonnera pas je je vais pas donner
l'avis de Nicolas sensu que je connais
mais moi j'y suis
défavorable monsieur sensu vous y étiez
favorable tout à l'heure c'est ça oui je
suis favorable sur LEP ok je mets au
voix qui vote
pour contre
rejeté l'article 5 qui vare
pour contre adopté amendement 18
madame défendu 55 madame pan alors bon
c'est l' dont on parlait à l'instant sur
l'interdiction du recours au
prestataires et consultants privés sur
la réduction d'études d'impact
ou de au projet de loi euh bon c'est
assez évident pour enfin quand même
j'insiste dessus dans le rapport
notamment il est il est noté que des
consultants sont intervenus dans la
plupart des réformes des grandes
réformes du quinquena renforçant ainsi
leur place dans la décision publique
parfois en pouvant prioriser certains
scénarios plutôt que d'autres euh et
donc s'est développé en concomitant je
le disais avec le démand tellement de
l'État évidemment c'est aussi sur ces
études d'impact notamment que nous
prenons des décisions que nous faisons
des votes et donc il n'est pas
acceptable que ces études d'impact se
fassent autrement que par les services
de l'État et reste une prérogative
exclusive de l'État et non de de
prestataire et consultants privé sinon
la France devient une république de
consultants oui c'est un amendement
identique et dans le même esprit vise ch
le recours au cabinet de conseil pour la
rédaction de projet de loi l'état
dispose en effet des compétences propres
pour cette mission régalienne et puis on
l'a vu on a eu des exemples les
consultants interviennent beaucoup dans
la rédaction des différentes réformes ce
qui peut poser problème ça pose aussi
peut-être un souci d'argent public de
voir par exemple le recours par Édouard
Philippe à un cabinet de conseil pour un
montant de 30000 € pour sous-traiter
l'exposé des motifs de la loi transport
alors même qu'il y a un ministère entier
qui est consacré au
transport
bien les trois les trois amendements je
répondre au tro parce que trois
amendements tournent autour du même
sujet moi j'entends bien votre
préoccupation on a été
nombreux avoir été surpris d'apprendre
que l'étude d'impact d'un projet de loi
avait pu être rédigé à l'aide de
prestataire externe ça c'est une
évidence pour tout le monde mais je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur
l'article 2 de la proposition de loi qui
assure si on vote ce texte qui assure la
transparence en la matière lque des
consultants ont participé à la rédaction
de documents pour l'administration
celle-ci devra l'indiquer donc c'est à
ce titre là que je vous demand demande
un retrait ou sinon défavorable sur ces
trois
amendements monsieur su
oui juste pour rappeler que ce qui a été
identifié lors de la commission
d'enquête c'est un un sujet qui concerne
les avocats et que étant donné la non
intégration des professions juridiques
dans le d'application de la loi de toute
façon que l'on vote ça ou pas ça
n'empêchera pas les cabinets d'avocats
de faire les études d'impact et et les
exposés des motifs je je le rappelle
comme ça c'est c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
est la problématique qui qui à mon avis
existe donc je je je pense que c'est
mieux de le préciser comme ça même si
d'ors et déjà si un cabinet conseil
était amené à faire un exposé des motifs
d'un projet de loi il serait obligé de
l'inscrire dans les obligations de
transparence qui existent
au sein de la proposition de loi
aujourd'hui mais n'empêche que ça ne
concerne pas quand on fait appel à un
cabinet d'avocat pour pour pour pour
tenir ces ces sujets là Monsieur goselan
oui je crois qu'il y a un vrai vrai
sujet de fond on évoquait tout à l'heure
des des des secteurs un peu particuliers
comme le domaine régalien écoutez si la
rédaction de projets de
loi l'exposé des motifs
des études d'impact ne relèvent pas du
régalien par excellence si l'État qui
est quand
même à la tête de ce pays et par ce
démembrement d'administration par ces
ministères n'est pas en
capacité à avoir les compétences que ce
soit au Conseil d'État je rappelle qu'il
y a quand même au Conseil d'État des
juristes patentés enfin qu' on des
parcours et des carrière plutôt
exceptionnelle il y en a d'autres la
Cour des comptes qui peut apporter
d'autres éclairages et tant d'autres
organismes d'État je je je je crois que
si on flanche sur un de ces aspects on
est honnêtement à côté du cœur du
réacteur donc moi je suis tout à fait
favorable al peut-être qu'il faudrait
revoir la la la formulation le cas
échéant mais je suis tout à fait
favorable que dans ces cas-là l'État
soit au cœur du dispositif lui-même et
qu'il soit pas à l'extérieur et sil se
réassure sur certains sujets qu'il le
disent mais mais le principe c'est
l'État lui-même gère avec ses
administrations et ses
ministères
donc monsieur coulam j'avisi pas oublié
merci monsieur le Président oui il y a
quelques mois est sorti un reportage sur
la façon dont les lois étaient
fabriquées au au Parlement européen et
on y voit que les lobis ont largement la
main sur parfois des textes qui sont
intégralement intégralement fournis par
ces lobis à ces
mêmes députés européens donc on voit
bien que là on a quelque chose qui est
réellement une source de défiance des
citoyens ensuite vis-à-vis des lois qui
leur sont imposées et donc on ne voit
pas pourquoi effectivement on ne
viendrait pas euh se servir de toutes
les compétences qui euh qui sont celles
et euh de des politiques et euh de la
haute administration de notre pays pour
composer ces lois il est donc
complètement incongru de ne pas se
prémunir de de du risque d'avoir des
lois fabriquées par des euh lobby et des
euh
groupe
d'intérêt donc je mets au voix ses
amendements on commence par le 18 qui
vaêre
pour
contre il est adopté et donc il fait
tomber les
suivants le tien
Ccile alors attendez hop là le SO il
tombe le
69 le 69
tombe 69 82
Tom le 69 et le 82 tomb par
conséquent on passe à l'article 6
amendement numéro 40 de
Madame défendu
le 122 monsieur milen
122 l'article 6 il est
défendu c'est amendement de précision
alors je le précis mais donc vous êtes
défavorable à celui de Madame par
conséquent alors je mets au voix celui
de Madame avec défvorable qui vote pour
contre rejeté celui du rapporteur qui
vote pour
contre
adopté le 68 madame Pan Monsieur coulom
Merci monsieur le Président
oui lorsque l'on comprend que le la le
coût de toutes ces prestations externes
au fonctionnement de notre état
représente pratiquement le prix le coût
du fonctionnement de l'État français
c'est-à-dire euh présidence de la
République sénath euh Parlement euh
Conseil d'État et Conseil
constitutionnel ça a été évalué on va
dire à 1 milliard pour l'ensemble de
toutes ces institutions qui qui qui qui
gouverne notre pays donc on a finalement
quelque chose d'assez scandaleux c'est
que les cabinets conseil à eux seuls
coûtent aussi cher que toutes ces
institutions donc pour nous il n'y a pas
de justification au recours à une
prestation de conseil plutôt que le
recours à des ressources internes
monsieur le
rapporteur mais ça va peut-être vous
étonner monsieur le député mais je suis
favorable à cet amendement qui peut
permettre d'expliquer pourquoi la
prestation a ét externalisée ainsi mieux
appliquer la doctrine figurant dans la
circulaire du Premier ministre du 19
janvier 2022 donc j suis
favorable je mets au voix qui vote pour
Ben retire-le contre
adopté euh le 83 monsieur o ça oui il
s'agit que pour cet amendement euh de
renseigner le volume aaire des cabinets
de conseil employé par l'administration
euh les prestations facturées sont
difficilement quantifiables ce qui peut
donner lieu à des abus avoir un volume
horaire permet de le comparer aux
travaux effectuux et aussi d'avoir un
coût horaire de la prestation et de le
rendre comparable à l'emploi d'un
éventuel fonctionnaire
oui monsieur monsieur housoussin je sais
pas quoi vous dire honnêtement je sais
pas quoi vous dire parce que cette
information pour moi elle a pas grand
intérêt déjà pour commencer dans une
évaluation rendue publique en plus les
taux horaires en général sont connus
l'évaluation la surtout provocation à
indiquer si la prestation a été bien ou
mal réalisée c'est ça ça l'important
donc voilà bon ça et puis par il y a un
risque quand même d'atteinte au secret
des affaires donc voilà je suis
défavorable il est pas d'accord avec moi
allez-y bon je suis pas persuadé que mon
corapporteur soit d'accord avec ce cet
amendement le présent amendement en fait
propose de mettre en cohérence le régime
de publication au données ouvertes prévu
à l'article 6 avec le droit commun de la
communication des documents
administratifs et ainsi d'appliquer à
ces données les secrets mentionnés aux
articles
l311-5 et l311-1 6 pardon du code des
relations entre le
public pardon entre le public et
l'administration il prévoit également de
suspendre temporairement la publication
des évaluation lorsque celle-ci porte
sur une prestation de conseil
concourrant à l'élaboration d'une
décision administrative une fois la
décision prise ou si l'administration N
a pas manifestement n'y a pas
manifestement renoncé à l'expiration
d'un délai raisonnable l'évaluation
serait alors publiée cette précision
tant aligner le régime de publication de
ces informations avec celui prévu dans
le droit commun de la communication des
documents administratifs voilà je mets
au voix qui vote
pour
contre
adopté article 6 qui vre
pour contre adopté après l'article 6 le
125 monsieur le rapporteur mieur le
rapporteurs
alors l'amendement a pour objectif
d'étendre l'échamp de compéten de la
Commission de la CADA aux informations
dans la publication en données ouvertes
et prévu par la présente loi en fait
c'est aujourd'hui c'est pas forcément
évident donc c'est pour
que la CADA puisse avoir toute
possibilité de mettre mettre à
disposition du
public je mets au voix je mets au voix
qui vote
pour petite précision monsieur non c'est
le vote est par il est adopté l'article
7 qui vot pour contre adopté l'article 8
monsieur le rapporteur
ouis c'est simplement que le délai d'un
an nous paraît plus réaliste
ouais donc donc on est
favorable pour le rapport je le mets
pour le rapport je mets au voix qui
vaêtre pour contre adopté amendement
numéro
19 alors attendez parce que du coup il
fait non il fait
tomber le 19 le 85 le
20 c'est pas les mêmes délais
pardon si c'était rien àir c'est pas le
même dél pas le
même
attendez non effectivement madamemeer le
19 en fait j'aurais bien aimé que ce
soit allez-y allez-y nous proposons en
fait que le rapport soit remis tous les
ans au lieu de tous les 5 ans parce que
tous les 5 ans ça n'a plus de
sens monsieuroussin oui c'est la même
chose Monsieur le Président pardon c'est
la même chose le rapport demande à juste
titre au gouvernement de remettre pour
chaque ministère la cartographie de
ressources humaines disponibles en
matière de conseil en interne ou dans le
cadre inter
ministériel et les mesures prises pour
valoriser ces ressources humaines et
développer les compétences euh en intern
et les résultats obtenus le problème
c'est la périodicité cet amendement il
vise à rendre le rapport prévu au titre
de l'article 8 annuel pour que chaque
gouvernement soit comptable de sa propre
action et non de celle en fait du mandat
précédent par ailleurs cette perodicité
elle permet de réagir et non de
constater la politique qui a été mené
dans les 5 années précédentes parce que
si on observe une problématique il sera
un peu tard pour la corriger
alors Monsieur non pardon madame
hmeilleur le 20 qui est un repli à 2 ans
oui c'est un repli à 2 ans voilà
messieur les rapporteurs oui juste pour
souligner que évidemment 5 ans c'est
trop trop long annuel c'est compliqué
donc on vous propose de de tous
rassembler sur sur l'amendement numéro
20 de de madame intermeyer monsieur
milen ça n'a pas été proposé mais si au
cours de la séance il y avait un
amendement à 3 ans je préféreraai 3 ans
donc je mets au voix d'abord les deux
amendements identiques
85 je propose que le rapport annuel soit
retiré qu'on se rassemble sur le sur le
20 alors les deux sont retirés on va
mettre VO le 20 qui vot
pour contre il est adopté le 90
monsieur défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable VO pour contre
rejeté le 21
madame défendu monsieur le
rapporteur alors alors alors que je
reprenne mes
esprits pour moi c'est satisfait donc
demande de retrait
madamep moi je propose de de l'adopter
parce que aujourd'hui le rapport
l'article 8 ne comporte pas
explicitement d'éléments prospectifs
donc sur la stratégie je pense que c'est
une bonne
idée je le met au voix qui votre pour
contre
rejeté le 41 madame
teria défendu le 47 madame Ménard oui
merci très brièvement c'est un
amendement de précision afin de de nous
permettre de connaître les les raisons
objectives qui conduisent nos
administrations à recourir à des
prestataires privés plutôt qu'au
fonctionnaires de de l'État je vous
remercie messieur les
rapporteurs euh sur ces amendements je
crois que l'amendement 68 qui a été
adopté tout à l'heure l'amendement de
Madame pano satisfait cette cette
légitime
exigence alors je retrait ou défavorable
retrait ou défavorable donc je le mets
au voix le 41 qui vote pour
contre rejeté 47 pour contre rejeté 84
monsieur
merci monsieur le Président le principe
de fongibilité asymétrique établi par la
loi LOLF permet d'utiliser à l'intérieur
d'un programme des crédits économisés à
un titre au profit d'un autre titre à
l'exception des dépenses de personnel
dont les crédits peuvent être réaffectés
à d'autres titres mais qui elles-mêmes
ne peuvent être abondé par des crédits
prévus pour d'autres natures de dépenses
de ce fait le gestionnaire des crédits
ne peut utiliser ses entreg guuillemets
économie pour augmenter ses dépenses de
personnel à l'inverse il peut renier sur
les dépenses de personnel pour d'autres
poste de dépens ce principe s'applique
depuis 2006 et a pour but de maîtriser
les dépenses publiques le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il a un effet néfaste
dans une administration publique il est
beaucoup plus facile
d'externaliser que de recruter donc cet
amendement d'appel vise à étudier
l'impact de ce principe sur le recours
au cabinet de conseil et aussi les
surcûts qui seraient
liés alors moi sincèrement monsieur
loussin ça me paraît difficile à
appréhender et ça rendrait le
rapport visible et et peu opérationnel
donc j'ai mis un avis défavorable je
suis désolé j'ai pas fait autant
d'études que tout le monde mais là je je
vois pas comment je pourrais comprendre
ce genre de
chos met au
voix adopté après article 8 madame
interè le 22 défendu monsieur le
rapporteur alors euh défavorable euh je
crois que sur cette amendement ça pose
plusieurs difficultés certaines
infractions paraissent difficiles à
qualifier juridiquement tel que
l'obligation de remettre une évaluation
préalable correctement établi c'est
parce que d'autres infractions posent un
problème de cohérence l'amendement
associé des situations de pantouflage ou
de rétrop pantouflage à des situations
de recours à l'externalisation ce qui
n'est pas quand même la même chose et
d'autres enfin paraissent
disproportionnés le fait pour un
fonctionnaire de ne pas sanctionner un
contractant sans en préciser la raison
serait passible de sanction pénable je
donc on propose le retrait ou
défavorable
ok je défends 67 donc il s'agit tout
simplement de tirer les conclusions du
démelllement des politiques de
démentèlement de l'État qui ont déjà
commencé depuis la RGPP euh sous le
président Sarkozi et d'introduire ici un
article visant a reconstituer les
viviers de fonctionnaires qui auraient
pu être atteint par toutes les
entreprises d'externalisation ell-même
renforcé ensuite par le recours entre
autres au cabinet conseil
ouais j'entends bien monsieur Mathieu
mais euh c'est le principe est est beau
mais dépourvu de porter normative et la
cartographie des compétences réalisé à
l'article 8 permettra d'établir les
besoins de chaque administration et les
objectifs de réinternalisation donc
c'est un avis
défavorable oui je je pense aussi bon
que c'est un rapport on peut peut-être
regarder comment on fait mais on a quand
même un débat budgétaire qui fera
peut-être pas l'objet de 493 tous les
tous les ans donc peut-être que un jour
on pourra non c'était juste une boutade
on pourra peut-être discuter un jour
justement de de de quels moyens on donne
pour les politiques publiques et je
pense que c'est à ce moment-là qu'on
qu'on doit discuter de cela
oui merci monsieur le Président bon je
je j'entends bien la petite attaque RGP
PP l'entienne un peu antissarcosiste des
années de de de 2000 2007 2012
maintenant on remarquera quand même une
absence de lien évident suffit pas de le
proclamer pour que ça soit la réalité
euh la situation avec les cabinets de
conseil c'est'est particulièrement
dégradé chiffre à l'appui et le rapport
du du Sénat l'a bien démontré à partir
de 2017 et nous n'étions plus sous la
présidence de Nicolas Sarkozi mais sous
une autre dont je terrai le nom puisque
chacun a le nom en
tête merci monsieur le Président moi
j'entends ce qui vient d'être dit sur
les questions de loi de finances non
sans un certain optimisme d'ailleurs
mais en tout état de cause on si on veut
avoir de de l'expertise pour évaluer euh
les besoins en matière de fonctionnaire
il faut que cela soit anticipé justement
par par la Constitution et l'élaboration
de ce rapport qui permettrait d'avoir
une connaissance précise du nombre de
fonctionnaires manquant pour éviter euh
ce ce ce recours au au cabinet au
cabinet privé il est vrai aussi que
au-delà du du nombre de personnes dont
on aurait besoin il y a sans doute une
réflexion à mener sur l'attractivité de
la fonction publique et ce d'ailleurs de
manière générale puisque l'on voit bien
que le nombre de candidats au concours
baisse très très très sensiblement et ce
quel que soit le domaine de la fonction
publique que l'on que l'on
regarde oui pour exactement les mêmes
raisons que que l'amendement précédent
défavorable vous aurez l'article 8 avec
la cartographie
oui rapidement monsieur le Président il
s'agit de faire en sorte que les
consultants et prestataires de servicees
enfin que
l'externalisation ne ne s'affranchissent
pas des exigences minimales de
déontologie de la fonction publique et
nous proposons
d'intégrer rédiger ainsi et ajouter la
dignité l'impartialité l'intégrité et la
probité qui s'attache aux fonctionnaires
et qui me semble-t-il doivent s'attacher
également aux consultants travaillant au
sein de l'administration
oui merci Madame ununtermer dans la
rédaction actuelle du la proposition de
loi on prévoit que les prestataires et
les consultants assurent leur fonction
avec intégrité et probité on est
d'accord là-dessus ce qui nous paraît
suffisant j'ai du mal à voir comment on
juge la dignité l'impartialité je vois
un peu et d'autre part les consultants
peuvent ne peuvent toutefois pas être
assimilés à des agents publics il
fournissent une prestation
intellectuelle acheté par
l'administration donc c'est un petit peu
différent donc pour moi ce sera une
demande de retrait ou
défavorable la de la fonction publique
on peut l'exiger d'un cabinet de conseil
ça c'est ma première remarque ma
deuxième s'agissant de la dignité c'est
important aussi d'avoir parce qu'on
travaille au sein d'une administration
régalienne qu'on puisse avoir des règles
déontologie qui font appel à la dignité
et à l'impartialité dans les discussions
qu'on peut avoir avec les uns et les
autres représente une forme
d'administration et je pense que on ne
peut pas s'affranchir de ces règles
déontologiques et faire en sorte que les
fonctionnaires et ben ils doivent
s'organiser pour la dignité
l'impartialité l'intégrité et la probité
et les cabinets de conseil et ben ils
font seulement leur affaire de
l'intégrité et de la probité en excluant
les deux autres on interroge quand même
vraiment les règles déontologie monsieur
le rapporteur sensu oui euh la
proposition de loi vise à ne pas
confondre les consultants et
l'administration donc ça peut pas être
la mme même chose alors je vais je vais
vraiment extrapoler mais quand vous avez
quand vous avez une entreprise qui
intervient sur sur une route nationale
ou une autoroute non concédée pour le
compte de l'État est-ce que vous allez
leur demander la même
chose mais c'est pas un cabinet de
conseil mais ce sont des interventions
du privé pour le compte pour le compte
du public attention à ne pas mélanger je
je je le dis alors intégrité et probité
c'est c'est normal et il y a toutes des
règles de transparence et déontologie
qui sont qui qui
s'appliquent la question c'est qu'on ne
peut pas assimiler le consultant à un
agent public sinon si on fait
ça l'esprit de notre proposion de loi
tombe je vous le dis si si si si parce
que justement ça vise à mettre des
règles et des frontières et des frontièr
donc je je pense que c'est justement pas
une très bonne
idée
oui je pense que c'est un mauvais procès
qui est fait là la proposition
d'amendement de Madame ununtermeer en
fait il s'agit pas d'assimiler de ce que
je comprends les consultants externes
c'est de partir du principe que les
consultants des cabinets conseil comme
ils endossent une responsabilité à un
moment en tout cas un rôle d'orientation
des politiques publiques par les
conseils qui prodiguent concrètement ils
prennent des boulots de catégoria et
bien qu'il prennent les responsabilités
et les contraintes qui vont avec parce
que forcément ça n'est pas euh
assimilable au fait de poser un enrobé
sur une route parce que là vous avez une
position en tant que consultant externe
qui vous qui vous associe étroitement de
manière symbolique de manière régalienne
à l'action même de ce qui est l'action
euh au voilà au sens même de ce qui'est
l'action de l'État et donc que des
règles déontologiques supplémentaires
s'y associent euh ne ne paraît pas euh
voilà ça paraît pas inopportun moi comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
faut laisser aucun angle
mort
il s'agit là de
réécrire un petit peu le le texte du
Sénat sur la question du code de
conduite en fait on souhaite avec
l'amendement commun avec mon collègue
milien
que le code de conduite pour
l'administration soit fait une fois pour
toutes alors peut être révisé bien
entendu mais soit fait pour
l'administration et dans le même temps
ça permet de mieux prévenir le conflit
d'intérêt donc voilà c'est le le
principe c'est c'est le même état
d'esprit que au Sénat mais nous pensons
que c'est mieux
écrit faut pas que je dise ça au
sénateur par contre
oui merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit en cas d'accord cadre de prévoir
la signature de l'ensemble des documents
par les consultants au moment de
l'engagement de l'accord cadre et non
pas pour chaque attribution subséquente
qui ne sont que les conclusions de
l'accord
cadre
défavorable
oui en fait il s'agit là de du référents
déontologu moi je me suis inspiré de
l'audition de la direction générale de
l'administration et de la fonction
publique la DGA AFP qui propose
d'établir deux échelons dans l'examen de
la demande d'avis qu'ell viennent de
l'administration bénéficiaire du
prestataire ou des consultants dans un
premier temps vous avez le référent
déontologue qui est saisi et répond aux
demandes d'avis toutefois si le si le
cas le justifie ou s'il le juge
nécessaire ce dernier peut saisir la
hatatvp pour y répondre il nous paraît
important en matière de diffusion de
déontologie et bien d'apporter plus
précisément les modalités d'action qui
s'attachent au travail du référent
oui madame htermerer et le mesur de vous
faire plaisir donc voilà la précision
que vous avez suggéré dans cet
amendement a été suggéré par plusieurs
personnes que nous avons auditionné vous
étiez aux auditions donc vous l'avez
constaté ça permet en effet de
responsabiliser les administrations et
de ne pas surcharger la h TVP donc
faudra peut-être un peu préciser la
rédaction mais on se reparlera pour la
séance mais à à ce stade avis
favorable euh 62 64 monsieur le
Président parce que c'est c'est ils sont
identiques hein vraiment euh enfin
presque identique puisque il s'agit de
la remise de rapport l'un par la ch TVP
l'autre par le gouvernement afin de
s'assurer que attribuant cette loi
attribuant de nouvelles missions à
l'achat TVP celle-ci a bien les moyens
qui qui sont requis en organisation en
effectif et cetera pour pouvoir mener à
bien ses missions puisqu'il ne servirait
à rien de voter une loi et de renforcer
les normes pour pas mettre les moyens
qui vont
ensemble j'entends bien monsieur Mathieu
mais ce n'est pas du ressort de la
proposition de loi ci c'est du ressort
du projet de loi de finance donc on
reverra ça au moment de au moment des
discussions sur le projet de finance et
ça peut pas être dans le cadre de ce
projet de loi
oui je moi je comprends la volonté de
savoir si la htvp a les moyens de
d'assurer le le contrôle ou non et et le
surcroix alors très clairement
aujourd'hui il y a eu quatre équivalents
en plein je crois de de d'accepter à l'
chtvp ça fait pas énorme euh il faut
qu'on regarde comment se fait l'article
10 et comment il y a la subsidiarité
voilà très clairement comment les
déontologues des ministères des
administrations centrales des
établissements publics sont d'abord
saisis et ensuite peuvent saisir au cas
où l'h TVP parce que sinon on va
engorger et emboliser le système donc il
en est il est pas question d'emboliser
le système il est question d'être
efficace pour prévenir les conflits
d'intérêts alors monsieur Mathieu
s'agissant des moyens adéquates pour l'
ch TP je rappelle ce sont des demandes
de rapport des propositions de rapport
je bien entendre monsieur milen en effet
que un rapport euh un rapport du
Gouvernement au Parlement sur la
question serait peut-être plus du
ressort de loi de finan par contre je
suis pas d'accord sur le fait que la ha
TVP ne pourrait pas nous remettre de
rapport à nous sur les conséquences et
les besoins liés à l'adoption de cette
loi ou tout simplement sur son sur son
fonctionnement c'est pas incohérent
qu'une autorité administrative
indépendante puisse informer le
Parlement de ses besoins et de ses
manques
oui je crois qu'il y a il y a évidemment
un intérêt à à à mettre la chatvp au
centre du dispositif mais l'objet de la
PPL c'est pas non plus d'engorger
d'emboliser le la hachat TVP on sait
très bien qu'il y a quand même un
certain nombre de procédures qui sont
très lourdes euh chaque élu que nous
sommes et d'autres en France le le
savent donc évitons peut-être de
suradministrer dans ce domaine-là et
puis qui t'a confié effectivement un
certain nombre de missions nouvelles à
la htvp moi je souhaiterais qu'on soit
particulièrement vigilant sur certains
pantouflages euh qui peuvent affecter de
membres de cabinet qui qui passent dans
des cabinets de conseil cette fois-ci de
cabinets ministériel à des cabinets de
conseil voilà éventuellement des des
éléments qui me paraissent plus
pertinents alors sur les moyens sans
doute mais je sais pas si c'est vraiment
l'objet de la PPL que de le rappeler ici
mais c'est un sujet qu'il faut avoir en
tête évidemment
oui juste pour souligner que on peut
éventuellement avoir une démarche auprès
de la hatvp pour qu'elle l'intègre dans
son rapport annuel et de dire voilà
comment l'intégration des nouvelles
demandes euh suite à la PPL peuvent être
peuvent être traité ou ou traité plus ou
moins bien je je pense que c'est plutôt
par ce biais là qu'il faut qu'il faut
l'avoir et non pas par un port
particulier parce que ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens
l'amendement 62 qui vote pour contre
rejeté même vote pour le 64 on passe au
65 monsieur
Mathieu défendu monsieur toujours aussi
défavorable défavorable je mets au vois
qui vote pour contre rejeté le 9 article
9 qui vote pour contre adopté l'article
10 le 159 monsieur le
rapporteurend oui mais d'abord c'est
votre amendement j'arrive j'arrive
j'arrive lors de lors de nos travaux
préparatoires de nombreuses personnes
auditionnées nous ont fait part de leurs
craintes à propos de la déclaration
d'intérêt prévu à l'article 10 pour leur
caractère très général et exhaustif
cette obligation déclarative pourrait
porter atteinte à la liberté
d'entreprendre et à la vie privée des
consultants qui sont
constitutionnellement garantis c'est ce
que je vous désire en propos liminaire
donc cet
article a également des enjeux
opérationnels pour l'administration et
pour les cabinets suffit pas que
l'administration reçoive les
déclarations encore faut-il qu'elle
puisse les analyser et en tirer les
conséquences concrètes l'amendement que
je vous propose cherche à mieux cibler
les informations exigé et à rechercher
un meilleur équilibre entre la volonté
de prévenir les conflits d'intérêts et
le nécessaire respect de nos libertés
voilà en gros ce que je pouris vous dire
sur cet
amendement alors rajouter monsieur
housousin vous avez deux
sous-amendements oui tout à fait puisque
je pense que cet amendement va faire
tomber les suivants j'ai donc fait un
sous-amendement pour reprendre l'idée de
mon amendement précédent donc pour le
166 l'objet de cet amendement est
d'ajouter à la liste des personnes
effectuant une déclaration d'intérêt les
dirigeants des cabinets de conseil
actuellement l'article 1 parle des
prestataires qui sont définis à
l'article 1 comme étant des personnes
morales les consultants sont aussi
définis à l'article 1 comme étant des
personnes physique qui s'enengage à
titre individuel c'est-à-dire des
indépendants soit des personnes
physiques qui exécutent les prestations
de conseil pour le compte du prestataire
donc pour moi il y a il y a un trou dans
la raquette c'est qu'on laisse de côté
les intérêts des dirigeants du cabinet
de conseil d'ailleurs le gouvernement
l'a vu puisqueen séance au Sénat il
avait proposé
de remplacer le terme consultant par le
terme
dirigeant alors vos avis monsieur mieur
les rapporteurs sur ces deux
sousamendements ah pardon il y a
Monsieur l'amendement de Monsieur Pradal
qui est en discussion commune pardon
monsieur Pradal j'ai oublé j'ai pas
défendu le 167 ah je pensais vous aviez
terminé
mais très rapidement le 167 c'est un
amendement qui vise à ajouter à la
déclaration déontologique les
participation financière des conjoints
susceptibl de faire naître un conflit
d'intérêt en fait vous formez avec votre
conjoint
un foyer si votre foyer a des des
participations financières importantes
susceptibles de faire naître un conflit
d'intérêt il semble nécessaire pour nous
que cela soit déclaré monsieur Pradal
merci monsieur le Président nous allons
garder de la hauteur à nos débats en
citant Voltaire des lois que nous
suivons la première et l'honneur c'est
pour ça que je propose de substituer une
déclaration sur l'honneur aux
déclarations demandé au consultant dans
cet article
10 alors défavorable au sous-amendement
et à l'amendement de de philiip Pradal
et je veux expliquer euh un peu la
position parce qu'elle est elle est
compliquée euh on substitue à la
déclaration d'intérêt euh euh
généralisée euh une une déclaration euh
de une attestation d'absence de conflit
d'intérêt qui doit être documenté en cas
de risque de conflit d'intérêt auprès du
déontologue de l'administration c'est ça
le le principe de l'amendement milienne
alors
moi je comprends l'esprit non je pense
pas que je l'ai Cigné chers
collègu parce que je pense je comprends
l'esprit et en même temps je ne voudrais
pas que ce soit un
moyen d'amoindrir la déclaration
d'intérêt alors c'est c'est mais ça
s'entend parce que tous les consultants
son premier niveau et ceux qui n'ont pas
de conflit d'intérêt potentiel ça n'a
pas de sens de recueillir leurs données
personnelles donc c'est ça le le
principe et ça précise quand même un
certain nombre de de de
sujets sur la confidentialité sur la
conservation des des déclarations
d'intérêt sur on substitue la notion de
mission réalisée dans le même secteur
que la prestation de conseil celle de
prestation réalisé auprès d'un client
dont les intérêts entrent en
interférence avec ceux de
l'administration il y a un certain
nombre de clarifications mais mais le le
cœur du sujet c'est bien qu'il y a plus
de déclaration d'intérêt pour tous les
consultants à charge au déontologue de
voir s'il y a un conflit ou pas c'est de
dire vous avez une attestation de non
conflit d'intérêt de de d'absence de
conflit d'intérêt et puis si vous pensez
qu'il peut y en avoir vous êtes obligé
de dire au déontologue qu'il a la
possibilité aussi de regarder bien
entendu de regarder voilà c'est ça le
principe alors évidemment c'est un peu
plus souple que le texte du
Sénat par examiner les sous-amendements0
qui vote pour contre rejeté le 167
sousamendements également qui vote pour
contre rejeté et le 159 du rapporteur
qui vote
pour contre adopté donc il rédige
l'article il fait tomber les autres
amendements à l'article on en arrive à
l'article 11 en conséquence le 171
monsieur les rapporteurs
oui1 oui oui à l'article 11 l'article 10
a été rédigé entièrement par votre
amendement vas-y
vas-y alors là là aussi c'est les les
déclaration euh de démarchage et en fait
l'idée c'est de dire euh que elles sont
obligatoires quand la prestation est
ralisée par le par le le cabinet
c'est-à-dire que vous avez un cabinet
qui a un marché il est obligé de
déclarer quelle action de démarchage il
a fait celui qui ne l'a pas eu n'a pas
forcément vocation à avoir à déclarer ça
c'est tout c'est uniquement ça le
principe je mets au voix qui vote pour
contre adopté le suivant le 130
rédactionnel madame mer vous en avez en
identique non pas en identique en
discussion
commune merci monsieur le Président
c'est une correction légistique puisque
cet amendement rend opérant finalement
l'article 11 puisque personnes morales
énumérées à l'article 238 bis du code
général des impôts ne relève pas du
champ d'application de la loi pour la
plupart alors messieur les rapporteur
j'imagine vous préférez le votre à celui
de Madame meriller et bien non je vais
prendre celui de Madame Miller alors le
votre est retiré dans ces cas voilà donc
je me vois celui de Madame Miller qui
votre pour contre adopté le 102 mais
alors le 102 vient de l'adopter le 131
est un rédactionnel également je le mets
au voix qui vote pour contre adopter le
132 monsieur milen
c'est
moi ah si on veut pas revenir demain je
oui je suis précié sinon vous reviendrez
demain ça va être compliqué quand même
président
euh l'objet de cet amendement c'est de
renvoyer un décret en Conseil d'État
pris après avis public de la chatvp la
définition des modalités de publication
des informations relatives aux actions
de démarchage de prospection et et de
mén 1323 madame mer B si 132
ouis oui merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement entend permettre au pouvoir
réglementaire d'exercer sa compétence
pour fixer les modalités de publication
et de présentation des actions des
prestataires en matière de démarchage et
de prospection par essence la HVP est un
organe qui a plutôt vocation à être
consulté plutôt qu'à édicter certaines
règles quit à avoir un rôle important
dans un processus de consultation comme
je le disais qui a édicté des règles au
même titre que le juge ou le parquet
n'ont pas un rôle de création
législative mais plutôt d'interprétation
et une
sanction on va faire l'inverse de tout à
l'heure madame Miller je vais préférer
le mien et je vais vous demander de
retirer le vôtre retirer donc je
mets
demande de retrait ou défavorable
monsieur
diilippo alors non il est retiré par le
madamemeilleurend défendu monieur le
rapporteur demande de retrait ou
des alors cet amendement vise à
supprimer la possibilité de saisir la
Haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique ouverte à une
organisation syndicale de fonctionnaires
donc je propose de supprimer
l'articlealinéa 4 pour moi les
organisations syndicales ont pour
mission de représenter les intérêts des
agents publics et de défendre leurs
droits elle n'a pas pour mission de
participer au contrôle du respect par
les cocontractants de l'administration
et leurs obligations cela n'engage que
moi mais je suis favorable à mon propre
avis le 4 n'est pas a été retiré pardon
pour être précis le 134 monsieur sensu
en discussion commune oui il s'agit il
s'agit là de de préciser organisation
syndicale
représentative tout simplement parce que
sinon évidemment il y a tout un tas
d'organisations syndicales qui
pourraient saisir la h TVP en mettant
représentative on restreint largement le
champ et on est sur des organisations
syndicales qui travaillent avec les
pouvoirs
publics donc je met d'abord au voix
l'amendement de Monsieur milien qui vote
pour contre il est adopté il fait tomber
le
14 le 61 Monsieur
coulom Merci monsieur le Président donc
là je voudrais juste rappeler l'article
15 de notre Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen qui prévoit que la
société a le droit de demander compte à
tout agent public de son administration
voilà en l'absence d'Antoine léomand je
rappelle quelques extrait de notre bloc
constitutionnel et bien dans cet esprit
là il est tout à fait normal que les
citoyens puissent se saisir de cette de
ce droit à interpeller en quelque sorte
leurs agents public et leur politique
pour demander des comptes sur la bonne
gestion la bonne administration des
deniers publics en l'occurrence donc
nous souhaitons juste rajouter après
l'alinéa 6 tout citoyen majeur français
pouvant se saisir de cette question
alors monsieur le rapporteur il ne vous
étonnera pas monsieur cou que je suis
défavorable c'est beaucoup trop large et
étendu donc défavorable pour ma part
monsieur di Philippo j'ai des vrais
doutes par rapport à cet amendement
parce que je crois qu'on confond deux
choses le contrôle du citoyen sur la
manière dont est utiliser l'argent
public c'est sur le contenu des
prestations de conseil là-dessus il faut
beaucoup plus de de transparence sur les
domaines où il est utiliser mais mettre
en cause les personnes syst de manière
plus ou moins systématique qui procèdent
à ces à ces à ces prestations de conseil
souscouvert de déclaration d'intérêt à
la ha TVP ça peut servir plus de moyens
de pression à certain es organisations
militantes et ça n'apportera pas
forcément grand-chose sur le fond je
crois vraiment qu'ici on confond deux
choses à savoir le contenu des
prestations telles qu'elles sont
demandées et puis et bien si le ciblage
à un moment donné des personnes qui se
livrent àees à ses prestations ou à qui
on a commandé ses prestations pour
éventuellement faire pression sur
elle donc monsieur coulom et prend votre
oui bah ça ça ça ne m'étonne pas en
réalité cette réaction et et et votre
point de vue monsieur le rapporteur
puisque de toute façon lorsque notre
commission a été saisie par une par une
pétition déposée sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale pour le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne bien évidemment
une majorité de nos commissaires ici
présents s'y était opposé il y a donc
une forme de suspicion à l'égard du
peuple alors que là il ne s'agit pas de
de de de de faire du peuple un
accusateur mais plutôt quelqu'un qui
interpelle la classe politique et je ne
vois pas en quoi ceci vous fasse si peur
monsieur rapporteur oui je vais je vais
essayer de de faire mon centr triste je
fais mieux que Bruno milienne euh non je
je je comprends l'état d'esprit mais
gardons gardons la ligne de la
proposition de loi sénatoriale qui met
déjà plus de transparence qui met
beaucoup de transparence qui qui assure
et donc l'objectif c'est bien sur ce
recours au cabinet conseil parce que là
on est en train de de de de de dans T
les sens essayer de d'ouvrir des coins
sur d'autres sujets qui à mon avis ne se
règlent pas ici voilà donc je moi je je
pense que gardons l'état d'esprit de
cette proposition de loi assurons la
transparence assurons la déontologie euh
et puis on aura déjà fait un pas voilà
bien bien al monsieur gosin oui je crois
que le rapporteur a raison à vouloir
trop embrasser on va mal étreindre et
c'est pas ce que l'on recherche
évidemment moi j'ai pas de difficulté
avec le contrôle citoyen dans une
démocratie mais là on risque bien
finalement d'entretenir plutôt les
polémiques de jeter des noms en pâure et
c'est pas du tout l'objet entre de la
transparence mettre fin à l'opacité ou
jeter en pâure avec les risques que l'on
peut voir déjà parfois avérés
aujourd'hui je crois qu' faut pas aller
trop loin faut raison garder bien donc
je mets au voix qui vote pour contre
rejeté le suivant le 104 madame mid
défendu monsieur le
rapporteurtirô défavorable dem de
retrait enfin je vais m'en expliquer en
deux mots madame mer aujourd'hui la h
TVP peut déjà procéder à des
vérifications sur place dans lesc
professionnel des représentants
d'intérêt mais pas dans les locaux
affectés au domicile
privé donc là le régime serait bien
encadré pour réaliser un contrôle sur
place dans un local professionnel ou
Affé au domicile privé il lui faudrait
d'abord obtenir l'autorisation du juge
des libertés et de la détention donc
c'est pour ça que je vous demande le
retrait de votre
amendement retiré le 135 précision pour
contre adopté le 105 madame mer défendu
le 129 monsieur le
rapporteur alors
ouais c'est un amendement qui demande la
suppression de la procédure permettant à
la commission des sanctions de lever
certains
secrets un amendement qui a été adopté
en séance publique au Sénat rend la
commission des sanctions de l'hatvp
nvement créé compétente pour se
prononcer
sur le bien fondé du motif invoqué
lorsque le prestataire ou le consultant
oppose l'un des secrets mentionnés à
l'article 12 pour refuser la
communication d'une information une
telle disposition serait à mon sens
inédite parmi les autres autorités et
est inédite parmi les autres autorités
administratives indépendante par
ailleurs la procédure prévue manque de
précision elle n'indique pas dans
quelles conditions la commission des
sanctions peut prendre connaissance des
informations ne prévoit pas les
garanties applicables et ne précise pas
les suites qui lui sont données en
particulier nindique pas si les
informations concernées peuvent
finalement être connu de la TVP ou si
cela constitue un refus de communication
passible de sanction comp tenu de toutes
ces imprécisions je propose de la
supprimer
OK et donc par rapport à l'amendement de
Madame
mer le même non il sont discussion
commune retrait madame
Merill donc il est retiré je mets le 129
au voix qui vote pour contre
adopté le
129 le 33 monsieur Pradal merci monsieur
le Président il s'agit de poursuivre les
précisions en matière de procédure t
couvertees par vous-même en ouverture de
réunion et par le le rapporteur mienne à
l'instant en prévoyant que les mises en
demeure sont adressées à la structure et
non consultant à titre individuel et
prévoir de ne pas rendre publique les
mises en demeure il ne s'agit pas
proprement parler d'une sanction
puisquelle permet des régularisations et
donc de mettre fin à la publicité de la
mise en demeure monsieur rteur vous avez
un
sous-amendement ah oui
oui effectivement monsieur le le
président moi j'ai mis un sousamendement
pour préciser un petit peu les
choses pour préciser le 33 de Monsieur
Pradal pour maintenir la possibilité de
mettre en demeure un
consultant ça complète bah sinon sinon
ça ne marche pas sinon ça ne vole pas
monsieur Pradal donc favorable à votre à
votre amendement ça vole mais enfin pas
pour moi donc favorable votre amendement
avec
avec l'adoption de mon sous-amendement
monsieur madame monsieur Rambo pardon
pour l'amendement discussion commune le
35 oui merci monsieur le Président bon à
l'inverse il nous semble que le fait de
rendre public les manquements constatés
d'un prestataire ou d'un consultant
coupable de défaillance en terme de
respect des règles déontologique
comporte un pouvoir de dissuasion
intéressant cet amendement qui entend
rendre systématique cet affichage public
et supprimer la formulation actuelle
reposant sur la possibilité espère ainsi
dissuader le prestataire de réitérer les
manquements dont il s'est rendu coupable
par ailleurs un tel affichage aurait
pour intérêt d'informer les
administrations bénéficiaires de tes
prestation sur les comportements du
prestataire auquel il souhait faire
appel la connaissance de ce passé
pourrait en ce sens permettre aux
administrations de choisir le candidat
le plus ver vertueux
merci non moi je veux bien finir mais
par
contre plus bref quoi y on a quand même
un problème avec la démocratie ici he
parce que finalement ne pas vouloir
qu'il ait de publicité c'est vouloir
désinformer les
citoyens mais non alors alors dans ce
CASL effectivement je vous entends je
savais que vous répondriez ça et bien ça
veut dire que tout toute la presse crée
de la suspicion par définition elle
n'informe pas sur ce qui n'existe pas
elle informe sur des changements d'état
sur des modifications de comportement
sur des faits qui sortent de l'ordinaire
et qui doivent attirer notre attention
dans ces cas-là la presse la presse est
euh comment dire force la suspicion
permanente et bien nous nous considérons
que de la même façon que la presse
informe il faut rendre publ les
manquements éventuels ou les suspicions
de manquement après ce sera au juge à se
prononcer mais au moins nous sommes
informés de de de des directions dans
lesquelles il faut que les citoyens
investiguent pour comprendre comment
fonctionnent nos institutions et ce qui
les
représentent amendement 33 pardon le
sous-amendement d'abord du rapporteur le
69 qui vote
pour contre adopté le 33 du rapporteur
sous-amendé qui pour contre adopté c'est
tombé le suivant le 27 madame htermeer
défendu défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable défavorable non non
favorable pour que au moins le le mise
en demeure soit obligé de rendre compre
à latvp 15 jours sous 15 jours alors je
mets au voix qui vote
pour contre adopté le 59 et 60 en
discussion commune qui les défend
monsieur cou oui voilà les deux sont à
peu près similaires c'est une question
de seuil déclenchement puisque là nous
proposons de mettre en place un
dispositif de comment dire de saisine
par les citoyens via une pétition donc
c'est tout simplement comment dire
reproduire auprès de la h PTV les mêmes
mécanismes qui existent aujourd'hui dans
d'autres pour d'autres institutions
d'autres fonctionnements de notre état
donc il y a rien de très révolutionnaire
là-dedans mais nous proposons que les
citoyens puissent saisir la Haute
Autorité au travers d'un droit de
pétition alors ce n'est pas non plus le
grand soir puisque cette pétition doit
dans le l'amendement 59 atteindre les
100000 signatures et dans le suivant on
a diminué le seuil un amendement non pas
de repli mais plutôt ambitieux donc
voilà voilà ce que nous proposons un
droit de pétition pour la Haute Autorité
de la transparence de la vie politique
monsieur le rapporteur bien monsieur
coulom il vous étonnera pas que je suis
défavorable à vos deux amendements pour
les même raison que nous avons déjà eu
le débat sur les personnes et que ce
n'est pas l'Office de la
hatvp que de recevoir et traiter des
pétitions donc défavorable pour les deux
amendements je mets au voix le 59 qui
vote pour contre rejeté même vote pour
le 60 c'est l'article 12 qui vote pour
contre adopté l'article 13 le 5 monsieur
Pradal il s'agit d'expliciter la règle
que la mise en demeure est préalable à
toute sanction monsieur le rapporteur
demande de retrait au défavorable je
mets au voix qui vre pour
contre alors il y a un il y a un contre
un donc il est pas adopté mais il faut
voter le 136 rédactionnel qui vre pour
contre adopté 137 même vote 91 monsieur
Houssin
91 et 92 peut-être oui merci monsieur le
Président le 91 c'est un amendement de
cohérence qui vise à préciser que la non
communication de la déclaration des
intérêt dans sa version actualisée s'il
apparaît une modification substantielle
des intérêts détenus au cours de la
présentation de conseil et passible de
la M Amand administrative que la non
communication de cette déclaration et le
92 simplement il vise à rendre
obligatoire pour la commission des
sanctions de la HVP le fait de rendre
publiques les amendes administratives
prononcées ainsi que le fait d'exclure
l'intéressé de la procédure de passation
des contrats de la commande publique
pour une durée maximale de 3 ans en cas
de faute professionnelle grave monsieur
les rapporteurs est favorable sur les
deux donc le 91 qui vote pour contre
rejeté le 92 pour contre rejeté le 28
madame en fait il s'agit de de de de
remplacer la publication des sanction
par la publication de la décision
elle-même laquelle comprend la sanction
pécuniaère mais aussi la motivation de
la décision qui n paraît tout à fait
essentielle c'est une demande du
président de la HVP monsieur le
rapporteur oui madame madame je suis
favorable à à votre amendement on
demandera peut-être une petite précision
rédactionnelle pour la séance il
faudrait supprimer la référence
amendement ah oui j'ai un sousamendement
pardon
excusez-moi c'est la fatigue là j'ai
faim donc mon sous-amendement propose
une petite précision
rédactionnelle donc je vous demande de
d'accord bon ben voilà
donc alors on va voir si la Commission
est d'accord le 170 du rapporteur qui
vote pour contre adopté le 12 le 28
pardon sousamendé qui vote pour contre
adopt le alors le 13 monsieur
Pradal il est proposé de supprimer
l'alinée 11 parce qu'il est satisfait
par les dispositions l'article1 41-1 du
code de la commande
publque le 8 vousz compris monsieur pr
madame le 44 défendu défendu monieur les
rapporteur écoutez c'est
peut-êtrefatoire mais on va le garder si
vous nous le permettez on va regarder
pour la séance et donc pas
superfitatoire me dit l'administrateur
donc donc on va le conserver donc on
vous demande le retirer ou défavorable
et puis euh madame un termailleur même
même chose c'est une exigence du droit
européen la faute professionnelle grave
et donc il nous semble pas que il y a il
y ait besoin de le
confirmer retiré monsieur Pradal
monsieur Pradal il est maintenu donc le
8 qui vote
pour contre adopté avec ma voix il
adopté monsieur oui oui monsieur le
président
donc l'article 13 qui vote pour contre
adopté le 14 monsieur le rapporteur
rédactionnel qui va pour contre
adopté le 45 madame et le 4 45 et 30 les
deux sont défendus alors messieurs les
rapporteurs sur le prier demande de
retrait ou défavorable et sur le 30 je
crois que c'est la même chose c'est la
même
chose alors le 45 le voie qui vote pour
contre rejeté le 30 qui vare pour contre
rejeté le 93 monsieur housoussin défendu
défendu défavorable qui vote pour contre
rejeté le 14 l'article 14 qui vote pour
contre adopté l'article 15 amendement
numéro 9 monsieur le monsieur
Pradal alors allez-y attendez je vousend
allez-y même justification que pour
l'amendement 8 précédemment
défendu alors rapporteur euh
défavorable nous souhaitons que ce soit
précisé dans dans la PPL actuellement le
code de la commande publique prévoit que
des mesures pour exclure un candidat au
moment de la passation d'un marché en
cas de conflit d'intérêt mais il s'agit
d'un conflit d'intérêt portant sur
l'attribution du marché et non pas de
conflit d'intérêt qui peuvent surgir sur
la question déontologique avec les
consultants ou les prestataires alors je
mettre au voix qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il est
adopté l'amendement de
suppression
donc l'article 15 est supprimé article
16 le 142 monsieur rapportteur milien
oui c'est un amendement de suppression
de l'article
16 actuellement le code général de la
Fonction publique prévoit que la hatvp
soit systématiquement saisie en cas de
mobilité vers le secteur privé d'un
agent public qui exercerait un certain
niveau de responsabilité cette
obligation concerne jusqu'à 14000
personnes dans les fait les situations
particulières qui avaient été identifié
par la commission d'enquête du Sénat
sont déjà couverte si je comprends bien
l'objectif recherché par nos collègues
sénateurs cet article cherche à ouvrir
la saisine de la h TVP à tous les agents
publics qui réalise une mobilité vers ou
depuis un cabinet de conseil quels que
soient les responsabilités exercées par
ces Agen ça ferait peser mes chers
collègues sur la hatvp des obligations
de contrôle bien trop importantes ce
n'est pas souhaitable et cela pose un
problème de principe pourquoi contrôler
plus spécifiquement les mobilités vers
les cabinets de conseil et pas vers
d'autres secteurs tout aussi sensibles
enfin la rédaction de cet article pose
problème au niveau légistique il me
semble qu'en l'état il est
imparfaitement rédigé et n'a pas de
portée pour toutes ces raisons de forme
comme de fond je vous propose sa
suppression alors je le mets au voix qui
votre
pour contre adopté
oui il est largement adopté monsieur
franchement alors il est supprimé
l'article après l'article 16 le
34 monsieur rambau
oui merci monsieur le Président donc cet
amendement pour va pouvoir paraître un
peu dur mais quelquefois il faut faire
preuve d'autorité dans ce pays enfit cet
amendement entend déchoir de leur statut
de fonctionnaire toute personne ayant
livré des informations sensibles sur
l'administration dans laquelle elles ont
eu l'occasion d' vrer de trop nombreux
exemples récents de personnalités au
servic de l'État passés dans le secteur
privé doivent nous alerter sur les
dangers relatifs à de tels transfuges il
est des administration où la délicatesse
des informations prodiguées doit
nécessairement s'accompagner d'un devoir
de discrétion de la part du
fonctionnaire cet amendement vise en ce
sens à empêcher la livraison
d'informations confidentiell par
d'anciens fonctionnaires auprès de
sociétés
privées alors monsieur le
rapporteur personnellement défavorable
monsieur le
oui moi je je suis contre le pentouflage
excessif évidemment et les conflits
d'intérêts mais euh le statut de la
fonction publique prévoit déjà un
certain nombre de de sanctions euh de
droits et devoirs et il me semble que
c'est parfait ement couvert par par tout
cela et que le le le l'amendement en
réalité est satisfait he et très
largement oui simplement il s'agit
d'imposer une obligation déclarative au
militaires qui après avoir exercé des
fonctions présentant une sensibilité
particulière ou requérant des
compétences techniques spécialisées qui
souhaite réaliser des prestations de
conseil au bénéfice d'un cabinet de
conseil privé dans les politiques
publiques ayant son siège en dehors du
territoire national ou son contrôle
étranger c'était l'article 40 de la LPM
monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur
monsieur Houssin je seraai défavorable
parce que votre votre amendement est
largement satisfait par l'article R
4122-14 du Code de la défense je met au
voix qui vre pour contre rejeté article
17 le 143 amendement rédactionnel du
rapporteur qui va tre pour contre adopté
le 48 n'est pas défendu le 74 monsieur
Lopez ligori merci monsieur le président
euh au cours de leur prestation auprès
des administrations des collectivités de
l'État les cabinets de conseil peuvent
recueillir des données ces données qui
sont potentiellement sensibles
stratégiques personnelles identifiantes
euh et qui pourrait pour le coup être
par exemple des données de santé puisque
le gouvernement a eu un recours assez
extensif au cabinet de conseil tels que
minse ou a ceinture pendant la crise du
covid et dans le texte malheureusement
il n'y a aucune mesure de protection
contre une quelconque
extraterritorialité de droit extra
eururopéen et le le Cloud Act par
exemple je pense à certaines
législations de pays extrauropéens comme
les États-Unis qui ont des législations
donc le Cloud Act qui est une véritable
menace puisque les autorités publiques
américaines peuvent accéder aux données
hébergées en Europe c'est d'ailleurs
écrit noir sur blanc sur le rapport du
Sénat sur les cabinets de conseil il
faut que nous prenions le le problème à
bras le corp et donc nous demandons un
cloud français ou européen pour stocker
les données de l'administration
française ce cloud devra reprendre les
critères du référentiel secum cloud de
Lancy qui est relatif à l'immunité
contre ce type d'ingérance étrangère et
c'est un amendement de bon sens qui va
dans le sens de notre souveraineté et en
plus qui soutient notre industrie
numérique merci le 88 monsieur oui très
rapidement puisque mon collègue a déjà
très bien expliqué l'esprit de ses
amendements il vise à assurer des
garanties de sécurité et de protection
des données en conformité avec le droit
européen le point précis cité porte sur
la protection vis-à-vis du droit
extraeuropéens les États-Unis notamment
ont mis en place des législations
permettant à leurs autorités d'accéder
dans certains cas aux données stockées
par des entreprises soumises à leur
droit il s'agit de s'en
prémunir défavorable sur des amendements
ça poserait de vraies difficultés pour
les TPE et les PME en plus nous
proposons au contraire de vos
amendements l'article 18 d'alléger les
obligations en matière de sécurisation
des données lorsque cela n'est pas exigé
par la nature de ces données voilà donc
défavorable sur le monsieur goselin oui
il y a quand même un vrai un vrai sujet
hein c'est pas la première fois qu'on
l'aborde sur la souveraineté numérique
sur les clouds souverains il y a une
mission
d'information ici que j'avais mené avec
Philippe latombe vous le savez d'autres
d'autres collègues et à chaque fois on
botte en touche en disant il y a pas de
problème tout va bien et cetera mais en
réalité tout va pas si bien que ça et on
a régulièrement des des difficultés je
rappellerai simplement ce qui s'est
passé pendant le le le l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avec la plateforme des données
de santé alors qui n'était pas créé que
pour le covid certes mais qui confiait
quand même largement nos données de
santé pas n'importe lesquel à Microsoft
enfin donc c'est c'est bien gentil mais
on a du droit américain qui est
applicable avec des injonctions de
données de données parfois et donc il
faut absolument qu'on s'inscrive dans le
cadre du rgpd et cette souveraineté elle
est nécessaire alors la l'amendement
lui-même ne ne satisfait pas
nécessairement tout ça mais je veux je
souhaite vraiment le rappeler c'est une
ardente obligation à laquelle on ne
répond pas nécessairement largement et
tout le temps met au voit les
amendements pardon monsieur Lopez igurri
oui malheureusement à chaque fois que
c'est pas la première fois qu'on qu'on
dépose des amendements sur le saum cloud
on nous répond qu'il va y avoir un
problème avec les TPE PME aujourd'hui on
a des des entreprises françaises qui
sont au niveau qui sont au niveau des
Microsoft qui sont au niveau des Google
en tout cas dans leur dans leur constru
de leur cloud je pense à des OVH je
pense à des scalway on aurait tout
intérêt à se diriger vers ces
entreprises et la deuxième chose c'est
en refusant ce type d'amendement nous
mettons à disposition des Américains
nous mettons à disposition d'entreprises
étrangères des données de l'état et
c'est soit de de du du je dirais pas de
l' compétences mais en tout cas c'est on
est on est à la limite de la trahison
merci alors le 74 qui votre pour contre
rejeté 88 pour contre rejeté le 163
monsieur le
rapporteur oui monsieur le Président
merci le présent amendement prévoit que
le cabinet de conseil remet à
l'administration bénéficiaire les
données collectées auprès de
l'administration ainsi que les
traitements réalisés sur ces données
avant leur
suppression je mets au voix qui vaêtre
pour contre adoptter le 155 monsieur le
rapporteur l'amendement complète
l'amendement précédent c'est une
déclaration attestant que les données
ont bien été détruites ce qui est
possible selon Lancy qui nous a expliqué
que comment faire je mets au voix qui
vote pour contre adopté le 32
madamemeill oui il s'agit par cet
amendement monsieur le Président de
d'introduire un contrôle
aléatoire par
laacnil s'agissant des données du de la
gestion des données par le consultant ou
le
prestataire monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable madamemaa parce que l'esprit
du texte c'est que l'acnil intervient en
appui de l'administration lorsque
celle-ci a un doute sur le respect de
l'obligation de suppression ou de non
réutilisation des données donc je pense
qu'il faut conserver la saisine par
l'administration donc défavorable à ce
titre je mets au voix qui vote pour
contre
rejeté le 144 rédactionnel qui vare pour
contre adopté le 164 monsieur le
rapporteur
oui un amendement
euh qui regarde les obligations prévues
à l'article 17 l'interdiction de
réutiliser les données et les
obligations de les supprimer qui n'est
actuellement pas sanctionné donc le
présent amendement prévoit que lorsque
ces obligations ne sont pas respectées
laacnil en informe l'administration
bénéficiaire qui peut alors saisir la
Haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique au finin d'infliger une
sanction
administrative le 168 en sous-amendement
monsieurouss
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit de
remplacer au second alinéa les mots peut
saisir par saisi ce sous-amendement vise
en fait à rendre systématique la saisine
de la hatvp par laacnil dans le cas
énoncé à l'article 10 alors messieurs
les rapporteurs sur le sousamendement
monsieur
housoussiny défavorable au
sous-amendement et favorable à mon
amendement donc d'abord le
sous-amendement qui vote pour contre
rejeté l'amendement qui vote pour contre
adopté l'article 17 qui vote pour contre
adopté l'article 18 le 107 Madame M
madame monsieur goufiervante défendu
défendu monsieur le
rapporteur article l'amendement 107
l'article 18 oui euh cet amendement vise
un petit peu à remplacer l'article 18
actuel en précisant comment la sécurité
informatique est est assurée ça nous
semble un peu plus opérant euh plutôt
que de demander à à toutes à tous les
prestataires d'avoir un audit de
sécurité qui coûte fort cher et donc là
ça risquerait d'exclure les les petits
consultants les petits cabinets donc
nous serions favorabl à cette à cette à
la rédaction de cette alinéa 2 je le
mets au voix qui vatre pour contre
adopté l'article 18 qui vote pour contre
adopté amendement après le 19
rédactionnel qui vote pour contre adopté
amendement 108 monsieur gouff
Valente endu monsieur le
rapporteur
oui bon monsieur milen est favorable moi
je je vais faire appel à la sagesse
parce que je pense que sur les contrats
en cours c'est plutôt embêtant de
d'appliquer de nouvelles
règle bien je mets donc au voix qui vre
pour contre il est adopté il supprime
l'article 19 nous avons terminé donc je
mets au voix l'intégralité de la
proposition de loi qui vote pour contre
adopté